WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE HEARING TO ORDER THE
TEN OH FIVE WE ASK THAT THE
REMAINING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE REPORT FROM
FOUR FOUR FOUR SO WE CAN
CONDUCT TODAY'S BUSINESS WELL
FOR TO A VERY PRODUCTIVE
HEARING TODAY- THING THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM- IF I
ENCOURAGE ALL MEMBERS TO PLEASE
REPORT FOR FORCE OF A
CONCEPTUAL WARM TO CARE OF
TODAY'S BUSINESS. A BECAUSE WE
DID OUT OF A QUORUM WE WANT
PARADE AS A SUB COMMITTEE INTO
A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED. I'D
LIKE TO NOTE AS YOU CAN SEE ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY HAS WITHDRAWN HIS
REQUEST TAUGHT AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO NOTE ONE CHANGE TO THE
PRINTED AGENDA ASSEMBLYMEMBER
C. GARCIA'S AUDIT REQUEST
TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE ONE
THREE. REGARDING THE CITIES OF
HUNTINGTON PARK IN COMMERCE IS
NO LONGER HONOR CONSENT
CALENDAR IS NOW ON A REGULAR
CALENDAR. SO WE NOW HAVE SEVEN
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO QUICKLY
MENTION THAT WE HAD THREE
INFORMATIVE. AND PRODUCTIVE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS LAST MONTH
REGARDING THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA HATE CRIMES AND
QUALIFIED MEDICAL EVALUATORS
THANK YOU MEMBERS THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THOSE HEARINGS
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENDANCE AT THOSE AS WELL.
AND ALSO LIKE TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE IS AWARE THAT OUR
COMMITTEE WILL BE HOLDING O
JOINT. OVERSIGHT HEARINGS OVER
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS NEXT
WEDNESDAY AT ONE THIRTY WILL BE
WE WILL BE HOLDING AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON THE STATE'S
PREPARATION. FOR NATURAL
DISASTERS AS RELATES TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS THEN
THE FOLLOWING TUESDAY MARCH
TENTH AT THREE PM WE WILL BE
HOLDING A JOINT OVERSIGHT
HEARING. ON A RECENT ON A
REPORT ON CHILDHOOD LEAD
LEVELS. WITH THAT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN TO ON TODAY'S
AGENDA THIS IS AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER ONE PRESENTATION BY THE
STATE OFFERED. TALK ABOUT STATE
BOARD A IN PRAGUE. I DON'T.
HE'S WHEN YOU'RE RIGHT. MEMBERS
THE WRECK MY NAME TO LES HOWELL
ME TODAY IS MIKE TO HE A DAY
STATE AUDITOR IN THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND HE BE TO A
BIT ABOUT OUR LOCAL HIGH RISK
PROGRAM A DASHBOARD ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT THAT WE DO AND LAUNCH
LAST OCTOBER THAT REALLY LED TO
THE RE THAT WE BEFORE YOU TODAY
SO I AS I AFTER I. MY STATUS
MISTER TILDEN WILL JUST THREE
MINUTES ARE TALKING A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HOW WE CONSTRUCTED
THE DASHBOARD AND WHAT LED US
TO THE PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE CURRENTLY OPEN AUDITS
IN PROGRESS NINE THOSE ARE
AUDIT THE- JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE APPROVED WE
HAVE TO STATUTORY AUDITS THAT
WE ARE CURRENTLY CONDUCTING.
AND AN APPLE YOU MAY. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE SIXTEEN RICK.
OF SOME ON A CONSENT. TODAY
THAT COMMITTEE WILL BE CAN. OUR
RESOURCES ALLOW US TO START
BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE SIXTEEN
AUDITS- MANY OF THOSE WILL BE
ABLE TO START THIS NEXT MONTH
IN MARCH WE HAVE SEVEN TEAMS
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE WE'VE
BEEN. PUTTING OUT A LOT OF
REPORTS IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS
SO WE DO HAVE TEAMS THAT WILL
BE READY AND WAITING FOR ANY
AUDITS THAT. THE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE APPROVES TODAY AND
THEN IN APRIL MAY AND JUNE WILL
BE ABLE TO START A AN
ADDITIONAL NINE OUT OF TEN IT'S
TWO THREE AND FOUR BUT THE-
VAST MAJORITY WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO START IN MARCH. AS YOU KNOW
MEMBERS THE WAY OUR LOCAL HIGH
RISK PROGRAM WORKS IS OF COURSE
ANY REQUESTS THAT MEMBERS HAVE
SUBMITTED THAT ARE APPROVED BY
THIS COMMITTEE GET FIRST
PRIORITY SO WE WILL. USE OUR
RESOURCES TO START JOINT
LEGISLATIVE ART LEGISLATIVE
QUESTS PRIOR TO STARTING THE OF
OUR LOCAL HIGH RISK WORK. WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIR. ONE OTHER.
WE DO. RESOURCES THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE REST OF THE
YEAR NOW WHAT I HAVE MY STAFF
DO MY DEPUTIES. ARE GIVE ME AN
ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY AUDITS WE
CAN COMMENCE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR SO THE COMMITTEE HAS AN
IDEA OF. AT THE NEXT HEARING
WILL THERE BE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE SO AS I SAID WE HAVE
RESOURCES TO START AUDITS
SIXTEEN AUDITS BETWEEN NOW AND
JUNE- IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THE
NEXT HEARING WILL LIKELY BE IN
AUGUST. AFTER YOU COME BACK
ADDITIONAL FOURTEEN TEAMS
AVAILABLE. ARE TO CONDUCT AUDIT
WORK WE DO HAVE SOME STATUTORY
AUDITS THAT WE HAVE TO START WE
ALWAYS DO A PROCUREMENT AUDIT.
FOR JUDICIAL COUNCIL I HAVE
FACTORED THAT IN SO THOSE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DRESSED SO WE
WOULD HAVE. FOURTEEN TEAMS THAT
COULD START OFF BETWEEN AUGUST
AND THE END OF THE FOR THE
CALENDAR YEAR. SO I WANT. TO
THE COMMITTEE THAT DEPEND. ON
MANY CUBA PROOF TODAY. WE WERE
HAVE RESOURCE AVAILABLE FOR
YOUR AUDITS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ASKED TODAY. WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO IT UP MR
CHILDREN IN HE WILL SAY AS AT
WE'LL KEEP IT TO. TWO TO
MINUTES. ARE TALKING OF ARE
LOCAL PROGRAM IN THE F. AFTER.
THROUGH UP TOGETHER THE DATA.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU RIGHT
.COM ONE MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE AS MISS
IN THE ON THE TALK TO YOU
BRIEFLY ABOUT OUR LOW HIGH RISK
FOR. WE RELEASE THE DASHBOARD
TALKED IN A TERMS BUILDING WHAT
WE DO IS WE ANALYZE THE FOR THE
HEALTH OF HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
pREVIEWING AUDITED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS AND OTHER
INFORMATION. IN DOING THAT WE
EVALUATED THE FISCAL HEALTH OF
EACH CITY USING A SET OF TEN
FINANCIAL INDICATORS AND THE
INDICATORS WERE DESIGNED RIDLEY
TO ASSESS EACH CITIES CASH
POSITION. OR ABILITY TO PAY ITS
BILLS IN THE SHORT TERM OR THE
COMING YEAR WE ALSO LOOK AT THE
DEBT BURDEN OF EACH CITY
ASSESSING ITS ABILITY TO PAY
ITS BILLS IN THE LONG TERM. IN
RELATED TO THAT WHAT THE
SUFFICIENCY OF EACH CITIES
FINANCIAL RESERVES THAT WOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO COVER ANY
UNEXPECTED COSTS. AND WE LOOKED
AT REVENUE TRENDS TO SEE IF THE
GROWTH IN THOSE REVENUE TRENDS.
WOULD KEEP PACE WITH INCREASING
COSTS INCLUDING INCREASING
RETIREMENT COSTS. FINALLY WE
LOOKED AT EACH CITY'S ABILITY
TO PAY FOR THE RETIREMENT COSTS
OF ITS EMPLOYEES. SO WE WENT
THROUGH THE ANALYSIS AND BASED
ON THE RESULTS OF THE TEN
INDICATORS WE CATEGORIZE EACH
CITY. AS HAVING LOW. MODERATE
OR HIGH FISCAL RISK IN ADDITION
WE RANK ALL FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE CITIES. BASED ON
FISCAL HEALTH FROM HIGHEST RISK
TO LOIS RISK. AND IS MISS HOW
INDICATED FOR THE CITIES WHICH
ARE SUBJECT TO OUR PROPOSALS
TODAY WERE AMONG THE TOP TEN
FINANCIALLY RISKY CITIES IN THE
STATE. WHAT WHILE THE FIFTH
CITY WHICH IS WEST COVINA WAS
IN THE TOP TWENTY. SO BASED ON
THE RESULTS OF THE DASHBOARD
AND ARE ON SIDE ASSESSMENTS
THAT EACH OF THE FIVE CITIES.
WE DETERMINED THAT THE CITIES
ARE DEMONSTRATING VARIOUS
HIGHER RISK CHARACTERISTICS AND
I WANT TO WALK THROUGH THOSE.
VERY BRIEFLY. ONE EACH OF THE
CITIES IS FACING INCREASING
PENSION COSTS NOT ONLY THAT BUT
THESE PENSION COSTS ARE VERY
HIGH RELATIVE TO THE ANNUAL
REVENUES IN EACH CITY COLLECTS.
THEY ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
LIABILITIES FOR POST EMPLOYMENT
HEALTH BENEFITS FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND MOST OF THESE
CITIES HAVE SET ASIDE VERY
LITTLE OR NO FUNDING TO PAY FOR
THESE BENEFITS. WE ALSO LOOK
THE CASH FLOW AND DETERMINE
THAT MOST OF THE CITIES HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CASH FLOW PROBLEMS
AN INSUFFICIENT LIQUIDITY TO
PAY THEIR BILLS IN THE NEAR
TERM. RELATED TO THAT MANY OF
THESE CITIES HAVE INSUFFICIENT
FINANCIAL RESERVES THAT THEY
COULD USE TO FUND THEIR
OPERATIONS IN THE EVENT OF A
FISCAL EMERGENCY OR ANY KIND OF
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. SOME OF
THE CITIES ALSO HAVE HIGH
LEVELS OF DEBT. AGAIN RELATIVE
TO THEIR ANNUAL REVENUES WHICH
IS GOING TO STRAIN THEIR
ABILITY TO SERVICE THAT DEBT.
AND FINALLY WE TOOK A LOOK AT
EACH CITIES REVENUES AND WE
FOUND THAT SOME OF THESE CITIES
HAVE FLAT OR EVEN DECLINING
REVENUES. WHICH IS TROUBLESOME
GIVEN THAT THEY HAVE INCREASING
COSTS- WITH THAT'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DASHBOARD. THANK YOU LET ME ASK
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS. SENATE
ROTH LEADING MISTER CHAIR I'M
JUST CURIOUS TO FIND IN ANY OF
THE CITIES THAT ARE IN IN THE
HIGH RISK CATEGORY- HAVE USED
TO PENSION OBLIGATION BONDS TO
ATTEMPT TO DEAL WITH. COSTS OF
PENSIONS OTHER POST RETURN
BENEFITS. YES WE ACTUALLY DID
FIND THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE IN THE
HIGH RISK CATEGORY AS WELL AS
IN THE MODERATE RISK CATEGORY
THAT HAVE USE PENSION
OBLIGATION BONDS TO BASICALLY
FIND THEIR UNFUNDED RETIREMENT
OBLIGATIONS WHEN WE CALCULATE
ONE OF OUR INDICATORS ASSESSES
THE MAGNITUDE OF THESE UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITIES AND WHEN WE
DO THAT WE INCLUDED. THE
PENSION LIABILITY PLUS ANY
OUTSTANDING PENSION OBLIGATION
BONDS. THE TO THE EXTENT THAT
IT. FITS IN WITH YOUR STANDARD
PROTOCOL AND THE ISSUES THAT
YOU ADDRESS AS A MATTER OF
COURSE- WHEN YOU CONDUCT THESE
OUT ITS I WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN IN- IN READING YOUR-
COMMENTARY ON THE EFFICACY. OF
PENSION OBLIGATION BONDS- I
ASSUME THAT YOU CAN CHOOSE.
PERIODS OF TIME WITHIN WHICH
THE BONDS ARE ISSUED AND
REPAYABLE AND- THAT SORT OF
COMMENT AGAIN I DON'T KNOW IF
IT FITS WITHIN THE PARAMETERS
OF WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU CONDUCT
A HIGH RISK GOT IT BUT IF YOU
IF IT DOES I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN. IN HEARING FROM.
OUR MODERATOR. YOUR VIEWS ON
THE EFFORT OF PENSION
OBLIGATION BONDS UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF SOME OF THESE
CITIES INCLUDING THE HIGH RISK
ONCE YOU'RE FACING. IT WOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE IN THE SCOPE OF
THE AUDITS THAT WE DO AND
THAT'S WHY WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE. WHEN WE LAUNCHED THE
DASHBOARD THAT WE HIGHLIGHTED
THAT INFORMATION FOR YOU. UP
THE DATA AND WHERE THEY CAN GO
IN AND IDENTIFY CITY ARE BAY.
TAKE AN ABA AT. IF A BOND.
WHERE THE YOU KNOW A ARE
PASSING THAT OP O TO OTHERS AT
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A PRACTICE
BUT WE WERE AB LOOK AT THAT
WHEN WE CAN THE ON AND WOMEN
COME MISSED THE AYES THE WITH
THE FOR A AND FIFTY WHATEVER IT
IS EIGHTY PLUS PLUS IT IS THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MANY OF THEM ARE BUT
ONE STEP AWAY FROM THE- HIGH
RISK OR ALMOST HIGH RISK LIST
AND THEY MIGHT BENEFIT FROM
READING YOUR COMMENTS. BEST
PRACTICES CERTAINLY CENTER
THAT'S WHAT WE WE'RE INTENDING
WITH THIS DASHBOARD AND WE HAVE
ONE YEAR'S WORTH OF INFORMATION
ON THE DASHBOARD AND THE INTENT
IS TO HAVE THIS BE A
LONGITUDINAL UP RESOURCE FOR
CITIES FOR RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA TO SEE HOW WELL
THEIR CITY IS DOING IS THEY'RE
CITY HEADING INTO. A PORT BAD
DIRECTION OR ARE THINGS GETTING
BETTER SO WE INTEND TO POPULATE
THE DATABASE LATER THIS YEAR
WITH ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
WITH RESPECT TO FINANCES AND WE
HOPE THAT CITIES. WILL LOOK AT
THE DASHBOARD AND SEE WILL THIS
CITY SEEMS TO BE DOING WELL
WHAT WHAT ARE THEY DOING
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE ARE DOING
WHAT ARE THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
THERE THINGS WE COULD LEARN
FROM THAT PARTICULAR LATEST THE
NORTH HEALT AND HOPEFULLY AS-
THE BILL. CALIFORNIA'S WILL
TAKE YOUR REPORT WILL SHARED
WITH THE OTHER CITIES
PARTICULARLY AS YOU. INCLUDE
COMMENTARY ON FINANCIAL
PRACTICES BEST PRACTICES SOME
THAT ARE NOT SO GOOD. I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT'S OKAY I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU DO THANK
YOU MADAM ON THANK YOU FOR THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. FOR CLARITY
I APPRECIATE THOSE C<c.cyan> IN</c>
THAT BE BECAUSE THIS IS A CAN
DOT IT FROM PREVIOUS CAR. WELL
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY CONTINUED
AUDIT MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
DASHBOARD WAS AN ANALYSIS WE
DID WE- MY STAFF MIKE STAFF OUT
WENT OUT AND LOOKED AT IT WE
WENT TO ALL A LOT OF THE CITY'S
WEBSITE WE WENT TO OTHER
RESOURCES. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
COLLECTED OPTED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS AND DID THE ANALYSIS
WHAT WERE WHAT THE DAY
COMMITTEE WILL BE CONSIDERING
TODAY IS AS WE NOTIFIED YOU WE
WENT AND SELECTED AS MR
CHILDREN INDICATED. SOME OF THE
CITIES THAT RANK VERY HIGH AS
FAR AS FISCAL DISTRESS A LOT OF
THOSE INDICATORS THEY WERE HIGH
RISK SO WAY OUR STATUTE WORKS
IS WE GO OUT WE NOTIFIED. YOU
AND THE AND THE VICE CHAIR THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING ASSESSMENT
BASED ON THAT ASSESSMENT THEN
WE PUT A PROPOSAL TOGETHER. IT
WILL STAY AYE. WE THANK.
THEY'RE SICK. PROBLEM WE WENT
AND GAVE WITH THIS. I DIDN'T
HEAR. THAT WERE CAN US THAT
THEY HAD EVERYTHING UNDER
CONTROL OR HAD ADEQUATE PLANS
TO DEAL WITH THEIR FISCAL
SITUATION. SO WE THINK IT WOULD
BE PRUDENT FOR US TO GET OUT
THERE AND CONDUCT AUDIT WORK.
AND HOPEFULLY IDENTIFY SOME
ISSUES OR SHARE BEST PRACTICES
THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT HOPEFULLY
WILL BE OF ASSISTANCE TO THE
CITIES AND OTHER CITIES THAT.
PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT WE'RE
DOING GOT IT. AND SO THESE ARE
THE- TOP TWENTY MOST CASES THE
TOP TEN- HIGH RISK ALREADY
IDENTIFIED IN THE DASHBOARD.
WHEN WE WHEN WAS THE FIRST HIGH
RISK AUDIT CONDUCTED. OR I'D
HAVE TO LOOK- WE'VE DONE I
THINK FOR. US WE'VE DONE FOR.
AUDIT THAT THIS CA HAS APPROVED
MISTER CHILDREN INDICATE HE'S
THAT THOUGHT THE FIRST WE DID
CITY OF HAMMETT MOM AND I THE
STATE OF MAY WOOD WERE BOTH
CONDUCTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN OKAY SO THIS
ISN'T SOMETHING NEW FOR ALL OF
THE CITY'S A SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN
AROUND FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
CORRECT CORRECT OKAY GIVE
WITHOUT THERE'S A REAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS FOR
THE AGENDA ITEM ONE. THE STATUS
REPORT WORK PROGRESS ANY THE
MEMBERS. OKAY HEARING IN SAYING
THAT THE YOU MADAM THINK MISTER
CHAIRMAN. AT THIS TIME IS GOING
AND THE STAFF QUORUM. SOUTH
PRESENT. BOERNER HORVATH GEN.
PATTERSON. RUBIO VOEPEL. WHAT
CENTER ROCK. GORGEOUS OPENS ALL.
HERTZBERG. MORNING HERE
MOORLACH. WIENER. OKAY THANK
YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED. OKAY WITH THAT
WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE DID WASWE
WILL MAKE TWO EXCEPTIONS ON THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR THAT
IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR CITIES OF
HUNTINGTON PARK IN COMMERCE
CONTRACTING PRACTICES IN
CANNABIS LICENCES BY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA WILL BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND ALSO- ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY DASH EIGHT
OH FOUR CITY OF LINDSAY WILL
ALSO BE REMOVED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND THOSE
WILL BE PLACED ON THE REGULAR
CALENDAR AGENDA- WITH THAT DO I
HAVE A MOTION TO YOU APPROVE
VACANCY. ALL RIGHT. THE PERSON.
RIGHT WE WERE ON THE SIDE WE
MUST SUSPEND JAIL RULES NUMBER
THIRTY AND OVER. AND SO WITH
THAT- NOW WILL THE CORRECT. YOU
CAN SO FIRST WE NEED TO VOTE ON
SUSPENDING JACK RULES NUMBER
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN. I DO TO
MOTION WILL MOVE I MISS ROSS
SECOND BY MISS RUBIO- SEXUALLY
CALDERON. THE MOTION IS TO
WAIVE COMMITTEE RULES THIRTEEN
AND FIFTEEN AND ARE TO APPROVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AS I'VE
EVER SALAS HI. SALAS AYE
BOERNER HORVATH. GEN. PATTERSON
RUBIO RUBIO AYE VOEPEL AYE
VOEPEL I WOULD. CENTER OFF
SENATOR ROBB AYE BARGES. OR
JUST I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. MORNING MORNING I
MOORLACH. WINNER.
WAS THE. FOR
OKAY LET ME ASK AT THIS TIME IF
WE COULD HAVE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REPORT TO. HEARING ROOM
FOR. PLEASE NOT ON THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY WITH THAT WILL
GO AHEAD AND WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ONCE WE
GET- WHAT'S WE CAN SUSPEND
RULES THIRTEEN FIFTEEN TO TAKE
UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THIS
TIME WAS GOING TO MOVE TO THE
REGULAR KEPT UNDER WE WILL MOVE
TO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
SO REMEMBER SANTIAGO. WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO PROCEED THIS
WILL BE ON AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S
ONE OF SEVEN DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL LEAD
CONTAMINATION CLEAN UP
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO WHEN
YOU ARE READY TO BEGIN PLEASE
BEGIN SURE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE WHAT WE'RE REQUESTING
AT THE STATE AUDITOR AUDITS IDT
ESSIE SPECIFICALLY TOWARDS WORK
ON EXCITE. AS YOU MIGHT RECALL
ON THIS IS THE WORST
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER ON THE
WEST COAST THAT WE HAVE NOW
BEEN FIGHTING TO CLEAN UP- THIS
BODY HAS BEEN VERY GENEROUS-
AND WE'RE NOW OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS BUT
THERE'S SOME BIG QUESTIONS WE
HAVE BASS. NUMBER ONE WHAT TO
TAKING SO LONG NUMBER TWO WHY
IS THE COST OF BURIED FROM
FIFTY FROM THE ESTIMATED FIFTY
THOUSAND A PROP NOW EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND A PROPERTY- WE
NOW KNOW THAT SOME THAT THE
PROCEDURES COULD'VE BEEN DONE
THAT. HOW I KNOW THE CAR TO
MAKE NOT HELD IN PLACE. AND OF
QUESTIONS WE FOLKS. FOLKS OF
MEN THAT WE PRINT TO ADD DTS
PLEASE QUITE BUT QUITE. ARE
THERE'S A BIT THE DISK. AND WE
WOULD LIKE THE STATE OUT OF TO
AUTO IN GIVE SOME ANSWERS TO
WHITES. SO MUCH LENGTH OF TIME
AND HOW WE CAN BE IS PUT IN AS
WE CAN WITH- PRECIOUS TAX
DOLLARS. SAW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND I'D LIKE
TO HAVE SUPERVISED RELEASE ALSO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON THE NEED
FOR THIS. PLACE SUPERVISORS
THANKS FOR JOINING US THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND TO THE CHAIR.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR INVITING ME
UP TODAY- OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
VERY CRITICAL ISSUE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THEIR TAKE FOR
THE PAST. YEARS I DO WANT TO.
UNDERSCORE THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROVIDED FUNDING TO PROVIDE
HOWEVER WE'VE HAD ISSUES
REGARDING THE ADMINISTRATION OF
TSC IN TERMS OF HOW THAT CLEAN
UP IS CONDUCTED. AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY IN MY OPINION
THIS IS OUR FLINT MICHIGAN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT'S
DEVASTATING TEN THOUSAND HEALTH
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. IN
THE SOUTHEAST COMMUNITIES AS
WELL AS A STEP HEY- HERNANDEZ
AND THE RED. THAT ARE PUT
FORWARD NOW I DON'T THINK ARE
SUFFICIENT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO ASK FOR DETAILS SEE TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AND CONTINUE
WITH THE CLEAN UP. AND TO ALSO
REVIEW THE TERMS OF AGREEMENTS
WITH THE CONTRACTORS BECAUSE AS
A- ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID- THERE
ARE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT. A
CONTRACTING OVERHEAD CHARGES
AND THAT WILL IMPACT THE CLEAN
UP. THAT THEN I THINK CREEK LZ
OUT OF HELPING AND HOUSEHOLDS
THAT CAN'T BE REVIEWED
EFFICIENTLY. AND THE COMMUTE.
AND WAITING. MORE THAN TWICE A
YEAR THE PLAN HAS BEEN CHAU.
WITH THE IMPACT IS WHAT IT A
TO. PEOPLE TO WOMEN. IT'S TIME
THAT WE TAKE A SECOND LOOK. SEE
MY OPINION I UNDERSTAND THE TSC
HAS ABOUT NINETY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDS REMAINING THAT
ARE ON ALLOCATED. ARE OVER
FIFTY YOUR PROPERTIES ROOM TO
BE. LOS APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND AND FIFTY. OF
PROPERTIES CAN BE CLEANED UP
FOR THE NINETY FOUR MILLION IN
OUR ESTIMATION. AND IT'S NOT
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO CLEAN UP
THE REMAINING FIVE HUNDRED
PROPERTIES TO REACH THE INTERIM
GOAL OF THREE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THAT WAS SET BY DE TSC.
SO WE KNOW TAT THIS IS A MOVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IF
YOU'LL APPROVED. THIS AUDIT AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ANTI TNC THEY'VE COME DOWN
SEVERAL TIMES. TO OUR AREA TO
TALK TO CONSTITUENTS BUT I WILL
SAY THAT. OF PEOPLE ARE ARE ARE
VERY ANXIOUS AND WANT TO SEE
REMEDIES WITH A ONE ALSO SEE
THAT THERE ARE SOME CULTURAL
COMPETENCE THE PROVIDED.
THROUGH THE CONTRACTING IS A
LIST WITH THE STAFF. BECAUSE
YOU DO HAVE MANY MONOLINGUALS
SPEAKING END OF IT. AND ARE.
ONLY A WILL A WITH THE PATIENTS
OF THE CLEAN. AND ALSO OTHER
FACT IT STILL. THERE'S A SIX
HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS WERE DTS SEE
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO OUR I'M
SORRY. A THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
PROPERTIES THAT HAVE. NOT
RECEIVED ADEQUATE ACCESS
AGREEMENTS TO BE ABLE TO GO
INTO THE PROPERTY TO IDENTIFY
THE CLEANUP. AND I KNOW THAT
CAN BE HARD BUT AS A COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WERE
WILLING TO WORK. WITH THE S.
DTS SEE TO HELP FACILITATE THAT
BUT WE'VE YET TO HEAR A
RESPONSE SO I JUST READ A
WRITTEN. REQUEST RESPECTFULLY
THAT OU OF. PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR THIS AUDIT AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN GET TO THE BOTTOM OF A WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO REMEDY. THE
BANKS AND- CAN. OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE SOUTHEAST AND
EAST LOS ANGELES AREAS THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY AND WILL PROBABLY
COME BACK TO THAT SPECIALLY IF
YOU HAVEN'T RECEIVED A RESPONSE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT- WILL WE
COME TO THE QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS AT THIS TIME IS GOING
TO MOVE TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
INDICATED THIS WOULD BE AN
HONOR TO THE DEPARTMENT TOXIC
SUBSTANCES. AND IT WOULD LOOK
AT THE VARIETY OF ISSUES
PRIMARILY. THE FIRST OBJECTIVE
REALLY LOOKING AT THEIR
CONTRACTS AND- THE CONTRACTS
THAT THEY'VE EXECUTED FOR CLEAN
UP ACTIVITIES AND HERE'S THE
DID THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THOSE CONTRACTS. PARTICULARLY
WHEN WITH RESPECT TO PROPERTY
OF VALUE BY THE CONTRACT AND
THOSE DIFFERENCES REASONABLE
WHAT ARE THE FACTORS. BECAUSE
THOSE THERE IS. GETTING TO THE
DIFFERENT. AS TOXIC SUBSTANCE.
ODD IN. PLIED WITH STATE CON.
RULES HAVE THEY DONE. THEY CAN
COULD OR DID THEY DO EVERYTHING
THEY COULD- IN AWARDING THOSE
CONTRACTS MAKING SURE THAT THEY
GOT THE BEST VALUE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALSO IN
MONITORING THOSE CONTRACTS ARE
THEY ENSURING THAT THERE OF
TRYING TO AVOID OR CONTAIN ANY
COST INCREASES. ALSO HE HAS
ASKED US TO LOOK AT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WHAT COST
IS THE DEPARTMENT TOXICS.
SUBSTANCE CONTROL INCURRING IN
MONITORING THE CONTRACTS- AND
ARE THEY DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO CONTAIN THOSE COSTS AS
WELL. AND THEN OUR OTHER
OBJECTIVE ASKING US EVALUATE
THE PER PROPERTY CLEAN UP
ESTIMATES SO NOT ONLY WHAT HAS
OCCURRED. THUS FAR BUT WHAT ARE
THE- THAT ARE TRIBUNE BRING. IN
OR- SUGGESTED IN. IN THE-
FUTURE. OUT REALLY LOOKING AT
THAT AND MAKING. THAT TALKS AS-
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION AND GET
DOCUMENTS ARE FULLY DISPLAY. OF
THESE MADE ARE. IN HE SAID A
PART. BE ARE ALSO A US TO LOOK
AT ONE TIME. WHEN IS THE ANSWER.
EXT WHAT IS EXPECTATION IS FOR
AS WHEN WILL THIS. PROJECT OR
THIS CLEAN UP EFFORT BE FULLY
COMPLETED AND DO THOSE TIME
FRAMES APPEAR REASONABLE WHAT
WERE THEY- ON ARE USING. PULL
INFORMATION INFORM. SOME THERE.
SUGGESTION AS FAR AS HOW IT
WILL CLEAN UP NOT ONLY PRICE
READ. BUT PERHAPS SOME COME
PROPERTY IN THE REGION AS WELL.
AND FOR. LOOK AT WHERE OR NOT
THE- ISSUE STEP ARE THERE FISH.
IS THAT. A P. TRY GET THIS CALL
BETH I'M MORE LIKELY AND ONLY.
CALL PASTA MATT MAN. THE HOURS
FOR THIS UP TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
OUR- THIS IS WOULD SIX COME.
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU.
YEAH OKAY THE TIME WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND READ FROM THE
IF AGE AFTER TO IDENTIFY IF YOU
CAN PLEASE BEACON WITH YOUR
COMMENTS NONE OF THEM. NINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONE OF THE. PLEASE IF YOU COULD
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES AND-
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS FRANCESCA DEGREE AND
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL AND WITH ME
IS DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR SITE
MITIGATION RESTORATION PROGRAM
GRANT COPE- WE'RE VERY PLEASED
TO BE HERE AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THE CONVERSATION OF THIS
PROPOSED AUDIT A DTS C. M.
WELCOMES AND ANY OPPORTUNITY TO
BE TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE
AND ITS BUSINESS PRACTICES AND
UNDERSTANDS THAT- WE UNDERSTAND
THE- THE ENORMITY OF THIS
PROJECT AND THE IMPACT TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE- WE
HAVE AND IT IN. AND AN TO THAT
POINT B.WE ACTUALLY RECOGNIZED
THAT CONDUCTING AUDITS ON THIS
PROJECT WAS VITAL POURTANT TO
ENSURING THAT WE WERE MAN DEAN
AND THE EXPENDITURES AND MONIES
RELATED TO THIS PROJECT
APPROPRIATELY I UNDERSTAND THAT
AUDIT RESPONSES OR AUDIT
FINDINGS HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERING. WE
HAD SEVERAL- AUDIT REPORTS THAT
CAME OUT ON THIS PROJECT ON ITS
HELP KEEP THE FINANCE AND-
THOSE AUDITS OF INDICATED THAT
WE HAVE STRONG AND CONTROLS FOR
MANAGEMENT OF THE EXPENDITURES
FOR THIS PROJECT IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS REAL. TO THE
CONTRACTS SINCE. WERE WHAT
WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING MISTER
COPE HERE TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU THREE THANK
YOU WITH THAT WE TURN IT BACK
TO THE DíAS LET ME ASK THIRTY
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS
SENATOR MONEY PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. WELCOME
SUPERVISOR SO LEASE MADAM
SECRETARY WELCOME HOME NICE TO
SEE YOU SO I GUESS FIRST FOR
THE AUDITOR I WAS PROVIDED SOME
RESPONSES PER WILL FOR THE
AUTHOR I WAS PROVIDED BY JANE
LACK. BY BY DTS SEEN SOME
RESPONSES TO YOUR J. LACK
REQUEST HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE
TO REVIEW THOSE ON UP. ON AND
WE REVIEW DOCUMENTS IN THE PAST
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR HAND
WHAT YOU HAVE AND BEFORE YOU.
THIS IS. SOME RESPONSES TO
QUESTIONS ON EXCITED. THERE SIR
PROVIDED TO ME BY CAL EPA. OM
YOU HAVEN'T PROVIDED THESE TO
THE AUTHOR. THEY WERE PROVIDED
HIS OFFICE WHEN IF WE PROVIDED.
HAS THE AUDITOR HAD A CHANCE
TRIBUNE THESE WE RECEIVE THOSE
MATERIALS LAST NIGHT AND I HAVE
AMEND MY I AND I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THOSE I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT M. GEO-
DID THE AUDITS OF THEIR
INTERNAL CONTROLS AND AN
INTERNAL CONTROL ON IT IS
DIFFERENT THAN A PERFORMANCE
AUDIT WHAT WHAT THE- THE MEMBER
IS ASKING US TO DO IS LOOK AT-
COME. COMPARISONS OF PER
PROPERTY- COST OUT LOOKING AT A
COUPLE OF CONTRACTORS LOOKING
AT CONTRACTING PRACTICES THOSE
WERE NOT THE TYPES OF THINGS
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT NGOS
TERRIFIC FIRM- BUT THEY WERE
LOOKING AT ARE THE EXPENDITURES
BEING RECORDED APPROPRIATELY
THEY LOOK AT SOME TIME SHE TO
MAKE SURE THAT. PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON THE PROJECT RECORDING
PROPERTY LAKE THE AND IT'S- THE
RESULTS ARE THAT THEIR INTERNAL
CONTROL SO THAT MAY BE A
PATIENT. I ON BUT IT CAN SCRIPT
DOES THAT WERE AND IS THERE
WHAT ASKING YOU THANK YOU
HELPFUL. OF INTEREST. ONE IN
USE. DOES PROPOSE A PACKAGE OF
FOR DTE ANY. MISTER CENTER OF
HIS CHANCE REVIEW GOVERNOR
BUDGET WE HAVE BUT LOOK HERE'S
WHAT'S ITS AND ALL FRAME WHY
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO US
RIGHT BECAUSE WHAT'S AT STAKE
IS OUR IS AND I DON'T THINK I
THINK I DON'T THINK I HAVE TO
CONVINCE ON THAT PART BUT ALL
UNDERSTATEMENT THE LAST WHAT'S
AT STAKE OUR COMMUNITIES HEALTH
BECAUSE WHEN WE STARTED THIS
THERE WAS APPROXIMATION OF HOW
LONG IT WOULD TAKE TO CLEAN. WE
NOW PASS THOSE TIMES THERE WAS
AN APPROXIMATION OF HOW MUCH
EACH PROPERTY COSTS WE HAVE NOW
BE GONE BEYOND THAT IT WAS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ONE
CONTRACTOR DO CERTAIN PROPERTY
FOR CERTAIN COST ABOUT SIXTY
ANOTHER CONTRACTOR DOING OF
ANOTHER COST ABOUT EIGHTY AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT SOME
PROPERTIES. AS THE THREE. ONES
WE- OUGHT TO. BUT WHAT WHAT.
PERFECTLY THIS BUT PROJECT IT
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY THAT IS
NOT WE DON'T BELIEVE IS BEING
ADDRESSED WHILE AND WHILE I
WHILE I CAN I WELL I UNDERSTAND
THE RESPONSES. WE FEEL THAT WE
NEED AN INDEPENDENT AUDITOR TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE QUESTIONS
WERE SPECIFICALLY REQUESTING TO
ENSURE NOT ONLY THAT THE
REMAINING DOLLARS ARE SPENT
WELL- BUT QUITE FRANKLY GIVE
THIS HAPPENS IN ANYBODY ELSE'S
COMMUNITY- ANY OF US WHO
REPRESENT WE BE DEMANDING THE
SAME SORT OF AUDIT. BECAUSE IT
THIS CAN HAPPEN IN ANYBODY'S
BACKYARD IN THE FACT THAT IT
HAPPENED IN OUR BACKYARD LOW
INCOME- LATINO NEIGHBORHOODS.
BUT WE FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT
THIS HAPPEN LOOK AT LOOK FOR
THIRTY THREE YEARS. EXIDE
ALLOWED. DEED FOR X. SORRY DTS
HE ALLOWED EXCITE- TO OPERATE
UNDER TEMPORARY PERMIT I MEAN
THAT THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
BIG RED FLAG WE'VE NOT GONE
THROUGH TWO OR THREE FACTORS
WILL HAVE A NEW DIRECTOR NOW.
WITH A REALLY GOOD OPPORTUNITY
WE HAVE A NEW DIRECTOR SHE'S
WORKING REALLY HARD TO GET THIS
DONE AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL ALL WILL. GIVE HER TOOLS
DON'T ARE ALL ON THE WORK OF
THE PERSON VOTE FOR THE- TIME
AND TO DO THE- TAKE CARE BUT
WILL. THEN MOVE FOR AND SPEND
LIKE WHY SUPPORT RE ANYMORE
DOLLARS CLEAN THIS UP THE END
OF THE DAY HEALTH. I DON'T. YOU.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THE CONFIDENCE
OF THE LET. THE COMPANY OF OUR
USE THE MONIES WILL BE. WELL IN
THE MOST IF. WAY WHEN IT COMES
TO CLEANING UP OUR NEIGHBOR. I
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT IME AND
QUITE FRANKLY I THINK THE
LITTLE BIT LATE THAT WERE HERE.
ASKING FOR NOT A FEW YEARS
LATER IN. BY CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE GRAVITY OF THE
CRISIS AS YOU DESCRIBED ITS-
CALIFORNIA'S PLANT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE
CONTAMINATED WATER SYSTEMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT IS
ALSO CALIFORNIA'S FLINT RIGHT.
ARM ONE OF MY CONCERNS WE'VE
ALLOCATED- GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
FOR THIS CLEANUP WHEN. WHAT'S
THE STE. WASN'T EXCITED PAYING
FOR THIS CLEANUP. THEY ARE WHAT
WILL BE WILL BE I MEAN I'LL
I'LL GIVE YOU THE VERY HIGH
LEVEL UNDERSTANDING. THERE WAS
A NON PROSECUTION AGREEMENT
THAT WAS SIGNED BACK I BELIEVE
IT'S TWO THOUSAND AND- FIFTEEN.
THAT AT SOME POINT ONE FOUND
CULPABLE- THE X. EXCITE WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE THE DOLLARS TO.
BUT FOR THE DOLLARS OF CLEAN UP
IN WOULD REIMBURSE THE STATE
NOW IF THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
THERE THERE IS A SECOND. A IT
WAS A SECOND BILL TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW IS CLEANING UP. WITH
THE WITH THE DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED. AND I THINK THAT'S I
THINK THAT'S A VERY HIGH LEVEL-
YEAH BUT IF I CAN JUST ADD ON
TO THAT. PLEASE SO THE THROUGH
THE CHAIR POLICE- THANK YOU
CHAIR I'M SORRY. SO THE US.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FIND A
NON PROSECUTION AGREEMENT WITH
BACKSIDE. NOT NOT THE STATE DID
YOU SEE HAS BEEN ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH THE STATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO BUILD A CASE FOR
COST RECOVERY AGAINST EXIDE NOT
EXCITED FIGHTING US THUS FAR
ADMINISTRATIVELY AT EVERY TURN.
WE'RE NOT GONNA ACCEPT THAT
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD TO PROSECUTE. COST
RECOVERY ACTION AGAINST EXIDE
TO RECOVER ALL THE COST THAT WE
CAN. WITH THE SCOPE OF THIS ON
IT LOOK AT THE STATUS OF. OF
THAT IN IN COST REIMBURSEMENT
TO THE STATE. THIS QUESTION FOR
THE MONITOR NO WE DON'T HAVE I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING IN THE SCOPE
OF THE HONORED AS FAR AS- COSTA.
IT'S REALLY LOOKING AT TOXIC
SUBSTANCES AND THEIR ACT
ACTIONS WITH RESPECT TO
CONTRACT FOR THE CLEAN
ACTIVITIES CONTROLLING THE COST
ESTIMATING HOW LONG IT WILL
TAKE. SO IT'S BASICALLY IN THE
SCOPE OF THE AUDIT. RIGHT IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE TO GET THE FULL
PICTURE THAT WOULD BE A HUMVEE
ELEMENT AT. THIS STAGE OF THAT
COULD BE A SUPPLEMENTAL WELL
COMPONENT IF I MIGHT ADD I I'M
SORRY PLEASE SENATOR WE ALL WE
ALWAYS HAVE ANYTIME WE CONDUCT
AN AUDIT WE ALWAYS HAVE AN
OBJECTIVE IN HERE THAT IF THERE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE RELEVANT TO
THE SUBJECT MATTER. THE FACT
YOU'RE BREAKING IT UP IT'S
RELEVANT TO THE SUBJECT.
SOMETHING WE COULD INCLUDE IN
THE SKIN IT WOULDN'T BE A SCOPE
MODIFICATION BECAUSE IT'S
RELEVANT TO THE ISSUE SO IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN CERTAINLY
LOOK AT IF THE AUDITS PRICKED
THANK YOU. SHE SO WITHIN. JACK
DISMISSED IF YOU COMMENT ON
THAT YEAH I WOULD INCUR APPS
THAT ALL PART OF THE THAT THAT
THE SEGMENT OF THE OF THE WORK
IS BEING AUTUMN THAT WE-
PROVIDING THE STATE COMPTROLLER.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S WITHIN
THE VENUE BUT ABSOLUTELY THAT
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
WITHIN THOSE PROCEDURES TO
RECOVER FUNDS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL IN A IN A NIGHT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP YET.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU IN
BEFORE WE MOVE TO THE NEXT
QUESTION I WANT TO GO AHEAD
SINCE WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER
HERE. IS A QUICK TAKE A PAUSE
HERE WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
BRING UP THE SUSPENSION OF THE
JOINT RULES. THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN SO THAT WE CAN. THEN
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR WERE
REMOVING ITEMS NUMBER FOR. AN
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN- PLACE IN THE
REGULAR. CALENDAR AGENDA WITH A
GOOD CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MISTER SECRETARY. THIS ONE. THE
IS TO WAIVE JOINT COMMITTEE
RULES THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN IN
ORDER TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BOERNER HORVATH. CHEN
PATTERSON PROCESS I. WHAT.
SENATOR HERTZBERG I CENTER
HERTZBERG HIGH MORE LOCKED.
WIENER. OKAY THAT MOTION
CARRIES TO SPEND THE JOINT
ROLES AND NOW WE WILL- TAKE A
VOTE ON THE FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH THE EXCEPTIONS OF
ITEM NUMBER FOUR TWENTY TWENTY
DASH ONE THIRTEEN CITIES OF
FUNDING TO PARK COMMERCE
CONTRACTING PRACTICES CANNABIS
LICENSING BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND ITEM
NUMBERS AND TWENTY TWENTY THAT
IT'LL OR CITY OF LINDSAY-
REMOVING THEM FROM THE CAN
CALENDAR- WITH A GO TO CALL THE
ROLL. SECTION SO WE NEED AT.
OKAY CAN HAVE A MOTION FOR THE
CALENDAR SO MOVED BY MISTER
BORCHERS SECOND BY MISS RUBIO
MISS SECTOR CULTURAL. THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- CONSISTING OF
AUTO REQUEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OH THREE BY SENATOR BELL.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OH EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO. TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT OH TO- CITY OF LIFE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OH THREE
CITY OF EL SERENO. TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX CITY OF
WEST COVINA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS AYE. SALAS HI
BOERNER HORVATH. GEN PATTERSON
PERSON I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD. SENATOR
ROTH CENTER ROTH AYE BARGES. OR
JUST HI GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI MORNING
MORNING HI MORLOCK. WIENER. A
CONSENT CALENDARS APPROVAL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON- WITH THAT
WILL GO TO RETURN BACK TO THE
SANTIAGO IS ITEM I BELIEVE
SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS QUESTION
THEN MOVED TO CENTER ARTS FOR.
I MORE OF JUST A COMMENT I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU BOTH
FOR CONTINUING TO KEEP THE
ISSUE ALIVE I KNOW- FURNACE IN
MY BACKYARD AS WELL AND I'M
NEWER TO THE ISSUE BUT- WITH
ALL DUE. RESPECT THIS IS JUST
IT'S GREAT THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING THE DISCUSSIONS- I
THINK THE ONLY. QUESTION I HAD
WAS IT SAYS IT'S- THE TSC IS
UNCERTAIN AS TO HOW MANY
PARCELS WILL ULTIMATELY NEED TO
BE CLEANED UP EVEN AS A
LEGISLATOR I FEEL LIKE I CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION BUT DO WE
HAVE ANY GUESSTIMATES ON WHAT.
PERCENTAGE IS. CLEANED UP
ALREADY. YEAH SINCE THE CLEANUP
PLAN WAS ISSUED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE LATTER HALF OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WE CLING OF
ABOUT THIRTEEN HUNDRED PARCELS.
THAT BRINGS THE ENTIRE AMOUNT A
NUMBER PARTIALS CLEANED UP TO
OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED AND FORTY.
SO THAT'S PRETTY MUCH AN
UNPRECEDENTED CLEAN UP IN THE
HISTORY THE STATE IN TERMS
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
TECHNIQUES TO BE DONE AS WELL
SO WHAT NEEDS TO BE SO THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THEY PROVIDED
THE MONEY. SAID CLEAN UP
ACCORDING TO THE THREAT
REPRESENTED BY THE MATERIAL ON
THE PARTIALS. AND THE POTENTIAL
FOR ACTUALLY- THAT THAT HAS A
SUBSTANCE THE LEAD IMPACTING
HUMAN HEALTH. SO THERE'S NO SET
NUMBER OF PARCELS. THAT IS
ESTABLISHED IN LAW. WHAT WE
THINK WE CAN DO THAT BASICALLY
OUR ENGINEERS ESTIMATE SAYS.
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
AVERAGE PER PARTIALS ABOUT HOW
MUCH IT SHOULD COST WE'VE GOT
ONE CONTRACTORS SIXTY THOUSAND
ANOTHER CONTRACTOR OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND. SO WE WERE STARTING
TO SHIFT MORE PROPERTIES TO THE
LOWER COST ONE. IN AN EFFORT TO
ACTUALLY CLEAN UP MORE
PROPERTIES OVER TIME. WITH WE
THINK WE CAN GET TO AROUND
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED. BUT
THAT'S GONNA VERY A LOT ON THE
TECHNICAL COMPLEXITY OF ACTUAL
CLEANING UP INDIVIDUAL PARCELS
THE AMOUNT OF MATERIAL TAKEN
OUT OF EACH PARCEL IT THE WE
KIND OF LAID OUT IN IN THAT
DOCUMENT FOR YOU. THERE'S A LOT
OF FACTORS THAT GO INTO EACH
INDIVIDUAL PARCEL ACTUALLY THE
COST THAT IT TAKES TO CLEAN IT
UP RIGHT. FOR OKAY RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SORRY JUST FOR
PLEASE CLEAR FONDEST YEAH I'M
SORRY IT IS JUST USE A TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED IS YOUR GOAL. OR
WEARABLES AS MEN PARTIAL PASTA
THE MORE MONEY WE CAN SQUEEZE
OUT OF EVERY DOLLAR WE'LL DO IT
RIGHT BY. USE MENTIONED. TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED CURRENT
PROJECTIONS ARE. THANK YOU.
THANK RIGHT WELL BETTER MOVED
HIS HERTZBERG PLEASE. THE ON.
WE DEBATED THIS MEASURE ON THE
FLOOR A FEW YEARS AGO AND
CENTER LENO WAS THE BUDGET
CHAIR AT THE TIME- AND WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS. YOU KNOW WE
WERE FACED WITH A DILEMMA ON
THE ONE HAND ON MISTER
RESPONSIBILITY PRIVATE
COMPANIES. START RESPONSIBILITY
THESE COMPANIES POLLUTED AND
THEY SHOULD PAY IT. THEY SHOULD
PAY FOR. YOU HAVE A AS YOU IN
APPOINTED A EXTRAORDINARY
IMPACT HUMAN HEALTH SO WE IN
GOVERNMENT- DID THE RIGHT THING
AND WE STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE-
IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH THE
PEOPLE A COMMUNITY THAT WERE
SEVERELY IMPACTED. WELL WE
DIDN'T DO WHAT I WANT TO KNOW
WHETHER YOU CAN AT LEAST HELP
US WITH RESPECT TO THIS AUDIT
THAT COULD BE IN THE PICTURE
DYNAMIC. IS A TO HELP US
RECOVER THE MONEY MISSION OF
THE MESSAGE ASIANS WERE WE
GOVERNMENTS WERE CHECKED. AS A
LAWYER FOR FORTY ONE YEARS I
KNOW HOW THIS GAME GETS PLAYED
NOBODY'S GONNA WANT TO SETTLE
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO SETTLE
BECAUSE KNOWS NORDIC
RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE FOR SELL
IT FOR LESS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GONNA PAY THE LAWYERS ARE GOING
TO BE RIGHT CHECKS. EVER GET
GET PAID BACK REASONS MUCH
MONEY IS WHICH MADE THIS A
ISSUE IT HAD SIXTY PROVISIONS
IN THE INTRO INDENTURE.
REPAYMENT AND WE BASE MADE TO
THE CAN I THINK IT WAY THAT I
DON'T THINK WAS WAS MY- THE IT
WILL TO REIMBURSE WAS RESPONSE
BACK TO THE LOCAL ISSUES WERE
THERE. WHAT WE'RE FACED TO SIT.
SO MY QUESTION IS. REALLY NO
WAS ANYTHING. YOU KNOW OF A
NUMBER IS OUR LITIGATION WITH
THIS TO FOLKS GOING AFTER. A
KNOW THE- PEOPLE RISK. FOR THIS
CONTENT. AND IF NOT OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU CAN DO WITH
WHICH- TO THE FOR. OF THIS ALL.
THAT HELPS US. PUT OURSELVES IN
A PROPER POSITION TO HELP US
GET OUR MONEY BACK IT COUNTY
GET ITS MONEY BACK. AND HOLD
THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE.
FINANCIALLY AS WE TOOK DI THE
RIGHT THING TO TAKE CARE OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY ANY
THOUGHTS IN THAT REGARD. WELL
FIRST I WOULD DEFER TO THE
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE A IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING APART WAS
INDICATING THEY WERE WORK ARE
WORKING WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WITH RESPECT.
LITIGATE CAN SO THAT I WOULD I
WOULD DEFER TO THEM. WE
CONDUCTED AUDITS OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES IN THE PAST THIS
DEPARTMENT AND LOOKING AT THEIR
EFFORTS AS FAR AS COST RECOVERY
AND- AND- IDENTIFYING. THE
WRIST WELL PART IN GETTING.
INTO TO. I PAY FOR THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCE OR OR THE CAN IN A
PARTICULAR. THE QUESTION
SENATOR MINING ASKED WITH
RESPECT TO COST RECOVERY I
THINK AS WE LOOK AT THAT WILL
LOOK AT THE EFFORTS THAT THE
STATE HAS TAKEN TO ENSURE THAT
ARE THERE CAPTURING THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT IS BEING EXPANDED
CERTAINLY AND THEN WHAT EXPERTS
THEY ARE TAKING TO TRY TO GET.
EXCITED TO BE DEEMED AS THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY AND EXCITED
TO BE OUR RISK OR FOR THE STATE
BACK BUT BUT WE WOULD CERTAINLY
DEFER TO OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE DEPARTMENT IS FAR GAUGE
AND MAYBE BEFORE YOU AS I JUST
FOLLOWING UP ON CENTER MONIES
IN QUERY IS. CAN YOU ARE IN
TUITION YOU CAN HELP NOT JUST
GATHERING DATA OF WHAT YOU KNOW
THE REIMBURSEMENT SHOULD BE BUT
UNDER THE GUIDANCE OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL QUESTION CAN PASS THAT
WOULD THEN IT HELP PROVE THE
STATE CASE IN THE COUNT. WELL
TO GET REMEMBER IN THE PRIVATE.
NOT JUST A BASS LINE DATA BUT
MADE IN COURT WITH THE LAWYERS
YOUR YOUR HOME OR CAN BE QUITE
VALUABLE IN HELPING THE
GOVERNMENT GET ITS MONEY BACK
AS I JUST WOULD. MAKE THAT
SUGGESTION BECAUSE I CAN THINK
IS REALLY MINING BUILDING I
WOULD BECAUSE OUR MINING SAID
BUT BUT I THINK THAT MIGHT BE
VALUABLE FOR THEM HERE FOR THE-
THAT WOULD BE TREMENDOUSLY.
VALUABLE TREMENDOUSLY VITAL. IS
THAT SOMETHING YOU CAN DO IF
YOU COORDINATION CERTAINLY WE
CAN CERTAINLY. HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND UNDERSTAND
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE. THE
TYPES OF THINGS THAT WE COULD
CONDUCT IN THIS DURING THE- THE
SCOPE OF THIS AUDIT THAT WOULD
BE BENEFICIAL- BUT BEYOND THAT
AS AS YOU KNOW WHEN WE CONDUCT
OUR AUDIT WORK IT'S
CONFIDENTIAL BUT WE CERTAINLY
WILL ENGAGE WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. OUT TO SEE IF
THERE ARE THINGS. WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED
TO DO THAT MAY BE BENEFICIAL TO
THEM AND PARTLY. STATE A
CALIFORNIA. THANKS OF AMMON.
THIS BY JUST THINK IT'S- REALLY
IMPORTANT TO DO YOU KNOW WE-
DID THE RIGHT THING BUT- WE GOT
AT THE SECOND HALF OF THAT
EQUATION IS WE GOT GET THE-
TAXPAYER. REMEMBER BY THE-
THOUGHT OF. THINK OF. WHAT THE
SCOPE. THANK SAYING SHOT INTO
SHE WE WILLING TO DO THAT AS
WELL. REALLY THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WILL IN. BUT WHAT I
WOULD WELL I MISTER HER IF YOU
YOU IN THE CAN. SENT OUT LAW
ABOUT LAW MESSAGE THAT THAT
THAT THAT SORT OF SCHOOL OF
WORK WHAT HOW AND I WE WOULD
INCUR I THINK WE BE ON THE SAME
PAGE CRIME. OKAY THIS TIME A
MASK THERE'S ADDITIONAL. FROM
ON THE DíAS HEARING AND SEEING
NONE LET'S GO TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S PUBLIC COM. AND
I. OKAY HEARING IN SAYING NON
LET ME GO AHEAD AND TURN IT
BACK TO SOMEONE OVER SANTIAGO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE YET NINE
I'LL BE BRIEF SO RESPECTFULLY
WOULD JUST ASK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE VOTED TO PROCEED WITH
THIS AUDIT. AND SAID COMMENTS
REGARDING REIMBURSEMENT BE- BE
INCLUDED IF THE COMMITTEE
WISHES TO DO SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGHT OF. ALL RIGHT
THANK RESPONSE IAGO I DO SEE
THIS AS A YOU KNOW. THE SCOPE
OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE TSC
ALREADY DID. APPRECIATE YES HE
ACTUALLY- LOOKING INTO THIS IN
A VERY SERIOUS MATTER AND-
OBVIOUSLY THE YOU'VE HEARD
FROM. MEMBERS OF THIS DíAS-
HOW MUCH IMPORTANCE WE PLACE ON
MAKING SURE THAT EXCITE IS
CLEANED UP THANK YOU SUPERVISOR
FOR BEING HEREAS WELL. THIS
TIME BUT ASK THERE'S A MOTION
FOR MISTER SUCH. I MOVE BY. OUR
SECULAR BY. SENATOR HERTZBERG
MISTER SECTOR. THE MOST IS TO
APPROVE WATER NUMBER TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE OH SEVEN
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL LEAD CONTAMINATION
CLEAN UP BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO THAT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS BY SALAS HI
BOERNER HORVATH. GEN PATTERSON
PATTERSON I RUBIO RUBIO I
VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD. WOULD I
CENTER RAFI. SENATOR ROTH AYE
FORGES OR AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
MONNING. MONNING AYE MOORLACH.
WIENER IT. OUR OUR OKAY THAT
AUDIT SIR PROVE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THAT MISTER THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
NEXT AGENDA ITEM I KNOW OF I
SAW ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
EARLIER SEE STILL IN THE ROOM.
OKAY. THIS TIME LET'S GO AHEAD
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH CRISTINA
GARCIA. THIS IS THE ITEM TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE ONE THREE
CITIES OF HUNTINGTON PARK AND
COMMERCE CONTRACT PRACTICES IN
CANNABIS LICENSING THANK YOU
SEVERAL WOMEN FOR JOINING US
AND WHEN YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU OUR PRE
PAID AT. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I'M HERE TO YOUR
QUESTION AUDIT OF CONTRACTING
PRACTICES AND CANNABIS LICENSE
PROCEDURES FOR THE CITIES OF
COMMERCE AND HIDING THEM PARK.
I BEGAN MY CAREER FIGHTING FOR
TEN BEEN SEEING GOVERNMENT AND
HAVE CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THAT
FROM MY TIME HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
PROVIDING SOMETHING CHINA
CONTRACTING IN CANNABIS IS
LICENSABLE LONG WAY- TO SHOW
THE PUBLIC WHAT WHAT'S GOING
ON. WITH THE ADVENT OF CANNABIS
LICENSES ANY TO THE CITIES AS A
PART OF THAT REVIEW THEIR
PRACTICES. TO ENSURE OUR THAT
AS AS FOR STARTING THIS PROCESS
THAT WE'RE USING IN BEST
PRACTICES ALONG THE WAY. THE
CITY OF COMMERCE ALREADY HAS
TWENTY EIGHT CANNABIS LICENSES
AND THE PROCESS WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TANK CURRENTLY BEING
CONSIDERED- RIGHT NEXT DOOR
MONTEBELLO WE HAVE TWENTY ONE
THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED. SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT OVER SIXTY
PERMITS AND ELEVEN SQUARE MILES.
THE CITY OF COMMERCE HAS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN THE ABOUT THE TEN
ADDITIONAL LICENSES WE'RE GONNA
BE LOOKING AT ABOUT A LICENSE
FOR EACH THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY PEOPLE. IN THE CITY.
OUGHT TO GIVE YOU PERSPECTIVE
AND THE- CITY OF LA- THEY HAVE
A LICENSE FOR ABOUT. EACH
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE. ALL
RIGHT NOW. HI HI. BUT IN A
DIFFERENT. PLEASE PROCEED MY IS
SLOW AT WHAT'S IN THE SOUTH THE
AS A- I AND SAID THAT SOUTH YOU
FOR MORE THAN ONE CITY TO BE
LOOKED THAT THE HUNTINGTON PARK
IS ALSO EMBARKED ON GETTING
LICENSES AND HAVE AN COUPLE OF
LICENSES OUT IN THEIR CITY. LET
ME ADD THAT NEVER WRONG PAYING
TO ADD MORE THAN SYING TO
GOVERNMENT BUT GIVEN THE RAPID
RATE AT WHICH IS LICENSES ARE
EXPANDING AND THE SOUTHEAST I
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
AUDIT IS NEEDED NOW. AND NOT
LATER. I AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE I'M HERE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT AB AT A MONITOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
INDICATED THIS WOULD BE AN
AUDIT OF THE TO CITY CITY OF
HUNTINGTON PARK AND ALSO CITY
OF COMMERCE. LOOKING AT
CONTRACTING THIS IS LOOKING
PERMITTING PRACTICES WITH
RESPECT TO CANNABIS- FIRST
OBJECTIVE CONTRACTING.
PROCESSES EVALUATE THEIR
PRACTICES MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED ARE
APPROPRIATE STEPS THAT COMPLY
WITH STATE LAWS RAGS IT CETERA-
AND ALSO MENTION OF ANY. TYPE
OF CONFLICTS OF INTEREST. IS TO
COMPARE THEIR CONTRACTING
PRACTICES TO PRACTICES THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS BOTH
ENDS CON THING MAN. AND STATE
IS A STRAIGHT MAN THOSE ARE
SENSUAL PRACTICE. IN ADDITION
SHE IS ASKING US TO LOOK AT
CITY COUNCIL OF THE RESPECTIVE
CITY COUNCIL. AND THEIR OVER.
OVER THERE STE WHO ARE WORKING
THESE CONTACTS. ALSO THING ON
THE PERMITTED PROCESS MANY
CONTRACT WHAT OF ALL. I BEING
CUT LAST LOOK AT US. ARMS LAID
OUT IN THE CONTRACT AND DO ARE
THEY ENSURING THAT THEY'RE
AVOIDING IN ANY TYPE OF A
POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
AND THEN WITH THE- THE-
PERMITTING SIDE. LOOKING AT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES FOR
SEEKING AWARDING. AND CERTAINLY
MONITORING CANNABIS BUSINESS
PERMITS- AND MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE COMPLY NOT ONLY WITH
STATE BUT ANY LOCAL DANCE LOCAL
A LOT REGULATIONS. ARE ALSO
ASKING US RESPECTED PERMITTING
ARE THOSE PROCESSES AND ALLOW.
WITH THE BEST PRACTICES THAT
ARE. MAY LOOK AT OTHER STATES
ARE MAY LOOK AT WHAT OTHER
CITIES AND CAL. HAVE ON AND
THEN SHE'S A- IN OUR HOW CLEAR
ENTRANCE. THE PUMP AS FOR. THE
PROCESS THAT THE RESPECTIVE ARE
YOU. AND THEY FOLLOWING THOSE
PROCESSES AND THEN FINALLY. IN
SING SOME THE- VISION MAKING
THAT'S BEEN DONE BY THE WRIST
CITY. ARE THEY FOLLOWING THEIR
PERMITTING PROCEDURE. THEY
PROVIDING AGAIN AN APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY AND THEN
ARE THEY PROVIDING SUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE BUSINESSES ARE ACTUALLY
APPLYING WITH LAWS AND
REGULATIONS WITH RESPECT TO
PERMITS. ON THE SIDE IT'S
BUDGET ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED HOURS TAKE US ABOUT
SEVEN MONTHS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MADAM WATER AT
THIS TIME IS GOING TO MOVE TO
THE AFFECTED AGENCIES IF WE
HAVE ANY THIS TIME ONE BY
REPRESENTATIVES FROMTHE
AFFECTED AGENCIES TO THE TABLE
PLEASE BEGIN BY STATING YOUR
NAME AND WHICH AGENCY OR CITY
YEAR WITH.
PLEASE MORE MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF MY NAME IS ARE
ALLOWED WORSE CLASS. I AM THE
CITY OF FOR THIS OF HUNTINGTON
PARK. OF PERSON THIS MORNING
ABOUT THE MAJORS CELLS. PLEASE
MORE CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NORMA
COMPLY TO I'M IN THE ESSENCE OF
YOUR TO FOR THIS COMMERCE.
THANK YOU HEY. GOOD MORNING A
GOOD MORNING TERM VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE MY
NAME A KIND OF A CITY MAN WITH
THIS IF I NEED TO PARK. THANK
YOU. SEC PLEASE IF YOU HAVE
STATEMENT. THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
CHAIRMAN. OF ANY. UP I'M SORRY
WILL BE STE ON BEHALF OF CITY
HUNTINGTON WHERE MISS COOPER.
WILL BE SPEAKING OF THIS OF
KARMA IN AS MUCH AS WE ARE OUR
FIRM BOTH CA. THE ISSUES FACING
THE TOOK ME OR SOME WITH THE-
UP. THE PURPOSE OF OUR OF OUR
PARENTS THIS MORNING IS TWO
FOLD OF FIRST- TO INITIALLY
CITY COMMITTEES TO DIAL OF THE
RESPECT WE SEE THE COMMITTEES
DIAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA'S
REQUEST. OR IN THE ALTERNATIVE
AT THE VERY LEAST YOU DELAY THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE AUDIT
REQUEST AND ALLOW THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HER STAFF. AND THE
AUDITOR STAFF WITH YOUR CITY
STAFF TO DRAW THE QUESTIONS ARE
CONCERNED SET FORTH IN THE
LETTER DATED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA DATE. JANUARY TWENTY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY. IT'S
INTERESTING NOTE THAT LETTER
WAS NOT COPY THE CITY OF PARK
ALSO NOT COPY TO THE CITY OF
COMMERCE. SO WE HAD
APPROXIMATELY ONE WEEK IN WHICH
TO PREPARE TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE AND TO TRY AND
ADDRESS THE- ISSUES OF BRITISH
REPLACING THE COMMITTEE. BOB NO
I KNOW MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE I BACK ALSO NOTICE
SOME OF MEMBER GARCIA AND IT
STRUCK ME THAT. AN APPROACH
THAT IS MUCH BETTER TO-
CONSIDER IS THAT OF INSTEAD OF
GOING. DIRECTLY TO THE
COMMITTEE IS TO TRY TO MEET
WITH YOUR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU REPRESENT
IN THIS CASE THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON PARK IS OUTSIDE THE
JURISDICTION. OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA BUT IT'S STILL A
THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON PARK IS
STILL OPEN AND WILLING TO MEET
WITH HER AND HER STAFF IN THE
AUDITOR'S STAFF. IN ORDER TO
TRY TO DRAW MINIS IN ORDER TO
SAVE TAXPAYER DOLLARS. THE COST
OF SUCH AN ODD IT WOULD BE. IS
INDICATED IN OVER THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WELL A I THINK
FIFTY YEAH THAT ARE BEING. I'M
SURE QUESTION- ARE BEING SOUGHT
COULD BE TEST UP. MUCH MORE
FIRMLY IN TO GET TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION. IN ACTING THE
SEVEN. TO OF TEMPLE BURKE. MET
BUT HE AUDITORS ARE THEY WERE
INITIALLY THE CITY OF PARKING
RISK PROFILE WE MET WITH THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND AFTER THAT
PROCESS STUDENT COMPLETED UP
THERE DID NOT MOVE FORWARD ART.
WITH RESPECT TO THE K. ISSUES
THE CITY FUNDING TO IS ONLY A
THREE CANNABIS LICENSE LICENSES
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS- IN
FACT THAT MATTER WAS CHALLENGED
IN FEDERAL COURT. THE óRDENES
OF THIS WAS HAVE UPHELD BY THE
FEDERAL JUDGE AND- THE STANCE
FOR CONFIRMED BY THE COURTS OF
BY THE COURTS. UP WITH RESPECT
TO CONTRACT BRIEFLY OF THE
CITY'S CONTRA NOT RUBBER STAMP
THEY'RE NOT PUTTING CONSENT
AGENDA THEY'RE REVIEWED ONE BY
ONE BY THE CITY COUNCIL AND I
CAN ASSURE THE COMMITTEE. AND
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES THAT THE
PROPER STEPS ARE BEING TAKEN TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY. AND THE
PARENTS OF APPROVING THOSE
CONTRACTS. UP WITH ASKING
CLOSING FOR. CAN PARK THE
NEGATIVE. IMPACT OF COST TIME
EXPENSE TO THREE DAUGHTERS
OFFICE OF THE CITY STAFF AND
THE BUSINESS ATTRACTION AND
RETENTION ISSUES ARE LOSE LOSE
LOSE AS OPPOSED TO WHEN. WE ASK
THAT YOU RESPECT ME TO THE
COMMITTEE TO DENY THE WEST OR
EAST TO DISPLAY THIS
CONSIDERATION TO ALLOW CITY
STUFFED WITH THESE REMEMBERS
OFFICE WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY FOR CITY COVERS YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCH- I WOULD LIKE
TO START OFF WITH- CONTRACTING
PROCEDURES AND JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME POINTS THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY FACT THAT ARE VERY
RELEVENT- AS TO WHY WE THINK A
NOT IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE IN
THIS CASE. THE CITY OF COMMERCE
HAS BEEN IN A FIGHT BY THE
AUDITOR AS A- HAS NOT BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
AS A HIGH RISK MUNICIPALITY- ON
THE CONTRARY. I'M GLAD THAT
DEPUTY ARE OUR CHILDREN.
REFERENCE TO THESE FACTS UP AT
THIS HAS BEEN DESIGNATED AS A
LOW OVERALL. AND RANKS THREE
HUNDRED SO FOURTH. FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE CITIES RACKED WITH
THAT THE ARREST CITIES WE HAVE
THE LOWEST NUMBER OF FINE.
FURTHER THE CITY APPROACHES
AUDITED EVERY OTHER CITY AND
HAS RECENTLY RECEIVED MARKS.
AUDITS WITH A QUALIFY CLEAN UP
THIS HAS. BEEN RECOGNIZE AS
YEAR'S OVER FIND IT'S. THIS IS
THE ASIA PACIFIC BUT SHE- FOR
ACCESS TO FIND REPORTING. HI
THIS FOLLOWS. PROCUREMENT
POLICIES AND HAS NOT HAD ANY
REAL ARE COME OF AND BAD ABBE.
SINCE THE CITY'S CAN LAW
PROGRAM AND A DO TO MAKE
CORRECT. I CONCERNING ASSEMBLY
GARCIA- I MENTION AS TO HOW
MANY A LICENSES THERE HAD BEEN
TWENTY NINE LICENSES SAYS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED AND THAT IS
THE- THERE IS THAT THE
APPLICATION PROCESS HAS
CONCLUDED IN THERE IS NO. A
NEAR FUTURE PLANS TO OPEN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS- WE WOULD
LIKE TO BRING TO LIGHT TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT THERE IS ACTIVE
PENDING LITIGATION AND THE LA
SUPERIOR COURT. ARE CHALLENGING
SOME OF THE CITY'S CAN A
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS PERMITTING
PROGRAM- WE BELIEVE THAT IF
THERE'S WOULD BE AN AUDIT THAT
IT COULD POTENTIALLY COMPROMISE
THIS IS A LEGAL DEFENSE-
FURTHER AID I NECESSARILY MAKE
CUT- AND THIS UNNECESSARY CAST
A NEGATIVE CLOUD- THAT THERE'S
SOME SUGGESTION OF WRONGDOING
BUT THERE HAS BEEN NO EVIDENCE
TO SHOW. AND EVEN THOUGH WE
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE LITIGATION-
SHOULD THAT THAT CASE GO TO
CHURCH TRIAL. YOU WILL THAT
THIS. BUT GIVE I. I'M UP. TO I
THINK THAT TRANSPARENCY IS OF
THE CALL THAT WERE MADE AT CITY
OF COMMERCE PAINS STAKE IN MATT
MATT TO A VERY PROGRAM THE
CITIES OR ALONE IS A FOR TWO
PAGE OR NAY I'M NOT ONLY DID WE
IMPLEMENT ALL OF THIS LICENSE
RICK. WHICH BY LAW AND THAT THE
OUR MINIMUM STANDARDS BUT WE
WENT AHEAD AND MADE ADDITIONAL
MORE REQUIREMENTS FROM THE
APPLICANTS. ALTHOUGH OUR
APPLICATION PROCESS OUR OUR
ACTUAL APPLICATION PACKET WITH
A TWENTY SIX PAGE APPLICATION
PACKET FROM THE INCEPTION AND
IN THE SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHEN THE CITY STARTED
THIS PROGRAM WE DESIGNATED A
WEBSITE. AND EVERY ACTION THAT
EITHER THE PLANNING COMMISSION
WAS TAKEN ANY ACTION THAT THE
CITY COUNCIL ACTION WAS TAKEN
NOT ONLY WAS IT UNDER A PUBLIC
HEARING WHERE WE DID THE PRIOR
NOTICING SO THAT EVERYBODY FROM
THE PUBLIC HAD THE OPPORTUNITY.
BUT EVERY ACTION THAT IS TAKEN
AS POSTED ON THE CITY'S WEBSITE
IF YOU PRINT THE CITY'S WEBSITE
NOW JUST DESIGNATED ON CANNABIS
FACTS IT'S ABOUT A TWENTY SIX
PAGE DOCUMENT- HAVE ARE TO THE
ORDINANCE TO THE APPLICATION
ALL OF THE INFORMATION. WAS
THAT'S A AND MEANS. ON THE AS
WELL. I'M AT AND I IN HE DID I
THE CITY OF REQUIRES IT
AGREEMENT FROM THE CAN OP.
EVERY ALL BUILDING FOR PER
EVERY ALL THAT THE MEET ALL
STATE REQUIREMENTS AND A
BUSINESS LICENSE AND ONLY THEN
WILL THE CITY ISSUE A
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS PERMIT-
THIS THIS PROCESS STARTED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OF THE
SUMMER WERE NOW IN EARLY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN OUT OF THE
TWENTY NINE OPERATORS ONLY
THREE APPLICANTS ARE ONLY
OPERATING SO TO ME IT JUST
SHOWS THAT IT IS A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE LONG. AS TO BASED
UP START THAT PROCESS AND THE
TO ECHO OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MR GLASSMAN WE TO WE WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AND HER
STAFF FOR HAPPY TO GO OVER ANY
OF THE INCREASE IS CONCERNS
THAT SHE ASKED. WE JUST MIGHT
HAVE THE UPPER. SKIP PROSSER
AND COME TO AND TO PUT HAVE
ABOUT AND THIS REQUIRE. THAT
WOULD BE UNFORTUNATE OKAY THEY
YOU. AT THIS TIME OF THE
NOTICEABLE COMMENTED WE GOT
BOTH CITIES I THINK WE'RE GOOD
THIS TIME I'M RETURNING BACK TO
THE DíAS ASK FOR- QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE DICE BUT
LET ME BEGIN JUST BY ASKING YOU
TO THE CITIES. HAS THERE BEEN A
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT THE AUDITS AND YOU
MENTIONED THE HIGH RISK GOT ITS
BUT CAN I ASK WAS RECIPROCALLY
HAS EITHER THE OTHER. EVER DONE
AUDIT LOOKING AT JUST THE
CONTRACTING OR THE LICENSING OF
CANNABIS AND WITHIN THE CITY'S.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH RESPECT TO
HUNTINGTON PARK UP AS I
INDICATED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN- WE MET WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE CITY
FROM THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
TO REVIEW THE SIMILAR
QUESTIONS- EXCLUDING CANNABIS
ISSUES. A SIMILAR QUESTIONS
WITH RESPECT TO THE OF
MANAGEMENT OF CONTRACTING
WITHIN THE CITY. ARE AFTER
CAREFUL REVIEW BY THE STATE
AUDITOR BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IT WAS BE ELECTED NOT
TO MOVE FOR BY THE BY THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE. TO TAKE ANY
STEPS FOR THE TWO OF A FORMAL
AUDIT. OF I GUESS ANOTHER WAY
OF RESPONDING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IS. UP
EVERY COUNCIL MEETING THOSE
ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED- THEY ARE
EXAMINED BOTH BY MR REYES AND
HIS STAFF AND ALSO BY THE CITY
COUNCIL AND AS I INDICATED.
THEY ARE NOT PLACED ON CONSENT
THE HANDLED ITEM BY ITEM ON THE
CITY COUNCIL CALENDAR ARE NEVER
CAME TO ME. THANK YOU. I CAN
CAN. HI AND ON MY BE TO THE
HIGH RISK PART. OF ACTUALLY
HAVE. WELL LET ME. RIGHT WILL
TURN IT TO THE ASSEMBLY WELL
LET ME START WITH QUESTIONS AND
I'M SURE IT'LL COME UP AND
QUESTIONS AS WELL- BUT
LISTENING TO SET HER OFF THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW THE
FIRST NOTE YOU KNOW THERE
APPEAR TO BE SOME PROCESS
ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO THIS
AUDIT IN TERMS OF NOTIFICATION
TO SO MY COLLEAGUES AT LEAST.
ONE OF WHOM WHO SITS ON THIS
COMMITTEE WHO REPRESENTS THE
CITY HERE IN TERMS OF
NOTIFICATION OF THE YACHT IT.
WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT.
SOMEHOW SOME TIME IN ANOTHER
WAY BUT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
NOTIFICATION TO THE ROLE
RESPONDING CITIES- SIR DID I
UNDERSTAND YOU TO SAY THAT YOU
ONLY HAD ONE WEEK NOTICE OF
THIS AUDIT. QUESTION MR MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND SENATOR THE
ANSWER TO THAT IS YES- WE WERE
NOT COPIED ON THE ORIGINAL
LETTER SO THEY WON'T LET ME
FOLLOW WITH THAT THEN SO I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WE DON'T I
DON'T LIKE TO DO BUSINESS THAT
WAY. ARE THOSE OF THE OUTCOME.
SO WHAT WOULD ADDITIONAL TIME
DO FOR YOU AS A CITY IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO RESPOND TO
THIS AUDIT REQUEST BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE. THIS IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO TELL US WHY YOU
NEED MORE TIME. YES MISTER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. IT
WOULD GIVE EACH CITY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GATHER THE
REQUISITE- DOCUMENTS ORDINANCES
AGENDAS OF. THE VERY OTHER
ELEMENTS THIS APPROVAL PROCESS
AND PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE
AND THEN- AND TO STATE AUDITOR
INTO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN ALSO.
THE A COMPREHENSIVE-
UNDERSTANDING OF THE STEPS THAT
THE CITY'S TAKE IN ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES THAT ARE BEFORE
YOU- AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ADDITIONAL TIME WOULD ALLOW
THIS COMMITTEE TO BE. BETTER
INFORMED ON EXACTLY WHAT- WHAT
STEPS CITIES DO TAKE IN ORDER
TO MEET THE QUESTIONS AT HAND.
SO WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A CONTINUANCE OF THE
POSTPONEMENT AND WE BELIEVE WE
CAN EACH CITY CAN MAKE A
COMPELLING A STATEMENT AS TO
THE FACT THAT BOTH CITIES ARE
IN FULL COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
LAW WITH AUDITING PROCEDURES
AND WITH THE WHAT IS THE GOAL
AND OBJECTIVE IS THE- OF THIS
COMMITTEE. SO I GUESS MY NEXT
QUESTION IS TO THE OTHER
PROPONENT GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THIS. JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE MEETS ON A REGULAR
BASIS DURING THE COURSE OF THE-
OF THE YEAR AND WILL DO SO THIS
YEAR IS THERE ANY REASON TO.
FOR US TO. MAKE A DECISION ON
THIS PARTICULAR AUDIT ON THIS
PARTICULAR DAY AS OPPOSED TO
GIVING THE CITY'S ADDITIONAL
TIME TO RESPOND TO THE OTHER
REQUEST AND TO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER
WHATEVER THEY PRESENT I MEAN
I'M ASSUMING. YOU KNOW MORE
ABOUT THE REQUEST AND I DO YOU
KNOW MORE ABOUT THE SITUATION
IN THE CITIES AND I DO. YOU'VE
JUST HEARD THE RATIONALE FOR
WANTING MORE TIME MAYBE THAT
HAS VALIDITY MAYBE IT DOESN'T
BUT- I GUESS I THINK MY
QUESTION THANK YOU SENATOR OFF
YES- SELECT TWO ITEMS- TALKING
ABOUT BOTH CITIES OFFENSE. THE%
HIGH RISK DESIGNATION OR LACK
THERE OFF AND IN PART BECAUSE
OF ITALY MENTIONED THE WORK
WHEN YOU IDENTIFY POTENTIAL IN
THE MET WITH THE AUDITOR THE
QUESTION I'M ASKING ARE NOT
RELATED TO THE HIGHER RISK. A
DESTINATION WITH THE AUDITOR
CAN EXPLAIN THAT A LITTLE BIT
BETTER ON TO DEADLINE A
CLARIFICATION. WELL MY QUESTION
HAS A HOLD ON IT SO I WILL WILL
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION WHICH IS
WHY WITH FAMILY LATER NOT IS
YOUR PART. BUT I WANTED TO TAKE
OPPORTUNITY CLARIFY THAT PIECE
OF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU WELL
THAT'S FINE I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE SOMEBODY. YEAH I'M A
CUSTOM EVERY NOW AND THEN I
WILL ANSWER IT WHEN MY OTHER
CAREER I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SIT AT THE DíAS AND- GO IN A
DIFFERENT SET OF CLOTHES AND-
AND SOMEBODY'S THEY NEEDED
ADDITIONAL TOP MY LISTEN TO THE
RECORD. BEEN DECIDED WHETHER
THE ADDITIONAL TIME REQUEST FOR
ALL OF THE ORIGINAL THIS WAS
REASONABLE AND SECOND WHETHER
THE ADDITIONAL TIME REQUEST WAS
REASONABLE ON IT WHETHER IT WAS
GOING TO LEAD O A MORE
PRODUCTIVE. AND I'M DECISION
AND SO SOME NEEDS TO. THE LAST
ACTUALLY. BUT HONESTLY IN A
QUEST SO WILL HAVE ANSWER
SECOND I BE ONE NO PROBLEM. SO
WE HAVE HAD THE SHORT. SEC IS
ONE. THE PART FOR THAT THERE
PROCESS CANNABIS. EIGHTEEN IS A
COMMERCE STARTED THEIR- ON
CANNABIS. NOW WE HAVE THE CITY
HUNTINGTON PARK WHEN NEXT.
MONTEBELLO STARTING THEIR PA.
WITHIN A RELEASE. WINDOW TIME
WE'VE HAD. THIS LARGE. OF
CANNABIS IN THE COMMUNITY. I AM
FOR LEGALIZING REGULATING- AND
FOR THESE BUSINESSES FINING
HOMES- THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
THAT INCLUDES YOU KNOW MY
BACKYARD. ON MAY BE CLEAR THAT.
I THINK AT THAT RATE AT WHICH
THE GROWTH IS HAPPENING. I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ASK THE
QUESTION ARE WE USING DESPERATE
BEST PRACTICES AS THIS IS
GROWING. AND IF WE ARE. THEN
GREAT LET ME CONGRATULATE YOU
UNLESS MAKE SURE ALL CITIES
AROUND THE AREA ARE YOU SEEN
THOSE PRACTICES AND THEY WERE
NOT. THAT WE EARLY ON THE SIDE
OKAY THIS IS NOT HOW WE SHOULD
BE YOU KNOW LET'S FIX IT. SO
THAT I CITIES ARE LOOKING TO
EACH OTHER TO MOVE FORWARD AND
BRING IN THIS BUSINESSES. WERE
DOING IT IN THE BEST. POSSIBLE
WAY- I. I DO NOT KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO THE WAITER THAT THINGS
ARE GONNA CHANGE WHEN OUR-
EXPIRATION IS ABOUT. BEST
PRACTICES AND- YOU KNOW IF THE
CITIES ARE DOING THAT THEN THEY
CREATE A MODEL FOR OTHER
CITIES. ARE NOW QUICKLY LOOKING
TO EXPAND AT LOOKING AT WHAT
NEIGHBORING. ARE GETTING. I
THINK THAT THAT GOT WHAT MY-
LISTENERS. BY AND IT COULD BE
SO. I SHOULD ALSO GET INTO THIS
ALONG THE WAY AND SO WE HAVE.
THIS DOMINO EFFECT. I TRIED ON.
I'M SORRY TO SAY THAT I DIDN'T
THAT'S WHAT AT THIS TIME. LET
ME SAY THIS I WE DON'T GET
MATERIAL VERY EARLY OURSELVES
AND WE'RE NOT BEING. TO A STATE
AUDIT SO I'M ALL ABOUT DUE
PROCESS AROUND HERE AND I THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD RECEIVE
INFORMATION IN A IN A TIMELY
MANNER AND IN A MANNER THAT'S
DESIGNED TO GIVE THEM AN
ADEQUATE OPPORTUNITY. TO
PRESENT THE CASE AS TO WHY WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE A STATE ON IT
BECAUSE OF COURSE EVERY TIME WE
VOTE FOR NOT IT. IT'S SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN THREE AND FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OUT OF THE
STATE AUDITOR'S BUDGET NOW IF
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE ON IT I
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT- I.
FRANKLY WAS AND I AM PREPARED
TO VOTE FOR THIS AUDIT-
PROVIDED MY COLLEAGUES WHO- HAD
A NOTICE PROBLEM HERE IT. IS
OKAY WITH THAT. BUT HAVING SAID
THAT I ALSO THINK THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT COME BEFORE US I TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THE MATTERS. IN SUPPORT OF
THEIR POSITION AND IF PEOPLE
ARE GETTING TWO OR THREE DAYS
OR FIVE DAYS NOTICE OF ANOTHER
REQUEST IN YOUR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- THAT MAY NOT BE
SUFFICIENT AND THAT'S- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THAT'S WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IT'S AT THIS
POINT MORE THE OPTIC TO ME.
THAN THE DECISION AND THE
DECISION MAY IN FACT BE THE
VERY SAME DECISION- THAT ON THE
FACE OF IT I'M PREPARED TO MAKE
TODAY BUT I CERTAINLY WOULD
WANT PEOPLE WHO. DON'T HAVE
THAT SAME POSITION TO CAN HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THEIR
SO THAT'S THE PURPOSE FOR MY
QUESTION AND I'M NOT SURE WHEN-
TO BE HONEST MYSELF WOULD
COMMITTEE. SENDS OUT THOSE
REQUESTS I MEAN THE FOCUSES OR
NOT YEAH SO THERE'S A PRETTY
TWO PARTS THAT QUESTION SENATE
ROTH RIGHT ONE IS- PROCEDURAL
IF WITH THE CITY WHICH YOU KNOW
STARKLY WE'VE- HI. THANK AT
LEAST FOUR FIVE TEARS NOW.
ABOUT FOLLOW THAT PROCEURE IN
TERMS OF GETTING THE MATERIAL
TEACHER THE J. LACK MEMBER SO
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN A FIGHTER
TO. ABBOTT SECONDLY I THINK
WITHIN A ROTH IS ASKING
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IS YOU KNOW
REACHING OUT TO THE CITY THAT
ARE AFFECTED POSSIBLY. AND
MAYBE IF THAT CAN BE DONE MAYBE
IN THE FUTURE AS OTHER PEOPLE
ARE LISTENING TO THIS HEARING
AS WELL. OTHER AUTHORS BABY
MINDFUL OF AS WELL. SO I THINK
THAT'S A WAY OF UNDERSTANDING
IT AS WELL AND I KNOW WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF FAIR ENOUGH LATEST
YOU LET THE COMMITTEE. THAT NOT
TO THE AFFECTED HM IN A- OUT OF.
STATEMENT THAT YOU'RE MAKING TO
MYSELF AND OUR COLLEAGUES AS
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THIS
MOVING FORWARD. WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD THEN SENATOR GONZALEZ AND
TO SEND HER MONEY. PLEASE
MISTER WHAT THANK YOU- THROUGH
THE TRAFFIC COUPLE QUESTIONS
AND IT'S- TRYING TO UNDERSTAND-
SOMETHING- TO YOU TALKED ABOUT.
PERMITS. YOU TALK ABOUT
CONTRACT. SO I'M UNCLEAR THE
CONTRACTING PART OF THAT SO CAN.
EXPLAIN TO ME. IS THE CITY
CONTRACTING WITH CANNABIS
BUSINESSES. OR YOU CONTRACTING
WITH PEOPLE PROVIDING SERVICES
THAT ARE AIMED AT HELPING
CANNABIS BUSINESSES BECOME
COMPLIANT WITH WITH THE CITY
YEAH PERHAPS WE COULD HAVE THE
CITY'S RESPOND PLEASE YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PERMITTED
DRESS THE MEMBERS CERTAINLY S.
UP. MY READ OF THE LETTER IS
NOT AS RICH TO CONTRACTING IS
NOT RELATIVE TO CANNABIS ISSUES
IS RELATED TO JUST GENERAL
CONTRACTING PRACTICES OF THE
CITY THAT'S MY READING THE
LETTER. OUR STATE CANNABIS
ELEMENT HOWEVER DOES ADDRESS
HOW LICENSES ARE ISSUED AND THE
DEVELOPMENT CONTRACTING
ELEMENTS OF THAT NO TURN OVER
MISS COMPETITIVE. I WANT TO
WEAR A OF KIND. AS PART OF A
CANNABIS- PERMITTING PROCESS SO
I THAT'S THAT'S AND LOOK AND I
SAT ON MY AYE AYE HELP RIGHT
THE ORIGINAL THING- MEDICAL
CANNABIS REGULATORY SAFETY ACT
AND THERE'S A LOT OF. THE NEW
LAWS ARE BASED ON THAT BUT I
NEVER I CANNOT REMEMBER THE USE
OF THE WORD CONTRACTING
ANYTHING YOU HAVE THAT
DOCUMENTATION AND I APOLOGIZE I
THINK WHAT WHAT WE'RE DIRECTING
IS BASED ON THE RESPONSE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA'S
LETTER. SHE HAS A LIST NINE
QUESTIONS AND THERE'S TWO
UMBRELLAS TO DIFFERENT TOPICS
WHEN IS CANNABIS LICENSING
PRACTICES. IN A SEPARATE PART
IS THE CITY'S CONTRACT. UP UP
PRACTICES SO WHERE THEY ARE I
DID THE I IN THIRD THEY'RE
RELATED WITH NOT THAT. BY
CITIES CONTRACTING WITH KIND OF
PROVIDERS A MESSAGE LIKE CLUB
SO I'VE GOT A THING BUT I THINK
THE CONTRA WITH INDIVIDUALS
HELP CREATE THE STANDARDS FOR
HOW THEY'RE GONNA BE AWARDING.
LICENSES AND STUFF LIKE THAT SO
THOSE THOSE CONTRACTS AT THE
LAFAYETTE CONTRACTING PRACTICES
BUT NOT DIRECTLY WITH THAT THIS
MYTH THAT AND THAT WOULD BE MY
UNDERSTAND SENATE THERE ARE
BUSINESSES THAT. THEIR WORK WAS.
WITH YOU KNOW HELP WITH. IN
GUIDE FOR APPROPRIATE
APPROPRIATE NOW FOR THE SO A
COUPLE. I'M SET SIR OF
SURPRISED QUITE FRANKLY THIS
THAT HAVE A- ROUGHLY. CANNABIS
PERMIT FOR LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED RESIDENTS IN THE CITY
OF COMMERCE THAT SEEMS. LIKE A
PRETTY HIGH NUMBER IF I'M
READING YOUR POPULATION OF
THIRTEEN THOUSAND AND TWENTY
NINE LICENSES THAT. THAT'S A
BIG NUMBER- ARE THESE- PERMITS
MANUFACTURING EIGHTEEN OR THE
DISTRIBUTION OR THE CULTIVATION
OR THEY MEAN WHAT ARE THEY
BECAUSE CERTAINLY IF YOU GOT TO
NINE RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS
THERE YOU GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS TOMORROW.
AND I TO BE ARE VERY SPECIFIC
THE CITY OF COMMERCE DOES NOT
HAVE ANY STOREFRONT DISPENSARY
NONE OF THE BUSINESSES ARE
OPENED TO THE PUBLIC EVERYTHING
IS CULTIVATION MANUFACTURING
DISTRIBUTION AND THERE IS A NON
STOREFRONT DELIVERY. BUT ALL OF
THE BUSINESSES ARE CLOSED TO
THE PUBLIC OKAY ALL RIGHT
THAT'S THAT'S HELPFUL ELSA. BUT
IF I MAY- I'D LIKE TO ALSO MAKE
ONE CLEAR FIND POINT- O CENTER
ROTS QUESTION EARLIER ABOUT
REASONS WHY NOT TO HAVE DECIDED
I THINK I CAN PROVIDE WHEN AT
LEAST ACTUALLY THINK THAT WE
KIND OF DRESS THAT IT'S MY TURN
TO HAVE CAUGHT. THE RIGHT ARE
THIS IS ALSO ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION IS ONE THAT TERMS OF
THE CITY BRING TARA JENS
INSTANCE OF THE CITY FUNDING TO
MARKET IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE CITY. HAS ONLY ISSUE
THREE LICENSES PERMISSIBLE COLD
A WE WILL WE WILL NOT ISSUE ANY
MORE THAN ANY GIVEN TIME- THESE
BUSINESS LICENSES WERE ISSUED
BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE CITY AND ALL THE
APPLICATION. SEND RISEN ONE YOU
APPLICATIONS THE CITY'S CURRENT
TRIGGERING THERE HASN'T SINCE
TWENTY. SO IN TERM OF RELEVANT
OF THIS TOP. I JUST FEEL
HUNTINGTON IS BE POORLY. AND
UNFAIRLY TARGETED BECAUSE
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG CITY
ATTORNEY US GIVE TURN CITY
ATTORNEY UP I BELIEVE OUR-
MUNICIPAL COURT WAS MODELED OFF
THE STATE'S- MEDICAL MARIJUANA
REGULATIONS. WELL ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE- YOU KNOW THAT
THE STATE THE STATE. GRANTS
LICENSES BASED ON ON ON A
CITIES- PERMISSION TO OPERATE
SO BUT WE DO NOT DICTATE HOW
THE CITY ACTUALLY. GOVERNMENTS
IT'S CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND WHAT
I MEAN WE SET THE FLOOR NOT A
CEILING SO YOU CAN BE A LOT
MORE RESTRICTIVE AT THE CITY
LEVEL THAN THAN WHAT WE WEEK WE-HAVE DONE AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND WE'RE VERY RESTRICTIVE SO-
SO I. I'M I'M STILL YOU KNOW
I'M GONNA I'M I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE AUDIT TODAY BUT I
I'M I'M- I'M JUST. STILL
THERE'S PARTS OF THIS THAT MAKE
ME UNCOMFORTABLE. I FRANKLY AND
I THINK LOOKING AT THAT THANK
YOU MISTER WOOD. OKAY WITH THAT
LET'S GO TO MOVE TO SENATOR
GONZALEZ. YES THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND YOU KNOW I SURE
THE SAME SENTIMENT I KNOW WE
SPOKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
APPRECIATE YOU YOU KNOW
REACHING OUT BUT IT WAS
CERTAINLY AFTER THE FACT AND IT
WAS SURPRISING TO ME OF COURSE
THAT MY CITY WAS BEING AUDITED
WITHOUT MY KNOWLEDGE SO PUT ME
IN A POSITION- HERE I AM ON THE
COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY WILLING
TO WORK AND I THINK THAT. I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR COMMERCE BUT I
CAN SPEAK FOR HUNTING PARK
THERE CERTAINLY WILLING TO
LEAVE THE AUDIT AND DO
EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED TO DO
TO ASSURE THAT THEY'RE
FOLLOWING BY STATE LAW AND
GUIDELINES. YOU KNOW BUT THERE
PROCESS AND SO I KNOW WE ARE AT
NOW HAVE A FEW QUICK AND I KNOW
UP AGAIN RESPECT INTO PARK I TO
THE STATE- ALSO IF YOU KNOW
JUST HAVE. A REAL TOUGH TIME
WITH THIS. BECAUSE I GET IT
THERE BEEN A YOU KNOW NEWS
ARTICLES WE'VE SEEN YOU KNOW
MANY THINGS ABOUT THE SOUTHEAST
BUT UNFORTUNATELY- NOT
RESPECTIVE TO JUST THESE TWO
CITIES THOUGH. AND SO I WOULD
SAY YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAVE A
GOAL OF LOOKING AT THE REGION
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THE
REGION AND I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO SIT DOWN.
FIRST WITH ME THEM MANY OF
THESE CITIES TO ENSURE THAT
WERE CAPTURING ALL. KIND OF
FEEL THAT THIS WAS YOU KNOW
SORT OF AN ARBITRARY LIKE WE'RE
GONNA JUST PICK AND CHOOSE WHO
WE WANT TO. AT TO WHO WE WANT
TO AUDIT THAT MAKES ME FEEL AN
EASY. I'M BUT A QUESTION FOR
THE AUDITOR IS THERE WAS A AN
AUDIT THAT OCCURRED I THINK IT
WAS IT DIDN'T GET COMPLETED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WITH THE CITY
OF HUNTINGTON PARK. AND IT DID
MENTION IT WAS A REGARDING
FUTURE FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS
AND SORT OF A POTENTIAL HIGH
RISK IT DID MENTION CONTRACTING
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU. I DON'T
KNOW WHERE THAT WS AT AND SO I
WANT TO KNOW WHERE THAT WAS AT
RELATIVE TO WHERE WE'RE AT NOW
WITH THIS AUDIT RIGHT AND I
MIGHT HAVE A MISTER TILDEN
ASSIST ME WITH THIS. BUT WHAT
WHAT THE CITY IS REFERRING TO
WHEN YOU WERE REFERRING TO
SENATOR IS WHEN WE WHEN WE
CONDUCT THE ANALYSIS THE HIGH
LEVEL ANALYSIS SAYS MR CHILDREN
WAS REFERRING TO EARLIER. AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT FISCAL
INDICATORS- YEAH- AS FAR AS YOU
KNOW ABILITY TO PAY THEIR BILLS
AND SHORT TERM LONG TERM DO
THEY HAVE SUFFICIENT FUNDS IN
RESERVE. AND OF THOSE
INDICATORS APPEAR TO US TO
SUGGEST THAT THE CITY IS UNDER
FISCAL. CONSTRAINT THEN WE WILL
GO OUT COCKED AN ASSESSMENT IT
IS NOT AN AUDIT WE DO NOT A
STATUTORY STODDARD AUTHORITY TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT. LOCAL HIGH
RISK PROGRAM UNTIL THIS
COMMITTEE APPROVES IT SO WHAT
WE DID IS WE WENT OUT AND
CONDUCT AN ASSESSMENT
ESSENTIALLY WHAT AN ASSESSMENT
IS GOING OUT MEET. IF IT PULLS
IT DOING SO FOLKS LOOKING AT
SOME DOCUMENTS BUT ONE. THING
BUT IT WORKS WELL TEST CONTRA.
WE'RE NOT TESTING EXPENDITURES
THOSE ARE THINGS WERE JUST
HAVING. BILLY AKON. OUGHT TO
GET A FEEL FOR WHETHER OR NOT
WE THINK THE CITY HAS. PLUS
PLACE IF THERE IN IN OUR
STRUGGLING WITH. ODD REVENUES
OVER THERE EXPENDITURES ARE ARE
TOO HIGH EACH YEAR- SO. ONCE WE
COMPLETE THAT ASSESSMENT THEN
WE HAVE TO MAKE A DETERMINATION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT SUFFICIENT
CONCERN. TO COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND ASK FOR AN AUDIT.
IN THE CASE OF HUNTINGTON PARK
WE DID THE ASSESSMENT. IT
COMPARED TO OTHER CITIES THAT
WE HAD LOOKED AT IT DIDN'T RISE
TO THE LEVEL OF SOMETHING WE
THOUGHT WE SHOULD COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE. SO WE MAY HAVE
LOOKED AT CONTRA I'M SORRY I
DON'T HAVE ALL THE DETAILS- WE
MAY HAVE TALKED TO THEM ABOUT
THEIR CONTRACTING. DISS BUT WE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T CONDUCT AUDIT
WORK. IN ACTUALLY TEST CONTRA
LOOKING OUT THERE PROCESS FOR
REPORTING CONTRACTS. AND
MONITORING CONTRACT BUT BASED
ON THAT ASSESSMENT. THERE
WASN'T ANYTHING OF SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN TO US. THAT WOULD
GENERATE AN AUDIT REQUESTS TO
THIS COMMITTEE SO I HOPE THAT
HELPS ANSWER YOUR- OKAY AND
THEN I KNOW THAT- ASSEMBLY
WOMAN YOU'D MENTIONED SOME
ARTICLES BUT WAS THERE ANYTHING
RECENT THAT WAS. STRIKING TO
WARRANT THIS- PARTICULAR AUDIT
REQUEST FOR THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON PARK I THINK THAT'S
WERE LOOKING AS BUT AT A TRYING
TO IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES AND
OF THE CITY FIFTEEN BEST
PRACTICES THAT WAS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHO'S BEEN DOING
THIS IS SOMEONE THAT HAS. THE
SLIGHT LONGER PROCESS THAN A
CUP AND THAT WE COULD THEN SAY
OKAY LET'S LOOK AT THIS AND DO
THEY HAVE EXAMPLES OF THINGS
THAT THEY DID OR YOU KNOW THAT
MAKES SENSE ON AND WE CAN SAY
WELL HERE'S A COUPLE OF THE
WITH THE THING THAT MAKES THIS
REBEKAH BEST PRACTICES. IN
THOSE DAYS. THIS TIME WHO HAVE
HAD A SOME LICENSES OUT THERE
FOR WHILE- WITH THE
LEGALIZATION OF IT IT'S THE YOU
KNOW IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
GROWING RAPIDLY NOW ON THAT
WITHIN HALF WE HAVEN'T HAD TOO
MANY YEARS FOR. I THINK IT'S
FOR ME MAKING SURE AS IS.
EXPANDING IN THE BEST POSSIBLE
WAY SINCE- WE STEP BACK TO THE
EARLY BUT OTHER PEOPLE FACT.
APPLIQUE OKAY. I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION HERE PLEASE SENATOR
YES RIGHT I'LL I'LL HURRY IT UP
OKAY SO ONE MORE THING I WOULD
JUST SAY- I THINK THAT ANSWERED
ALL OF MY QUESTIONS I SO I'M
TEETERING BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS BUT THE FIRST AT
QUESTION I'LL ASK YOU IS
WHETHER HE'D BE- YOU'D BE OKAY
POSTPONING THIS UNTIL YOU SIT
DOWN WITH THE LEASE. AND THEN
WE CAN START A NOT AT THAT
POINT. WELL I THINK I GUESS I
DON'T- WHEN AUDIT STARTED ON
SALE AT THE PASSES THE OUTER
COAST I'M NOT SURE I MEAN I
WOULD SAY THAT I WOULD. REQUEST
THAT THE VOTE FOR THE LATTER TO
STARE AT SOME POINT B. TAKEN
TODAY WHEN KERR WORK ACTUALLY
STARTS AND SO FORTH. I'M
WILLING TO SAY THAT MAYBE SEE
START OFFICIALLY A MONTH FROM
NOW OR SOMETHING WHEN I OR
WHATEVER I DON'T KNOW BUT I
WOULD SAY THAT WE'RE NOT PLAN
TO HAVE A MEETING FOR A COUPLE
MONTHS AT LEAST. I AND- SO WHAT
CAN MAYBE I CAN ADD SOME
CLARITY HERE SO THERE'S TWO
THINGS WE CAN DO WITH THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE. THREE ONE IS. TO PUT.
THE ENTIRE. AND OUR NECKS
REGULAR SCHEDULED ONE WHICH
WE'RE ANTICIPATING THE FIRST
WEEK OF AUGUST. OR WE CAN DO IS
APPROVE IT TODAY AND ASK THE
AUDITOR IF SHE WOULD DELAY- THE
AUDIT GOING INTO THE CITIES. SO
WE'VE DONE THAT IN THE PAST AS
WELL THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR THAT
AS WELL SO THOSE ARE OPTIONS-
BUT OF COURSE IS CONTINGENT
UPON. THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN SINCE
IT IS RIDE IT. AND BEYOND
NEGOTIATIONS OR- DISCUSSIONS
WITH THAT MEMBERS OF THE DICE.
I MEAN I WOULD SAY WAITING
UNTIL AUGUST. TROUBLING TO ME
BUT- THE LATE IN. OF THAT THE
CHAIRMAN HAS STATED TO
SOMETHING I'M COMFORTABLE WITH.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT- I WOULD LIKE
TO THEN SAY- YOU KNOW IF WE
WERE ABLE TO POSTPONE AND I
WOULD PREFER THAT- TO WAIT TO
OUR NEXT- MEETING JUST TO GIVE
THIS THESE- TO CITIES TIME TO
DISCUSS AND SIT DOWN WITH YOU-
IF YOU'D BE WILLING TO DO THAT.
WOULD BE MUCH APPRECIATED I'D
BE WILLING TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU
TO ENSURE THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT FOR THE SOUTHEAST REGION.
AND ENSURE THAT THERE'S MORE
CITIES THAT WE CAN INCLUDE IF
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AS WELL.
I'M MY PREFERENCES THAT WE VOTE
FOR A TWO DAY I THINK WAITING
THAT MANY MONTHS FOR A VOTE AND
THEN- IT MAKES ME UNCOMFORTABLE
UP HAVING A VOTE THAT THIS WILL
HAPPEN BUT ALLOWING THE AUDITOR
TO DELAY HER WORK WOULD BE WHAT
I'M MORE COMFORTABLE WITH- I
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT EXTRA
TIMES GOING TO SWITCH THE
REQUEST- AND THE WORK THAT THE
AUDITOR HAVE TO DO. CUT SO THEY
GO FROM THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SHE'S A- MORE COMFORTABLE WITH-
THE AUDITOR DELAYING WHEN SHE
ACTUALLY GOES INTO THE CITIES.
BUT I THAT LET'S GO TO MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WILL COME
BACK TO THIS BECAUSE SOUNDS
LIKE SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA NEED
TO COME BACK TO. REMOVED OKAY.
SENATOR ROBB MISTER MISTER
CHAIR I'D PLEASE CENTER MINING
IS WILLING TO LET ME JUST
SUPPLEMENT MY- COMMENT. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
CLEAR ON THE RECORD ONE OF THE
ADVANTAGES. TO ALLOWING
RESPONDING ENTITIES TO BE
PREPARED WHEN THEY COME IN
HERE. IS WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING TO DEFINE
THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT. AND
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A FULL PLATE
OF INFORMATION. THAT'S
PRESENTED ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
WHEN WE VOTE TO APPROVE AN
AUDIT OR NOT. WE DON'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHAPE THE SCOPE
OF AN ART. AND THAT'S PART OF
THE REASON WHY I'M INTERESTED
IN DUE PROCESS WHY I WANT
PEOPLE TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE ADEQUATE NOTICE TO COME
IN HERE WITH THEIR BRIEF CASE
FULL OF MATERIAL. AND TRY TO
CONVINCE US. EITHER TO NOT VOTE
FOR THE AUDIT OR TO VOTE FOR
THE AUDIT AND TO VOTE FOR A
FOCUSED ON IT. OR RESHAPE
DOTTED AND THAT'S MY POINT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU RESTAURANTS LET ME JUST ASK
THE AUDITOR MAYBE THIS OP
CLARIFY A LOT OF THINGS FOR A
LOT OF FOLKS- MAN WATER YOU'RE-
LOOKING AT THE SCOPE OF. MISS
GARCIA'S LETTER DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT EVEN CHANGING
VERY MUCH EVEN IF WE ALLOWED
ADDITIONAL TIME GIVEN THAT
WE'RE ONLY LOOKING AT THE
CONTRACTING IN CANNABIS
LICENSING. I'D IN YOUR- HISTORY
IN YOUR- EXPERIENCE HAVE YOU
SEEN MUCH CHANGE. OVER THE
COURSE OF A COUPLE MONTHS WELL
AGAIN IT. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
IT'S A TO MEMBERS REQUESTS SO
IF SHE WOULD HAVE TO BE
CONVINCED BY THE CITIES. THAT
THEY HAVE PROVIDED- APPROPRIATE
MATERIALS TO HER AND HER STAFF.
OUT TO CONVINCE HER THAT SHE
DOESN'T FEEL THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE A STATE AUDITOR ARE AN
AUDIT OF APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE DIRECTING MY OFFICE
TO GO IN AND- ASSESS THEIR
CONTRACTING PRACTICES AND
ASSESS THEIR PERMITTING
PRACTICES- WE CERTAINLY. WE
TYPICALLY DON'T ENGAGE WITH AN
ENTITY ARE IF AN ORDER IS AN
APPROVED WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
PLENTY OF WORK FOR US TO DO FOR
THE AUDITS THAT THE COMMITTEE.
APPROVES TODAY NOW CERTAINLY WE
WANT TO BE OF SERVICE TO
MEMBERS SO IF MS GARCIA'S
OFFICE ENGAGES WITH THE CITIES
SHE RECEIVED MATERIALS SHE
CERTAINLY COULD ASK US TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THE END. BUT IT WON'T
BE BASED ON AN AUDIT IT'LL BE
JUST BASED ON IN A REASONABLE
PERSON- BUT SHE AGAIN- I KNOW
I'M I'M NOT BEING EXTREMELY
HELPFUL HERE IT'S THE MEMBERS
REQUEST AND I CERTAINLY WANT TO
RESPECT THAT. IT'S HER DECISION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT SHE'S
CONVINCED THAT WHAT THE CITY
PROVIDES IS SUFFICIENT TO
ANSWER HER QUESTIONS OKAY THANK
YOU ATWATER ASSEMBLY WOMAN
PLEASE I THINK FOR MYSELF AND
FOR THE COMMUNITY HAVING THAT
THEIR PARTY IN THE- LA ME.
LEANING X. TO AT THIS DOCUMENT
CENTER ON MY QUESTION THIRTY
SAID THE DOCUMENT THAT I WANT
TO SEE AT AGAIN THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT AN INDEPENDENT
AUDIT WOULD GET TO AND A MUCH
BETTER CAPACITY THEM MYSELF.
UNDER OKAY THAT WE HAVE A OF
COURSE SO FROM THE DíAS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO REMINDING THEM
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO THAN
CENTER BORDERS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. ON SO MY
PREFERENCE WOULD BE THAT THE
AUDIT REQUEST BE POSTPONED THAT
THE- ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEET WITH
THE CITIES AND ENGAGE WITH THE
CITY'S WITH HER QUESTIONS AND
IF NOT SATISFIED RETURN. TO
REQUEST THE AUDIT FROM THIS
COMMITTEE. MY CONCERN OF
GRANTING THE ON IT TODAY AND
THEN POSTPONING IT IS THAT
THERE'S THE CITY WAS HER REYES
TO POTENTIAL ADVERSE IMPACT IN
TERMS OF A COMING BALLOT
MEASURES- POTENTIAL
MISINTERPRETATION OF HEADLINES
ABOUT A STATE ON IT. THAT COULD
ADVERSELY IMPACT THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
BOTH SENATOR GONZALEZ AND
SENATOR ROTH. THE WHOLE
QUESTION OF DUE PROCESS I JUST
THESE AUDITS KOSTELANETZ MY TAX
ARE FOOTING THE BILL FOR IT AND
I DON'T SEE WHY ANYONE WOULD
REQUEST AN AUDIT BEFORE ASKING
THE QUESTIONS TO THE ENTITY.
THAT THEY WANT TO AUDIT IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE THAT'S A LOGICAL
FIRST STEP SO- I WILL BE NOT
VOTING- FOR AN AUDIT TO BE.
GENERATED TODAY I'LL BE GLAD TO
WORK WITH THE PARTIES IN THE
CHAIR ON IN TERMS OF TIME
TABLE. ONCE THE COURTESY OF
MEETING WITH THE CITY'S HAS
BEEN AFFORDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR MOUNTING KIT ON
BELIEVE THOSE QUESTION AND THAT
WILL MOVE TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REVIEW. THANK YOU- SO FOR ME-
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT TIME
ISSUE BECAUSE THIS COMMITTEE
THE MEAT ON A MONTHLY BASIS
LIKE MOST OF THE OTHER
COMMITTEE SO I UNDERSTAND WHY
WAITING TO AUGUST WOULD BE A
DIFFICULT- I THINK WE CAN COME
TO MIDDLE GROUND- TO ADDRESS
THE POINT OF OUR MEETING WITH
THE CITIES. TO QUITE HONEST I
DON'T KNOW WHICH QUESTIONS TO
ASK IF I WENT TO A CITY- AND OR
WHEN I HAVE ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE PERHAPS ONLY THE
AUDITOR HAS ACCESS TO SELL TO
YOUR POINT I APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENT HOWEVER IF I AM. YOU
KNOW TRYING TO AUDIT WHEN MY
CITIES WERE I DON'T KNOW WHICH
DOCUMENTS I WOULD NEED- I CAN
GIVE YOU WILL- EXAMPLES OF WHY
I THINK I'M NOT SHOULD BE-
CONDUCTED BUT I WOULDN'T KNOW
WHICH DOCUMENTS I WOULD NEED SO
IN TERMS OF MEETING WITH THE
CITIES I BELIEVE THAT- IF WE
APPROVE AN AUDIT AND POSTPONE
IT I THINK THE CITIES WOULD
HAVE AN- OPPORTUNITY TO.
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AND NOW HE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WOULD HAVE THE
AUDITOR'S YEAR IF YOU WILL TO
BE ABLE TO. GUY THAT AND WHY.
YOU KNOW BUT- OUT. FORMS OF
TARA. QUESTIONS DOES ASSEMBLY
WOMAN COULD NOT THAT'S IN
OPINION I'M AND AGAIN REASON
FOR POSTPONING WOULD BE THAT-
WE DON'T MEET ON A REGULAR
BASIS WE MEET UNTIL AUGUST AND
SO THAT'S THE TIME CONSTRAINT
ISSUES SO I AM IN FAVOR OF. OUR
VOTING FOR THE AUDITS OF BY
POSTPONING IT SO TO GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THIS FOR THE
CITIES TO RESPOND AND AT LEAST
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN WILL HAVE-
THE AUDITOR KIND OF AS A
SOUNDING BOARD OR BECAUSE NOW
THE AUDIT IS YOU KNOW BOB.
APPROVED IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT- THE AUDITOR CAN DO PLEASE
CLARIFY IF YOU CAN'T THEN BEEN
MY WHOLE ARGUMENT IS OUT THE
WINDOW. THE SHERMAN. LEASE SO
IT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF
DISCUSSION NEEDS TO HAPPEN ON
THIS- FAIRLY QUICKLY BUT LET'S
GO AHEAD AND I DIDN'T HEAR A
QUESTION THERE SO LET'S GO TO.
PLEASE ATWATER SO IF THE
COMMITTEE APPROVES AND AGAIN
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS ALLEGE
COUNSEL TO ADVISE ON COMMITTEE
RULES BUT THE WHAT THE
COMMITTEE APPROVES TODAY- WOULD
BE THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT THAT
WE WOULD DO- IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT COMES TO OUR
ATTENTION DURING THE COURSE OF
THE AUDIT LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT
THE PREVIOUS AUDIT ON ON TOXICS
WHERE WE WOULD LOOK AT COST
RECOVERY IF SOMETHING CAME TO
OUR ATTENTION WE COULD EXPAND
THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT BUT WHAT
WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO IS.
IF THIS AUDIT GETS APPROVED-
PERHAPS IT'S DELAYED WE DON'T
START UNTIL JUNE THIS WOULD BE
THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT NOW WE
WOULD BENEFIT FROM IF THE CITY
BELIEVES THEY HAVE A LOT OF
ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
IT WOULD TAKE US TO CONDUCT THE
AUDIT IT WOULD REDUCE THE COST
OBVIOUSLY- BUT WE WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE ENGAGING WITH MS
GARCIA- AS FAR AS OKAY THEY
CITY HAS TOLD US THIS DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THAT NOT HOW THE PROCESS WORKS
ONCE THIS. THIS PROPOSAL THAT
WE PUT TOGETHER ANALYSIS THAT
WE PUT TOGETHER FOR THE
COMMITTEE HAS APPROVED. THIS-BASICALLY DICTATES. THE WORK
THAT WE WOULD DO WE CERTAINLY
CAN DELAY COMMENCING THE AUDIT
AND AGAIN. IF THE CITY'S
RESPECTFULLY HAVE INFORMATION
THAT THEY BELIEVE WOULD.
CONVINCE US THAT ALL OF THESE
PROCESSES ARE TERRIFIC THEN WE
WHAT WE TYPICALLY DO WHEN WE
CONDUCTED NOT IF WE GET INTO AN
ENTITY AND WE SAY WE'RE GONNA
TEST THIRTY ITEMS. AND WE TEST
FIFTEEN WE FIND NO PROBLEMS
IT'S LIKE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
WASTE TIME TESTING ANOTHER
FIFTEEN WE WANT TO KEEP THESE
AUDITS AS COST EFFECTIVE AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT'S THE APPROACH
WE WOULD TAKE IN CONDUCTING THE
ON IT TRYING TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF. A COST BECAUSE WE
ARE VERY SENSITIVE TO YOU KNOW
THE EXPENSE OF THESE AUDITS ON
WE THINK THEY'RE VALUABLE
OBVIOUSLY- BUT THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THE AUDITS
APPROVED THIS WOULD ESSENTIALLY
BE THE SCOPE OF THE WORK. THAT
WE WOULD DO. CUT. YEAH AND
TYPICALLY WHAT WE DO IN
COMMITTEE IS- WILL WE MAKE THE
MOTION WE WOULD ASK FOR A
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
STATE AUDITOR MOVING IN WHICH
WILL. MOST LIKELY DO WITH ONE
ANOTHER ITEM THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN AGREED TO LATER ON IN OUR
AGENDA. SO WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO CENTER BORE
JUST REPLACE THANK CHAIRMAN WAS
ANTICIPATING A COMMENTING ON
THIS BUT THERE. WERE IN THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF ISSUES PUT
FORWARD THAT I THINK. HAS
CAUSED ME TO QUESTION. THE ROLE
OF THIS BODY AND WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE PROCESS SEES ARE.
INTUITIVELY I WOULD THINK THAT
AN AUDIT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE.
WHEN AT A COUPLE THINGS HAVE
ALREADY OCCURRED NAMELY THAT
INFORMATION SAW IT HAS NOT BEEN
PRODUCED. ANSWER QUESTIONS
POSED HAVE NOT ALLOWED FOR-
COMPETENT ANSWERS. OR A LAYER
OF SURFACE- CERTAIN LAYERS OF
SOPHISTICATION ARE REQUIRED ON
THAT ARE OUTSIDE THE DOMAIN OF
A GIVEN LEGISLATIVE OFFICE I
THINK THAT'S ON THOSE ARE NOT
ON FAIR I THINK. PRESUMPTIONS
TO MAKE BEFORE IT ELEVATES TOOL
FOR FULL FLEDGED USE OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO REVIEW
SOMETHING IN IN DETAIL AND I
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT ON
BEFORE I- BEFORE I CAME TO THE
SENATE. AND I THINK THAT THERE
IS SOMETHING TO BE SAID ABOUT
RESPECTING. IN GOING THROUGH A
PROCESS OF A WIN- CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS REPRESENT AREAS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE THE
SUBJECT OF AN AUDIT ON. NOT
JUST WITH THIS ISSUE I MEAN
THERE'S ONE THAT'S GONNA BE
COMING UP ON ITEM ONE OH TWO
THAT WE WERE ONLY RECENTLY MADE
AWARE OF ON THAT MY- THE AREA
THAT I REPRESENT WILL BE THE
SUBJECT OF AN AUDIT. I THINK WE
HEARD FROM THE SENATOR A MOMENT
AGO THAT SAID IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN VERY HELPFUL TO HAVE
GOTTEN A HEADS UP AND MAYBE
QUESTIONS COULD HAVE BEEN
POSED. PRIOR TO THAT IN ANSWERS
GOTTEN- SO I THINK THE WRIST
THERE'S A DUE PROCESS RESPECT
FACTOR THAT I THINK IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD NOT BE
OVERLOOKED. BUT ALSO GIVEN THE
FACT THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO
ELEVATE SOMETHING TO AN AUDIT
IT SAYS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
REQUESTING IT OR THE OFFICE
REQUESTING IT. WITH A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS REQUESTING IT THAT
THEY PUT FORWARD THE DUE
DILIGENCE TO GET ANSWERS TO
THEIR QUESTIONS SPEAK WITH YOUR
WITH ALL PARTIES IN THIS IS A
CITY OR TWO. AND IF THEY CAN'T
GET IT THEN IT BATES WORE THE
LAYER OVER THE AMOUNT OF CITY
CATION ON THE ISSUE REQUIRES
THE INVOCATION OF ODD THE
DEPARTMENT ON THOSE HERE SO
WITH THAT BEING SAID. I'M
SENSITIVE TO THE IDEA THAT-
THERE MIGHT BE A TIMING ISSUE
BUT BEAUSE IT THERE IS A DUE
PROCESS THAT I THINK IS NOT
BEEN FOLLOWED HERE JUST YET THE
IDEA OF LAYING OUT. ON LIVE
AGAIN SUMS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS
SEEMS SLIGHTLY MATURE SO WHY
WOULD I WOULD RESPECT TO WISH
UP. ON THIS SPOKE EARLIER.
MAYBE I COME BACK THE PROBE I'M
IN ALL. IF THE DO YOU DILIGENCE
THAT SHOULD PUT FOR INTO INTO
PRO. DOES NOT YIELD A RESULT TO
ME TO. THANK CENTER BORDERS
LET'S GO TO BACK TO CENTER ROTH.
YOU KNOW I OBVIOUSLY ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
GOOD. WHO JUST SPOKE I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
CLEAR ON THIS AND UNFORTUNATELY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU HAPPEN TO
BE IN MY- LINE OF SIGHT AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S THIS
PARTICULAR AUDIT- IT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE TO ME. THAT AN AUDIT
REQUEST COMES IN HERE IMPACTING
A LOCAL JURISDICTION. WHEN THE
COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENTS A
JURISDICTION IS NOT MADE AWARE
OF THE OTHER REQUEST ONE. TWO
IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO ME WHEN
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE HAVING THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE HAVING TO
RESPOND TO THE OTHER REQUEST.
GET ONE WEEK'S NOTICE.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE FEEL
ABOUT THE CONTENT OF THE
REQUEST REGARDLESS OF HOW WE
COME IN HERE. THINKING THAT
WE'RE GONNA VOTE REGARDLESS OF
WHAT WE THINK WE'RE GONNA VOTE
AFTER WE HEAR THE INITIAL
RESPONSE. I THINK IS A BODY WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT MEANT THAT. ENTITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO DID WHO DO NOT
SERVE HERE. THINK THAT WE SERVE
HERE AT. A PROPERLY AND THAT WE
HAVE CORD PEOPLE WHO COME
BEFORE US. THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF DUE PROCESS. DURING
OUR DELIBERATIONS. HI WILL
UNLESS THINGS CHANGE IN THE
NEXT FEW MINUTES I WILL NOT BE
VOTING- TO SUPPORT THE AUDIT
TODAY. I WOULD SUPPORT A MOVE
OF THE AUDIT TO THE NEXT. I THE
REGULARLY SCHEDULED OR
SPECIALLY SET. A MEETING OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE AND I'M IN FAVOR OF
SPECIALLY SETTING AN AUDIT TO
HEAR YOUR PARTICULAR REQUEST.
AFTER WE GIVE THE INDIVIDUAL
THE ENTITIES INVOLVED AN
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF TIME
WHATEVER THAT ISTO BE
DETERMINED BY YOU. TO COME IN
HERE AND RESPOND TO THE OTHER
REQUEST THE OUTCOME MAY VERY
WELL BE THE SAME BUT IT'S THE
OPTIC IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME. AND
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
TO THE EXTENT THAT I WASN'T
CLEAR. THAT I WAS FUZZY IN MY
COMMENTS BEFORE AND IT HAS I
HAVE ABSOLUTE RESPECT FOR WHAT
YOU DO AND FOR THIS OTHER
REQUEST. I JUST THINK WE NEED
TO DO A LITTLE BIT BETTER ON
THIS ONE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU CENTER ROTH OKAY WITH
THAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND- I
DON'T KNOW IF I'D SIMPLY WOMAN
YOU LIKED RESPOND IF THAT WILL
GO TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
ABOUT ALSO DOES THE SURPLUS AND
ACTUALLY AND LEAVE WE'VE BEEN
HERE FOR AWHILE I THINK WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
SOPHISTICATION I MEAN I HAVE
GONE ONLINE TO LOOK AT WITHOUT
THEIR- AND BEEN TRACKING STUFF
AND- IT'S GOTTEN TO THAT POINT
OF LEVELS OF THE KIDS THAT THIS
OCCASION WHERE IT'S BEYOND. MY
ABILITY AND I THINK ALSO THE
POINT OF WANTING TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT INDEPENDENT OF
US RIGHT AND I COULD HAVE A-
DIFFERENT PROFESSIONAL. LAND SO
I WOULD SAY TO THAT TO THE-
PROCESS TO THE AFFECTED
AGENCIES I JUST ASSUME THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD GIVE THEM.
THROUGH THEIR PROCESS THAT
WOULD HAPPEN AND- YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT PROCESS IS A SOFTWARE THAT
THE SEPARATE CONVERSATION- TO
THE- TO MY CONVERSATIONS- AND
WHAT I COULD HAVE SHOULD HAVE
DONE. MISTER ROCK THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM OF
THINGS THAT I SHOULD WORK ON.
TIMES OUGHT WITH MY CITY OF
COMMERCE WEEK I HAVE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH COUNCIL
MEMBERS AT DIFFERENT TIMES- AND
IT'S FOR ME IS THAT THIS
PROLIFERATION IS MOVING SO
QUICKLY. THAT I HAVE CONCERNS
AND I DO HAVE CONCERNS WAITING
UNTIL AUGUST I'M NOT TO TRY TO
GET TO CALL WHEN HEARINGS
HAPPENED OF THEIR SPECIAL OR
NOT WITH THAT. OKAY THANK YOU
SOMEBODY WOMAN THAT THIS TIME
LET'S GO AHEAD AND I. ASK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS HEARING. AND
SEEING THAT LET'S GO TO MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
THERE IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT HEARING AND SEEING. NON
ALTERNATE BACK. TO MEMBERS OF
THE DICE. SIMILAR AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I YOU KNOW I
THINK. THE MIDDLE OF THE ROAD
THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED FOR IT TO
BE BY SOME FOLKS I'VE I'VE
HEARD VERY AND THINGS RIGHT TO
VOTE Y SOME FOLKS TO APPROVE
THE AUDIT BUT WAIT- DELAYED
WHEN THE UTTER BEGAN TO WORK
SOMETHING AND I'M OKAY WITH
THAT I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE. MY PERSPECTIVE
IN ME GETTING TO THAT POINT
WORK THAT THEY'LL ALL WHY I'M
I'M NOT PREPARED TO. ASK FOR
THE LETTER TO BE ASKING FOR ANY
MORE ON MAKING SURE THAT THESE
ARE THE BEST PRACTICES IN
GENERAL- AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR. AN EVO OF SOME VERSION
OF THE TAP NEAR TODAY THAT A
LOT OF A LOT OF USEFUL
DISCUSSION THANK YOU SEVERAL
WOMEN AND PERHAPS I CAN. OFFER
SOMETHING THAT MAY BE MAY BE
USEFUL IN THE SHORT TERM IN
AROUND THAT WE HAVE HERE. LET
ME ASK THAT MAYBE WE TABLE THIS
TILL THE END OF THE AND BRING
IT BACK FOR A VOTE AT THE END
OF TODAY'S HEARING MAYBE A
GIVES YOU AN OPPORTUNITY IN THE
NEXT. WAS WERE HEARING THE
ADDITION I REQUEST TO MAYBE-
MEET WITH SOME OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO DISCUSS
WHAT THE PROPER WAY YOU'D LIKE
TO MOVE FORWARD. SO LET'S GO TO
THAT. OKAY ALL RIGHT. SO THAT
WILL TAKE THAT BY. TO THE END
OF TODAY AGENDA. VOTE ON. AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE NEXT I REQUEST US BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. PART OF.
YEAH SELECT UP TO LIKE. THAT'S
WHAT. YEAH YEAH. THE HARD. WHAT
WHAT IT. BUT IF IT IS WITH.
WHEN YEAH YEAH THAT OKAY SO THE
ONLY OPEN UP AGAIN. HI ABOUT
MAKING PRODUCTS FOR. HAS BEEN.
FIRST TIME DOING THIS SO GOT TO
GO FOR NO YOU THE FIRST. ME ON.
THIS NO HE WILL ALLOW 10% YEAR
REQUEST THANK OUT OF HER. CAR.
TO AND THAT'S BECAUSE I MEAN TO.
THAT IS GOOD WITH YOUR. THE
QUICKNESS YEAH YEAH. WHATEVER
IF. YOU CAN GROUND AND. YEAH.
NUMBER ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER RIVAS I HAVE MISSED
GARCIA FOR JOINING US THIS IS
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE ONE TWO
ALMOST SERVICES COUNTY
CONTINUUM OF CARE LEAD AGENCIES
MYSTERY OF US WHEN YOU'RE READY
TO BEGIN PLACE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AYE AYE IT'S STILL
APPROPRIATE TO SAY- YOU KNOW
GOOD MORNING I WAS AFRAID I WAS
GONNA SAY GOOD AFTERNOON
POSSIBLY GOOD EVENING BUT IN
ANY CASE IT IS GREAT TO BE HERE
ONE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES IN HIS AS WE ALL
KNOW. HOMELESSNESS IS A STATE
WIDE CRISIS THAT IS IMPACTING
EVERY REGION OF CALIFORNIA AND
OVER TIME THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE ALLOCATED-
MILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN EFFORTS TO FIGHT
SYSTEMIC AND TO EQUIP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE TOOLS OR
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
CREATE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE OUR HOMELESS POPULATION-
AND AS WE ALL KNOW BASED ON THE
DAILY NEWS ARTICLES WE READ THE
PEOPLE WE TALKED TO LOCAL
LEADERS ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
NEIGHBORS I AM FROM THE
OBSERVATIONS WE CAN MAKE
WHETHER IT'S- WHILE IN THE CAR
DRIVING A WALL GOING ON A WALK
THESE OBSERVATIONS BACK. HOME
OR DISTRICTS OR RIGHT HERE IN
OUR STATE CAPITOL IN SACRAMENTO.
THAT THIS HOMELESS. THIS
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE HAS EXPLODED.
AND IT HAS EXPLODED IN ALL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA I CLEARLY
THE SITUATION THIS CRISIS HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO GET MUCH MUCH
WORSE WORSE BECAUSE MORE AND
MORE CALIFORNIANS. FACE HOUSING
IN SECURITY EACH AND EVERY DAY-
AND IN RESPONSE OUR STATE HAS
INCREASED ITS ROLE IN PROVIDING
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING- AND IT IS
CLEAR THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ALLOCATED
TO ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
AND AS THE GOVERNOR SAID THE
LAST WEEK IN THE STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS THE ROAD AHEAD IS
DIFFICULT. BUT NOT IMPOSSIBLE-
AND WE AND WE MUST DO ALL WE
CAN TO SOLVE THIS CRISIS. AND
WHILE WE WRAP UP FUNDING OR AT
LEAST WHAT WE CONSIDER IT AND
WE DEBATED IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE ALSO RAMP UP OUR ANALYSIS OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS- TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE BOOSTING- THE
EFFORTS THAT HAVE SHOWN THE
MOST PROMISE- AND SO- I'M HERE.
THIS MORNING ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYWOMAN GARCIA-
AND WE ARE CALLING FOR STATE
AUDITOR TO ANALYZE A CONTINUUM
OF CARE EFFORT. BECAUSE THESE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL AGENCIES ARE
ANY CENTRAL TOOL- AND ESSENTIAL
TOOL FOR THE STATE TO HELP OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE IS AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM OF CARE- THAT
GUIDES AND TRACKS HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES TO
HELP ORGANIZE AND PROVIDE
SERVICES TO MEET THE SPECIFIC
NEEDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS. N. AS THEY MOVE OR
TRANSITION TO STABLE LIVING
ENVIRONMENTS ANOTHER SOLUTION
TO ANY HOMELESSNESS ISN'T ONLY
ABOUT INCREASING THE HOUSING
SUPPLY OR THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS- IT'S
ALSO ABOUT FOCUSING ON THE VERY
NEEDS OF A SPECIFIC POPULATION.
SUCH AS OUTREACH EMERGENCY
SHELTERS RAPID RE HOUSING
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING-
AND IF WE ARE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW WE AS
A STATE CAN BEST SOLVE OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRIED. WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE TOOLS ALLIES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO HELP IDENTIFY
THE BEST AND MOST EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES. I IN ALTHOUGH EVERY
COUNTY EVERY REGION'S UNIQUE
AND DIFFERENT. THE LEAD THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE AGENCIES THEY-
WILL PROVIDE OR MAY PROVIDE
UNEXPECTED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OTHER CO SEASON OUR STATE OTHER
AGENCIES TO STRATEGICALLY
IMPROVE THE USE OF CURRENT AND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AGAIN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AND
SUPPORTING PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
AND IN CLEARLY CURRENTLY THERE
ARE GAPS IN TO EMPHASIZE. THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO BE AWARE
OF AFFECTED STRATEGIES TO
CONDUCT ACCURATE ANNUAL COUNTS
ACCURATE COUNT OF THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- IN
COORDINATION WITH OTHER
HOMELESS SERVICE AGENCIES AND
FINDING A PATHWAY- A PATHWAY
THE STRATEGY THAT WORKS YOU
KNOW HAVING AN ACCURATE COUNT
OF A HOMELESS POPULATION IS
CRITICAL IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
SURE THAT WE GET. THE MAXIMUM
AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE AT
THE AND LEVEL- AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY- TO GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO EFFICIENTLY TARGET
OR FOCUS- SUCH RESOURCES AND
DOLLARS- TO THE PROBLEM- AND SO
CERTAINLY THE STATE CAN
IDENTIFY AND PROVIDE INCENTIVES
TO THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
AGENCIES TO WORK ALONGSIDE NON
PROFITS AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
TO SECURE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-
AND AS A STATE WE SHOULD
STRIVE. TO LOCATE GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS OR REGIONS THAT HAVE
INSUFFICIENT OR IN SOME CASES
NO SERVICES- AND FIND THE
REASONS WHY THOSE AREAS HAVE
INADEQUATE RESOURCES AND WE
SHOULD BE READY TO REACH OUT TO
UNDER FUNDED REGION'S FOLLOWING
THE RESULTS OF THIS AUDIT. TO
BE APPROVED QUICKLY SUPPLY OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE NEST WITH
THE RESOURCES TO SOLVE THERE
YOU CALL SUCH SHINS I AM WILL
BALLOT EN WILL CONTINUE OKAY
THEN THIS SOURCE SOLVE THIS
CRISIS THIS BUSINESS
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. THIS
FUNDING WON'T FULLY OUR GOAL IF
UNDER WHAT PRO ARE WERE THAT IS
BY THE OP ED IS. OTHER MORE I
DAY BUT JUST A HAPPY ON
CONTINUE OF EIGHT ON THEIR WORK
BUT WE TAX REASON WE THE THEY
ARE IT'S A- ON AND THAT THEY A
AGENCIES AND FIVE CAN. A RIDGE.
THAT INCLUDE SOUTHERN. THE
CENTRAL COAST THE BAY AREA THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY AND SO WITH
THAT I. WILL HANDED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE- SOME THE WOMAN
GARCIA PLACE NOT THINK I WANT
TO THANK MR RIVAS FOR HIS
THOROUGH COMMON SO KEEP MINE
SHORT. I REPRESENT NINE SMALL
CITIES WITHIN IN THE COUNTY OF
LA AND WE'VE SEEN OUR
POPULATION GROW RAPIDLY LIKE IN
MOST OTHER PLACES ACROSS THE
STATE WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD ONE OF
THE- FASTEST RATES OF INCREASE-
AND LA COUNTY. AND THE REGION
THAT I AM AND SO AS WE ARE
SPEND THIS MONEY I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE NOT ONLY HAVE THE BEST
PRACTICES SOMEWHERE AWARE OF-
WERE WERE WHAT IS AND ISN'T
WORKING. BUT WHILE ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT CITIES LIKE MINE ARE
NOT OVERSHADOWED BY LARGE
CITIES. AND THAT RESEARCHERS
ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED EQUITABLY
ACROSS COUNTIES AND THE STATE
AND SO I DO ALSO APPRECIATE
THAT FOCUS TO THE AUDIT AND SO
I ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOUR THE SIMS
GO TO MOVED THE OTHERS
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS AND
GARCIA INDICATED WE WOULD LOOK
AT FIVE COUNTIES. IN THE
REGIONS THAT MR RIVAS
MENTIONED- AND STARTING IN
LOOKING AT PLANNING. THESE
CONTINUUM OF CARE OF CO SEES
ALL REFER TO THEM AS WHAT
THEY'RE PLANNING IS THEIR
STRATEGIES FOR ADMINISTERING
SERVICES TO THOSE. IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE COUNTIES WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
THEIR BEST PRACTICES THAT COULD
BE SHARED AMONG THE THIS CO
SEASON PERHAPS OTHER CO SEASON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALSO
LOOKING AT AS HE MENTIONED IN
HIS COMMENTS MR RIVAS. OUR
WATER THE CEO SEES DOING TO
CONDUCT WHAT STRATEGIES ARE
THEY USING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE CONDUCTING COUNTS. OUT
THAT RESULT IN AN ACCURATE
COUNT OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTIES. IN
ADDITION DETERMINING THE
RESOURCES AND WHAT PROTOCOLS
THE CEO SEES USED TO MEASURE
HOW EFFECTIVE THE PROGRAMS THAT
NON PROFITS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ARE PROVIDING TO A HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. IN ADDITION
LOOKING AT COLLECTING RETAINING
AND ANALYZING DATA NOT JUST
WITH RESPECT TO HOMELESSNESS
BUT ALSO WITH RESPECT TO
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
SKEWS ME- AND VERIFY WHETHER TO
THE EXTENT TO WHICH CEO SEES
ACTUALLY COLLABORATE AND
COOPERATE WITH. NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WITH RESPECT
TO AGAIN AS MR RIVAS INDICATED
OUT REACH. OUT REACHING OUT TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS
AND- TALKING TO THEM ABOUT OUR
ARRAY OF SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO THEM. I'M ALSO
LOOKING AT OPPORTUNITIES AND
INCENTIVES THAT PERHAPS STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CEO SEES
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY. OUR
COULD SECURE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING YOU MAY RECALL WE
ISSUED AN AUDIT A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO WHERE WE LOOKED AT
HOMELESSNESS WE WERE WERE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED TO LOOK AT
LA COUNTY. WE EXPANDED THE
SCOPE UP BY DOING SOME WORK TO
SEE. THE IMPACT ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF
THE RESULTS IN THAT AUDIT WAS
WE WERE NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
FEDERAL MONEY LIKE OTHER STATES
WERE SO THIS OBJECTIVE WOULD
WOULD GET AT THAT WHAT ARE THE
CEO SEES DOING TO. WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO TRY TO
MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
MONEY THAT COMES INTO
CALIFORNIA FOR THIS PURPOSE. A
COUPLE OF OTHER OBJECTIVES
DETERMINE WHETHER STRUCTURAL
CHANGES OR RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CEO SEES IN THE COMMUNITIES-
HAVE ACCURATE DATA ALL THE WAY
THROUGH VARIOUS PROCESSES- AND
CERTAINLY DURING THE EVALUATION
OF SERVICE PROVIDERS THEY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE CORRECT
ACCURATE DATA WHEN THEY'RE
EVALUATING. SERVICES THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED AND THEN THE
LAST COUPLE OF OBJECTIVES AS
FAR AS WHAT ARE THE CEO SEES
DOING TO TRY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF SERVICE PROVIDERS
WITHIN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES- FIRST IDENTIFYING
HOW MANY THERE ARE OUT THERE IF
THERE ARE SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO
HAVE NOT. ENGAGED WITH THE CEO
SEE TRY TO DETERMINE WHY- AND
WHAT'S PROHIBITING MEMBER NOW
PREVENTING THEM FROM REALLY
WANTING TO. PARTICIPATE IN SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND THEN
FINALLY WITHIN EACH OF THIS THE
CONTAINER OF CARE COUNTIES.
DETERMINE WHETHER THERE ARE IN
MY WORDS POCKETS OR GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS WITHIN THOSE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THERE ARE NOT SUFFICIENT
SERVICES AND DETERMINE WHAT THE
CEO SEES ARE DOING TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. AND THEN
FINALLY LOOKING AT BEST
PRACTICES AGAIN LOOKING AT
IMPROVING ACCOUNTABILITY
EFFICIENCY WITH RESPECT TO OUT
REACH ACCURATE COUNTS UP
PROVIDING SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES. THE BUDGET FOR
THIS OUT ITS THIRTY ONE HUNDRED
HOURS NOW IT'S A TYPICAL TEAM
THAT WOULD TAKE US EIGHT MONTHS
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT MY
OFFICE WOULD DO IN THIS ONE
BECAUSE WE'RE BEING ASKED TO GO
TO FIVE COUNTIES. I WOULD IN
ALL LIKELIHOOD DECIDE TO PUT
TWO TEAMS ON THIS SO WE HAVE
TEAMS OUT. YOU KNOW
CONCURRENTLY AUDITING AND
DIFFERENT OP COUNTY SO WE CAN
SHRINK THE AMOUNT OF TIME THE
ON IT WOULD TAKE TO GET THE
INFORMATION BACK TO. THE
LEGISLATURE- YET TIMELY WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIR I'LL
HOPEFULLY ANSWER QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK BETTER WATER A CAT THIS
TIME. WE ASK IF THERE'S ANY
AFFECTED AGENCIES I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NANA LET ME TURN IT TO
MEMBERS ON DíAS FOR QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BOERNER HORVATH
YES- NOT SO MUCH A QUESTION I
WANT TO THINK THE- REQUEST AS
OF THIS AUDIT FOR SUCH A
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH OF REALLY
CREATING BEST PRACTICES. IN THE
CONTINUE OF KAREN HOMELESSNESS
I THINK THERE MANY WAYS- WE CAN
GET AT THE HEART OF THE ISSUE
OF MANY THINGS THAT WE FACE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE ON
IT'S A VERY WELL THOUGHT
THROUGH CHRIST. THANK YOU
CERTAINLY WOMAN- LET ME TURN IT
BACK TO HEARINGAND SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS ON THE
DíAS LET ME ASK THE MEMBER IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE BRIEFLY.
JUST A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR-
AND I ABOUT. MAKING MONEY THANK
YOU BUT LET ME ASK JUST TO AND
ALL DUE DILIGENCE. IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
ALL RIGHT IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
MISTER ROTH SECOND BY MISS
RUBIO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE HOMELESSNESS
AND HOW WE'RE DOING WITH THE-
RESOURCES WE'VE ALLOCATED
TOWARDS AS IN THIS IS A GOOD
REASONABLE MEASURED APPROACH.
SO IT'S BEEN MOVED JUST IN
MOTION AND MISS SEXUALLY
CALDERON. THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE I REQUEST NUMBER TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE TWELVE. ALMOST
SERVICES COUNTY CONTINUED
CONTINUUM OF CARE LEAD AGENCIES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF ROBERT
RIVAS AND CRISTINA GARCIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AYE SALAS
AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I CHEN.
PATTERSON PATTERSON I RUBIO
RUBIO I VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD.
SENATOR ROBB ROTH I BOARD JUST.
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG. GOOD
MORNING. MORE LOCKED. WIENER.
OKAY THAT ITEMS ON CALL AND
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THAT ARE GET
THIS TIME WAS GOOD AND I
CONTINUED ON THE AGENDA CENTER
BRADFORD HAVE BELIEVE YOU'RE
SIGNED IN NEXT. OKAY TO THE
GENEROSITY OF CENTER BRADFORD
IS YIELDING TO MISS COM LAGER
SOME WE WOMAN THANK YOU FOR AT
FOR JOINING US THIS IS ON
AGENDA ITEM. TO WORRY. AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER TEN TWENTY TWENTY
DASH ONE OH TWO. THIS IS
REALIGNMENT FUND SPENDING.
THANK YOU AND SEVEN ONE PLEASE
THANK YOU TO SENATOR BRADFORD
FOR- ALLOWING US TO- GO BEFORE
HIM WE HAVE WITNESSES THAT HAVE
A FLIGHT TO CATCH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD.
AFTERNOON ON THE DOCTOR. SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF PRISON ALIGNMENT
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY ELEVEN
CALIFORNIA HAS SENT MORE THAN
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
COUNTIES TO COVER THE COST OF
MOVING INCARCERATED PEOPLE FROM
PRISONS TO JAILS. THIS STATE
HAS MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
TEN. LONG TERM JAIL FACILITIES
AND DEPARTMENTS ARE NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR POPULATIONS
THAT ARE LARGER AND FAR MORE
DIVERSE. CONDITIONS SUCH AS
OVERCROWDING POOR PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AND
MISMANAGEMENT OF FUNDS BY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS HAVE
BECOME FAR TOO FREQUENT READS
IN ARTICLES IN THE NEWSPAPERS
AND ALSO FAR TOO FREQUENT IN
JAILS ACROSS THE STATE. AND WE
KNOW THAT THE EFFICIENT
RESPONSIBLE SPENDING OF PRISON
REALIGNMENT FUNDS IS INCREDIBLY
CRITICAL. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CONTINUE TO MOVE PRISON
REALIGNMENT FUNDS FROM ONE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSE TO ANOTHER
WITH LIMITED STATE OVERSIGHT.
TODAY I'M HERE TO REQUEST THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SUCH
OVERSIGHT PARTICULARLY OVER LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND FRESNO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS. I ALONG WITH MANY
ADVOCATES ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
BUDGET BATTLES COUNTY LEVEL
REFUSALS TO CONDUCT AN AUDIT
AND DEATHS WITHIN FACILITIES
RESPECTIVELY THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY JAIL SYSTEM IT'S THE
LARGEST SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
HAS ITS FAIR SHARE OF TROUBLES
IN OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS VOTED UNANIMOUSLY
TO IMPROVE TO APPROVE A PARTIAL
FREEZE OF A HUNDRED FORTY THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT'S
BUDGET. OVER SPEND UNDER THE
CURRENT SHERIFF IS MORE THAN
FOUR TIMES THAT OF HIS
PREDECESSOR. ALAMEDA COUNTY IS
JAIL POPULATION HAS DECREASED
BY HALF SINCE PRISON ALIGNMENT
TOOK EFFECT YET EVEN WITH THE
POPULATION DECREASED THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY SHERIFF'S HAS
EXPERIENCED A BUDGET GROWTH BY
A HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE PAST
FOUR YEARS IN THE PAST TEN
YEARS MY BAD TOTALING FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
FORTY FIVE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
DIED WHILE HELD AT ALAMEDA
COUNTIES SANTA. RITA JAIL IN
THE FIVE YEARS BETWEEN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
IT'S THE HIGHEST DEATH RATE IN
THE BAY AREA. THE FRESNO COUNTY
JAIL WHICH HOUSES MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND INMATES HAS SEEN
THE SHARPEST INCREASE OF DEATHS
OF ANY CALIFORNIA JAIL SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF REALIGNMENT
LEGISLATION. FRESNO COUNTY
LARGER JAIL SYSTEMS THE
CALIFORNIA DOJ HAS REPORTED
TWENTY THREE DEATHS IN THE
SEVEN YEARS PRECEDING PRISON
REALIGNMENT. THAT FIGURE HAS
MORE THAN DOUBLED SINCE
REALIGNMENT AT FORTY SEVEN
DEATHS IN ONLY ONE OF THOSE
DEATHS WAS CAUSED BY A FELLOW
INCARCERATED PERSON. CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE LEADING STATES IN
PROGRESS OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM YET THERE IS LITTLE OR
NO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COUNTY
SHERIFF'S TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE SPENDING REALIGNMENT FUNDS
AS INTENDED. THE VASTLY
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT THREE OUT
FOR MENTION COUNTIES HAVE SPENT
THEIR FUNDS ATTEST TO THIS
FACT. MY HOPE IS THAT THIS
AUDIT OF THREE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS WILL OPEN THE DOOR
TO AUDITING OTHER SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE MUST WORK TO SUPPORT
THE DIGNITY AND HEALTH OF
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS IN
ACCESS TO DATA THAT IS FULL AND
TRANSPARENT IS NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO CRAFT LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTIONS SO HERE IN SUPPORT I
HAVE MARC ANTHONY CLAYTON
JOHNSON OF JUSTICE LA. AS WELL
AS EVETTE OUTLAY OF DIGNITY AND
POWER NOW AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I. BUT- HI THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON- MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THIS DISCUSSION AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER COMMA
FOR BRINGING THIS TO THE LIGHT
JUST SO LAYS A COALITION OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ADVOCATES AND FOLKS ARE
IMPACTED BY INCARCERATION OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY- AND WE COME
TO THIS CONVERSATION REALLY
WITH HOLLY PLEASE IF YOU WE
COULD HAVE YOUR NAME AS WELL
FOR THE RECORD I'M SORRY MARC
ANTHONY CLAYTON JOHNSON. WE
COME TO THIS CONVERSATION WITH
THE HOPE TO GROUND US AND THE
IMPETUS BEHIND AB ONE OH NINE
WHICH WAS THE BROWN VERSUS PLOT
THAT CASE- WHAT'S- AB ONE
ANNISE OFTEN TALKED ABOUT. AS A
STRATEGY TO REDUCE
INCARCERATION- REDUCE
OVERCROWDING REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
AND WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT THAT
CASE WAS ALSO ABOUT MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE AND ABUSE. ON THAT.
AMOUNTED TO A CONDITIONS- THAT
WORD NAME THIS CRUEL AND
UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT AS DEFINED
BY THE FOURTH AMENDMENT. AND SO
THE FUNDAMENTAL CONTRADICTION
WE HAVE TO ASK AN ADDRESS IS
HOW WE HAVE MOVED RESOURCES. ON
FROM THE PRISON SYSTEM TO THE
LOCAL JAIL SYSTEMS-
PARTICULARLY IN PLACES LIKE
LAST SENTENCE WHICH HAVE FAILED
ON THE SAME PREMISE IN FACT THE
DOJ IS OPEN UP INVESTIGATIONS-
INTO THE LESS IT IS COUNTY JAIL
SYSTEM FOR THAT VERY. REASON
ARE CRUEL AND UNUSUAL
PUNISHMENT AROUND THE ISSUES OF
HEALTH CARE ON THE ISSUES OF
OVER CUTTING ON AROUND ISSUES
OF ABUSE. AND IN IN FACT. THIS
LAST YEAR WE'VE SEEN- THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS BUDGETS
GO UP WITH RESPECT TO AB ONE OH
NINE ALLOCATION SPECIFICALLY
44% OF AB ONE ON NINE
ALLOCATIONS LOS ANGELES HAVE
GONE TO THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IS TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
51% NOW LET ME HAVE GONE TO THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND FRESNO
SEEN. AGAIN 53% GOING TO
CUSTODY ALLOCATION THAT SO WE
ARE ALL SET TO ASK OURSELVES.
HOW WE ALLOCATING THESE FUNDS.
TO ENTITIES ATTACKS DON'T HAVE.
A INTEREST DIVERTED. OUT OF THE-
THAT THAT MOVES. THOSE PEOPLE
OUT OF THEIR WRIST. AND IN THE
UPPER. OF A OTHER DEPARTMENTS
SUCH AS THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES- AND THEREFORE
WEAKENING THE JUSTIFICATION.
FOR THAT MONEY IN THEIR BUDGETS
I THINK ONE THING IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THAT THESE
ISSUES OF- CRUEL AND UNUSUAL
PUNISHMENT IN OUR JAIL SYSTEM
CONTINUE TO- CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN- SUCH AS THE H. THE-
OCCURRENCE OF THE DEATH OF ONE
GLORIA HE WAS A YOUNG MAN DON'T
LÏNG LATINO MEN AND LOSS AND
JUST COUNTY JAIL. WHO HAD A
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION WAS
PEPPER SPRAY TO DEATH BY THE
LOS ANGELES SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. HE IS ONE OF EIGHT
PEOPLE HAVE DIED LAST YEAR LOSS
CENTERS COUNTY JAIL SYSTEM-
WHEN WE HAVE OTHER METHODS
OTHER MECHANISMS OF THE
STRATEGIES THAT ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE IN WE HAVE WAVE THEM.
AGAIN TO THE PATTERN OF AB ONE
OH NINE ALLOCATIONS AS LAID
OUT. WE HAVE THE BENEFIT OF THE
PUBLIC DEBATE THAT HAPPENED ON
AUGUST THIRTEENTH IN THE
COUNTY. OF LOS ANGELES WHERE
THE COUNTY ELIMINATED AND
DECIDED TO CANCEL A CONTRACT OF
FOUR BILLION. FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS TO APPROVE A MENTAL
HEALTH- JAIL SYSTEM. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
OFFICE OF DIVERSION AND RE
ENTRY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
A- NON RECIDIVISM RATE OF
NINETY ONE PERCENT- AT SIX
MONTHS AND EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT.
AT TWELVE MONTHS FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH- SERIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES
VIOLENT CHARGES AND SUBSTANCE
USE WHILE THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. HAS A RECIDIVISM
RATE OF 60% AND LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ALSO LOOK AT THE BIGGER
PICTURE. WHERE THE LAR IN THE
LARGEST COUNTY IN LAW IT
LARGEST COUNTY IN THE COUNTRY.
PARMA MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
HEALTH SERVICES THE OFFICE OF
DIVERSION REENTRY AND THE PART
IN A PUBLIC HEALTH COLLECTIVELY
RECEIVE SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS. THAT IS 17% OF AB ONE
ON NINE ALLOCATIONS AND 20% OF
THE SHARES ALLOCATION OF TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
BEST POISED TO. FACILITATE MORE
EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS. THANK YOU
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME FOR
COULD BE VERY CONCISE BECAUSE
WE MVED TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
PRESENTATION. PLEASE KEEP THE
FAST MY NAME IS THE BALLET I AM
THE SENIOR POLICY LEAD FOR
DIGNITY EMPOWER NOW. A MEMBER
OF THE JUSTICE LA COALITION FOR
NEARLY A DECADE OUR MEMBERS
HAVE CALLED FOR THE EVALUATION
OF AB ONE OR NINE SPENDING IN
OUR COUNTY. AND REINVEST AND
COMMUNITY BASED ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF OUR COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COME AUGUST REQUEST FOR
AN AUDIT OF LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AB ONE OR NINE
SPENDING. BUT WE ALSO ASK THAT
THE AUDIT EXTEND TO ALL THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES RECEIVING
AB ONE OR NINE ALLOCATIONS.
INCLUDING THE LA COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN LA COUNTY HAS
RECEIVED OVER A BILLION IN AB
ONE OH NINE FUNDING INTENDED
FOR ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION. BUT SO FAR AB
ONE OH NINE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO FULFILL ITS PURPOSE OF
REDUCING RECIDIVISM AND JAIL
POPULATIONS BECAUSE THE FUNDING
HAS NOT REACHED. COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS WEBER
DEMONSTRATED SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS ON REENTRY NEEDS. THE
MAJORITY OF AB ONE OH NINE
FUNDING HAS GONE TO THE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
PROBATION OFFICE. TO PERPETUATE
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF JAIL
INCARCERATION IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. IN FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THESE
DEPARTMENTS RECEIPT OVER
SEVENTY SEVEN PERCENT. OF AB
ONE ON I'M FUNDING AND SAID OF
USING THESE FUNDS TO FULFILL
THE INTENT OF AB ONE OH NINE
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HAS
CHOSEN TO USE A LARGE PORTION
OF THE- FUNDS. TO PAY FOR STOP
OVER TIME. THE RETURN ON YOUR
INVESTMENT HAS BEEN A
RECIDIVISM RATE OF 60% OF OVER
60% LIKE MARC ANTHONY POINTED
OUT. BY CONTRAST THE OFFICE OF
DIVERSION RE ENTRY RECEIVED
YOUR 5% AND I COLLEAGUES MARK
AT THE NO. AT THE 84% RICH.
RATE DOLLAR FOR. INVEST.
RECEIVE A THOROUGH AUDIT OF ITS
AB ONE OR NINE SPENDING. THANK
YOU IT WAS GOING TO MOVE TO THE
STATE AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM LONGER
INDICATED WE WOULD GO TO THREE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES ALAMEDA
FRESNO LA- AND SHE'S ASKED US
TO LOOK AT A FEW ISSUES HERE
AND I'LL GO A RELATIVELY
QUICKLY. FIRST ASKING US TO
LOOK AT A TEN YEAR WINDOW- WITH
RESPECT TO POPULATION- AND THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO LOOK AT
POPULATION CHARACTERISTICS
PRIOR TO REALIGNMENT AND AFTER
REALIGNMENT AND- AND SHE'S
ASKED US OVER THAT TEN YEAR
WINDOW TO LOOK AT TRENDS. ARE
AND CERTAINLY TRY TO LOOK AT
SOME DEMOGRAPHICS WITH RESPECT
TO RACE RACE AND ETHNIC MAKE UP
AND CERTAINLY ON THE NUMBER OF
INMATE DEATHS. IN ADDITION ARE
ASKING US TO LOOK AT FUNDING
THAT IS GOING TO EACH OF THESE
COUNTIES. AND THE AMOUNT THAT
IS GOING TO SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT'S BUT WE ALSO IN
HAPPEN THE OBJECTIVE ANY OTHER
RELEVANT DEPARTMENT SO THAT
WOULD ON ALL LIKELIHOOD PICK UP
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENTS. IN
THESE THREE COUNTIES ALSO
LOOKING AT WHAT THE COUNTIES
ARE PROJECTING AS FAR AS FUTURE
REALIGNMENT FUNDING THAT THEY
WILL RECEIVE. THEN ON THE FLIP
SIDE LOOKING AT EXPENDITURES
AND THE CATEGORIES OF
EXPENDITURES FIRST OF ALL. ARE
THE ARE THE COUNTIES OUT
SPENDING ALL THE FUNDS THEY'RE
RECEIVING BURST. A SECOND IT IT
IN THAT FOR THE EXPENDITURES
WHAT MAJOR CATEGORIES
ENFORCEMENT TREATMENT- AN
OPERATION SO HOW MUCH ARE THEY
SPENDING ON ENFORCEMENT VERSUS
TREATMENT OF THE AT THE
INDIVIDUALS AND IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE JAILS. AND FOR
OPERATIONS. AND THEN WHETHER OR
NOT THESE EXPENDITURES THAT WE
LOOK AT OUR ACTUALLY CONSISTENT
WITH REALIGNMENT REQUIREMENTS.
AND THEN THE FINAL TWO
OBJECTIVES EVALUATING AGAIN
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES ARE AT
EACH OF THE RESPECTIVE OF
FACILITIES ARE THREE RESPECTIVE
COUNTIES. ARE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THEIR BEST PRACTICES IN
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE NOT
ONLY ACCOUNTABILITY OF THEIR
FINANCES AND REALIGNMENT FUNDS
BUT TRANSPARENCY OF THAT.
OVERSIGHT OF THE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS AND THEN FINALLY- TRYING
TO DETERMINE THE IMPACT OF
REALIGNMENT ON EACH JAILS
POPULATION. NOT JAIL STAFF BUT
ENFORCEMENT AND POTENTIALLY
LOOKING AT WHAT'S OCCURRING IN
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES-
THE BUDGET FOR THIS AUDIT ABOUT
TWENTY SIX A LITTLE OVER TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED HOURS. THAT WOULD
TAKE US A LITTLE OVER SIX
MONTHS TO COMPLETE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU MADAM
AUDITOR OKAY AT THIS TIME IS
GOING TO MOVE TO THE AFFECTED
AGENCIES THIRTY AFFECTED
AGENCIES I WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS AGENDA ITEM. PLEASE JOIN
US UP HERE. YOU CAN BEGIN BY
ANNOUNCING A YOUR NAME AND
WHICH CITY OR WITH OKAY I'M NOT
SURE OF GREG AARON ALAMEDA
COUNTY SHERIFF THANK YOU ON A
COUPLE THINGS- REGARDS TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE- OKAY.
CAN I HAVE ONE PERSON ALLOW THE
ADDITIONAL. FOR SOME TESTS.
PLEASE FUNDS FOR A AB ONE OH
NINE OR- CONTROLLED BY THE
PROBATION OFFICERS IN EACH
COUNTY AND THERE ALLOCATED TO.
OF THE DIFFERENT ENTITIES BASED
ON APPROVAL FROM THE A-
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PARTNERSHIP OF SO THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE SIMPLY REQUEST THE FUNDS
AND IN OUR CASE OF. A 50% OF
MONEY GOES OUT TO COMMITTEE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO HELP
FACILITATE OF THE INMATES AND
RE ENTRY WHILE THE FUNDS THAT
ASSURES OFFIC ALAMEDA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICERS ARE A DIRECT
PAYMENT FOR THE NUMBER OF DAYS
AND MAJOR SPENT IN CUSTODY
CHARGED AT AN AVERAGE DAILY
RATE. AND SO- WE BILL BASICALLY
FOR EACH DAY THAT WE HAVE THE
PEOPLE IN CUSTODY ARE RELATED
TO AB ONE NINE. A NEXT SOME OF
THE NUMBERS THAT- WERE-
DEDICATED TO OTHERS BODY A
SHOWED THAT THE WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A FORTY FIVE
THAT'S WHEN IN FACT WE BELIEVE
THAT NUMBER TO BE THIRTY NINE
TO US AND WE- UNDERSTAND THAT
ONE DEATH IS TOO MANY. AND WE
MONITOR OF THOSE WE HAVE A
OVERSIGHT- ALREADY IN PLACE-
THE DEALS WITH OUR- MEDICAL
PROGRAM OR MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM AND ARE OF. ISSUES
REGARDING THE DEATHS THAT OCCUR
IN INSIDETHE FACILITY AND I'D
BE WILLING TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT- YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU PLEASE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY. PLEASE ANNOUNCE
YOURSELF US WELL FOR THE RECORD
MARGARET MEN SHARE FOR FRESNO
COUNTY I DID. REALIGNMENT WAS
ESTABLISHED AS- PREVIOUSLY
OUTLINED. AND THE REALIGNMENT
MANY THAT CAME TO COUNTIES WAS
TO OFFSET THE IMPACTS OF THAT
REALIGNMENT. IN THE IMPACTS
WERE GREAT FOR INSTANCE 50% OF
THE PAROLE SUPERVISION CASES
NOW ARE THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT THE
WAY THE FUNDS GET ALLOCATED AND
THE OVERSIGHT IS THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PARTNERSHIP. A SEVEN MEMBER A
COMMITTEE THAT MAKES A DECISION
ON HOW THE FUNDING IS ALLOCATED
DEPENDING ON THE PRESENTATIONS
THAT ARE PROVIDED BEFORE THAT
COMMITTEE. SO AS A SHERIFF'S
OFFICE AND ANYBODY THAT WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT NEEDING CCP MONEY
HOW WE MAKE THAT PRESENTATION
THE COMMITTEE OF SEVEN MEMBERS
THAN VOTES. AFTER WE VOTE ON
HOW ARE BUDGET WILL GO FOR THE
YEAR AT THE IT'S NOT OVER
THAT'S NOT THE FINAL APPROVAL
GOES ON TO OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WHO THEN APPROVED
THE BUDGET OR CAN DENY. AT THE
BUDGET THAT IS PRESENTED. SO AT
AND ALSO RECENTLY WE'VE WE'VE
HAD AN AUDIT OF FINANCIAL AUDIT
OF OUR C. C. P. IN THE WE ARE
FUNDS ARE REALIGNMENT FUNDS ARE
SPENT- BROWN ARMSTRONG DID THE
AUDIT. THERE WERE NO FINDINGS
NOTE NO EXCEPTIONS A WE SPEND
96% OF THE MONEY THAT WE GET
FROM A REALIGNMENT. I AM AT HAD
ANY OF THESE QUESTIONS BEEN
ASKED OF ME BEFOREHAND I WOULD
I WOULD CERTAINLY HAVE ANSWERED
THESE QUESTIONS. ABOUT WE HAVE
RECENTLY HAD AN AUDIT THE
FUNDING DOES HAVE OVERSIGHT
WITH R. C. C. P. OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AT AN OUT ALL
INTERNET QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU SHERIFF- AT
THIS TIME LET ME ASK IF. I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL AGENCIES AND THE
ROOMS THAT ARE AFFECTED.
HEARING IN SAYING THAT LET ME
TURN IT BACK TO MEMBERS ON THE
DíAS FOR QUESTIONS ON A
SOUTHERN BORDER JUST IF YOU
LIKE. TO BEGIN PLEASE THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN OF WE HAD A VERY
INTERESTINGAND I THINK
CONSTRUCTIVE- CONVERSATION ON.
SOMETHING ANALOGOUS TO WHAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING HERE- WHAT
IS THE ROLE OF THIS BODYAND
WERE RISE TO THE LEVEL- SUBJECT
MATTER WISE AND PROCESS WAS-
DESERVING- AN AUDIT. ESPECIALLY
ONE THAT RAISES THE LEVEL OF
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS NOT
CHUMP CHANGE. I LOOKED AT A
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE SHEET HERE. AND IT
KIND OF CONFIRMED INTUITIVELY I
THINK WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
BEFORE. WHAT THE PROCESS IS FOR
SOMEONE ORDERS IN ORGANIZATION
TO ELEVATE. A MATTER TO YOU-
PURPOSES OF A OF AN AUDIT. AND
I THINK THIS IS THE INFORMATION
SHEET THAT EVERYONE FILLS OUT
WHEN THEY- OF PUT FORWARD. A
REQUEST. IT HAS- IT'S CALLED
THE INFORMATION SHEET FROM
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE THE REASON I BRING IT
UP IS THAT ON- NUMBER SIX
SEVEN. THE QUESTION IS
EXPLAINED THE STEPS YOU'VE
TAKEN TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OR
TOPIC OF THE AUDIT. AND THE
FIRST QUESTION IS HAVE YOU
REQUESTED THE AGENCY TO PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION YOU SEEK TO
OBTAIN. IN THE AUDIT. SO I JUST
LEARNED OF THIS AUDIT. RECENTLY
AND I THINK OF FRESNO LEARNED
OF IT NINETEEN THROUGH THE
TWENTIETH LAST WEDNESDAY LAST
WEDNESDAY ART SO WE KNOW OF
ANOTHER SITUATION WHERE WE'RE
WE'RE JUST FINDING OUT ABOUT IT.
ADEQUATE PREPARATION MAY NOT
HAVE ALLOWED FOR A GIVEN THE
TIME CONSIDERATIONS. BUT THE
SHERIFF MENTION A COUPLE THINGS
I THINK ARE REALLY APPROPRIATE
AND IMPORTANT FOR US TO
APPRECIATE. THAT THERE WAS IT
IN AUDIT OF FRESNO COUNTY BY A
FIRM CALLED BROWN AND ARMSTRONG
THAT- HAD FINDINGS RELEVANT TO
THE AREAS IN OF THE SCOPE OF
THIS PROPOSED INQUIRY- WINDED-
THE REQUESTING PARTY. GET A
COPY OF THAT BROWN ARMSTRONG.
ARM AUDIT TO MY KNOWLEDGE IT
WAS NEVER REQUESTED ALL RIGHT.
THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE FOR THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISOR- PROCESS
THAT WENT THROUGH IN TERMS OF
APPROPRIATING DOLLARS THAT DEAL
WITH- ALL THE ISSUES THAT ARE
BEING BROUGHT UP TODAY DID- AND
AT THAT INFORMATION GET A QUICK
REQUESTED AS WELL NOT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE. ART SO I THINK WE
HAVE A SITUATION HERE AGAIN
WHERE. WE JUST FOUND OUT ABOUT
THIS AUDIT. AND SOME OF THE
MOST PRESSING IN CLEAR CUT
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION WERE NOT PURSUED.
AND IT'S EVEN NAME EVEN IN OUR
OWN COMMITTEE PROCESS SO MY
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE
REQUESTING PARTY. DO THE DUE
DILIGENCE GET THE INFORMATION
FROM THESE THREE COUNTIES ARE
TWO OF THE LEADERS ARE ALREADY
HERE IS THAT A REASONABLE
REQUEST I WOULD I THINK SO
UNDER THE MICE YOU KNOW FOR MY
STANDPOINT. AS WE WERE ASKING
FOR THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED WORK HOURS WORTH TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED HOURS WORTH OF
INVESTMENT. BINDING ON THE
AUDIT DEPARTMENT I THINK IT
NEEDS TO RISE TO A LEVEL THAT
EITHER. YOU'VE DONE THE DUE
DILIGENCE AND NOT GOTTEN THE
INFORMATION YOU WANTED OR THE
LEVEL OF SOPHISTICATION IS JUST
TOO MUCH WHEN YOU NEED A THIRD
PARTY TO INVOLVE THEMSELVES.
BUT I THINK HAVING NOT DONE
THAT. I THINK THAT THIS IS
EARLY PREMATURE MIGHT IN MY
OPINION AND RESPECTFULLY WOULD
ASK MAYBE THE MAKER OF THIS-
THIS AUDIT REQUEST WOULD IT GO
BACK TO THOSE THREE COUNTIES
GET THAT INFORMATION AND THEN
IF THE IF YOU DON'T LIKE WHAT
YOU GET PORTS INCOMPLETE. THEN
BRING BACK THIS AUDIT REQUEST
AND I THINK THAT WOULD MAKE IT
A BILL YOU RIGHT REQUEST AT
THAT TIME. TWENTY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND
WELL YES THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR- THE COMMENTS AND
MAYBE- SOME OF THE ADVOCATES
CAN ALSO RESPOND WE KNOW THAT
REQUESTS AUDIT REQUESTS WERE
ASKED- FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN THOSE
ON ITS HAVE NOT HAPPENED AND
THAT'S BEEN. AS CONTENTIOUS
CONVERSATION THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING IN BOTH OF THOSE
COUNTIES RESPECTIVELY WE ALSO
KNOW THAT NONE OF THESE
COUNTIES HAVE THERE SEE C. PAP
CURRENCY CPSC PLANS WHICH TALK
ABOUT THE SPENDING. ON THE B.
SEC WEBSITE AND THIS IS A
WEBSITE WHERE YOU CAN GO TO GET
INFORMATION ON HOW THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS ARE
SPENDING IN ALLOCATING THE
MONIES AND WE HAVE HAD.NO
UPDATED PLANS SENSE IN SOME
INSTANCES TWENTY ELEVEN OR
TWENTY FOURTEEN IT DOES SAY
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE TO REVISE
IT BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT IF
THEY ARE MAKING CHANGES AND HOW
THEY'RE SPENDING THE
REALIGNMENT FUNDS. THAT WE AS A
STATE AND AS COUNTIES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY AN OBLIGATION TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT INFORMATION.
I WOULD JUST ADD LEASE. I WOULD
JUST ADD TO THIS CONVERSATION I
THINK IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
CERTAINLY. HAD A NUMEROUS.
ATTEMPTS BAR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO ACTUALLY GET
INFORMATION FROM THE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT CLOTHING-
INFORMATION ON THE CAUSES
DEATHS THAT HAPPEN INSIDE THE
COUNTY JAILS INCLUDING
INFORMATION ABOUT WHY. THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
REQUESTING THREE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS- FOR ITS BUDGET
DESPITE THE FREEZE THAT HAS
HAPPENED AND DESPITE A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY AROUND HOW THESE.
FUNDS ARE SPENT AND SO THERE IS
CERTAINLY A TRACK RECORD IN
WHICH WE COULD PROVIDE YOU- A
LIST OF SOME OF THOSE MOTIONS
AND OUTCOMES OF SOME THOSE
MOTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
UNSATISFACTORY TO THE COUNTY
AND CERTAINLY TO US. AS WHO
FOLKS OF LOVE ONCE INSIDE.
THANK YOU IF ALL QUESTIONS ARE
BORDERS ARE PRECISELY I THINK-
AND- I THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM
SOME FOLKS THAT THERE MIGHT BE
INSTANCES WHERE THINGS HAVE NOT
BEEN PRODUCED AND SHOULD HAVE
BEEN OR COULD HAVE BEEN
PRODUCED AND WARRANT WE HAVE A
GLARING SITUATION HERE AT LEAST
ONE POSSIBLY TWO COUNTIES. ARE
WHERE REQUEST HAD NOT EVEN BEEN
MADE. LIKE I DON'T WANT TO
PREJUDGE SITUATION BUT- I WOULD
MAKE ONE FINAL RESPECTFUL
REQUEST. BRING THIS MATTER BACK
IN AT IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
GET. WE HAVE OUT FRESNO ONE
ALAMEDA- I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU
CONSIDER IT I HEAR YOU I ALSO
KNOW THAT THEIR OF BEEN
CONVERSATIONS OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS LEVEL AT ALAMEDA
COUNTY WORK COMMUNITY HAS
REQUESTED AUDIENCE. AND THEY
HAVEN'T RECEIVED THEM AND SO WE
HAVE ONCE AGAIN AND TALKING TO
ADVOCATES AND PEOPLE IN THE
VARIOUS COUNTIES AND LOOKING AT
THE NUMBER OF SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WHAT'S BEING DONE WITH
REALIGNMENT OR WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S BEING DONE WITH
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS YOU KNOW
WE'VE- LOOKED AT SOME OF THE
CAR FEW OF THE DEPARTMENTS
WHERE EITHER MOST EGREGIOUS
ACTIVITIES. HAVE BEEN TAKING
PLACE OR WHERE THERE'S JUST A
HIGH DEGREE OF OPAQUE MATH.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE GOING TO MOVE TO SENATOR
ROTH. LET ME JUST A OFFICE MY
COMMENTS BY SAYING HOW MUCH
RESPECT I HAVE FOR THE
REQUESTER AND THE SPECTACULAR
JOB THAT SHE DOES- IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND CERTAINLY WITH
THIS REQUEST FRANKLY I.
REVIEWED MY- BINDER- OVER THE
pPREPARED TO OF. VOTE TO APPROVE
THIS REQUEST BUT I HAVE TO
JOIN. IN THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE ONCE AGAIN A- I'M
BOTHERED BY THE FACT THAT IT'S
A. ENTITIES THAT ARE BEING
AUDITED DON'T GET SUFFICIENT.
ADVANCE NOTICE OF THE FACT OF
THE AUDIT REQUEST IN THE
DETAILS SURROUNDING IT TO COME
TO THIS HEARING THAT WE HAVE
PREPARED TO ADDRESS THE REQUEST.
PROVIDE INFORMATION THAT MIGHT
ENABLE US TO- BUT JUST THE
SCOPE OF THE AUDIT WERE
APPROPRIATE. ANNA I THINK THAT
MAY. REFLECT A STRUCTURAL
DEFECT THEY WE HAVE PERHAPS IN
OUR PROCESS IF WE HAVE AUDIT
REQUESTS AND IF RESPONDING
ENTITIES COME HERE WITH SO
WEEKS NOTICE FOR FIVE DAYS
THREE DAYS NOTICE OR WHATEVER
THE NOTICE PERIOD IS. IT MAY
VERY WELL BE THAT WE VOTE TO
APPROVE THE AUDIT ANYWAY AND I
CERTAINLY THINK THAT. IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA THERE PROBABLY
NEEDS TO BE A NOT IT SOMEWHERE
SOMEHOW. BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE'RE BEING
ASKED TO PROVIDE IT'S WHERE THE
RESPONDING ENTITIES DON'T
REALLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME IN HERE WITH THEIR- PLATE
OF INFORMATION THAT ENABLES US
TO MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION ON
THE- THE WAY THE AUDIT IS
FRAMED THE SCOPE OF THE IT SO.
HAVING SAID I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION I'M JUST NAY ACUTE
JOINING IN THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE. IT IT CAUSES ME TO
BE UNCOMFORTABLE. AS A MEMBER
OF A JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE APPROVING THE
EXPENDITURE OF NOT IN
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF MONEY
APPROVING ANY IN ESSENCE THE
SCOPE OF AN AUDITING THAT IS
FRAMED BY THE REQUEST. HOWEVER
WELL RESPECTED BY ME AND OTHERS
AND HOWEVER WILL ROUTE-
RESPECTED BY MY COLLEAGUES. AND
JOINED IN BY THE AUDITOR WHEN
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO DECIDE WHETHER
THAT'S THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT
THAT SHOULD BE APPROVED OR NOT
PERHAPS. AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
WE DEAL WITH THAT. MAYBE I
COULD SHED SOME LIGHT ON THIS
RIGHT JUST BECAUSE HISTORICALLY
SPEAKING- WE'VE ALLOWED THE
REQUEST YOUR ONE TO TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE HEARING TO ACTUALLY
ADJUST THE SCOPE BASED OFF
THEIR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ENTITIES INVOLVED. I SEEMS TO
ME THAT TODAY'S HEARING THERE
SEEMS TO BE TWO DIFFERENT.
THINGS GOING ON ONE IS THE
ACTUAL NOTIFICATION WHICH WE'VE
GIVEN DEFERENCE TO EACH OTHER
OUR COLLEAGUES TO CHANGE THE
SCOPE WITHIN ONE TO TWO WEEKS
BEFORE AND SECONDLY WHETHER THE
REQUESTED ARE ACTUALLY REACHING
OUT TO THE IT TO THE ENTITIES
INVOLVED WHEN THEY'RE EXPLORING
THE IDEA. OF A POSSIBLE I
REQUEST AND IT'S AND IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT- THE LATTER IS THAT
SEEMS LIKE WERE REQUESTING OF
OUR COLLEAGUES IS IF THEY COULD
AT LEAST GIVE A- HEADS UP OR
HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH THE
MEMBER ONE WHOSE JURISDICTION
THAT A FAX. AND SECONDLY-
PERHAPS EVEN CONTACTING SOME
THE AGENCIES PRIOR TO
SUBMITTING A REQUEST TO THE
ATTIC BUT- READ. MISTER CHAIR
IF I MAY BE IF I MAY JUST.
FURTHER MY COMMENT THEN I GUESS
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS WHAT IS
OUR ROLE ARE WE SIMPLY A RUBBER
STAMP WHEN SOMEONE COMES IN AND
PRESENTS AN AUDIT SCOPE OR DO
WE HAVE AS A AS A AS A
COMMITTEE THE AUTHORITY TO
ADJUST. THE SCOPE OF THE OTHER
BASED ON THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IF WE'RE SIMPLY RUBBER
STAMP THEN I CAN SET UP STAIRS
EAT MY LUNCH SINCE WE ALL GET
ON IT IN RIGHT CORRECT NO-
MAYBE WE NEED TO WOULD HAVE FOR
THE YEAH THE CLARIFICATION THEN
WOULD BE YOU KNOW AS WE ALLOW
OUR COLLEAGUES THE WHAT THE-
THE ONE TO TWO WEEKS AS ARE
ADJUSTING THEIR SCOPE IS TO
WORK WITH COMMITTEE STAFF. IN
ADJUSTING THAT SCOPE WHERE
APPROPRIATE AND SO- NOT A
RUBBER STAMP BUT REALLY
ACTUALLY TRYING TO BE INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS AS WELL HELPING
THE MEMBERS I DETERMINE THE
SCOPE OF THEIR AUDIT AS A BRING
THAT BEFORE THE SLUDGE THAT
APPLY. AND IF I MAY ADD THEN
SAM YOU KNOW WE SOME FINALIZED-
ADJUSTED THE SCOPE OF THIS
AUDITOR'S REQUEST IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE SO IT WASN'T
AS IF THIS OFFICE JUST DECIDED
TO ASK A BUNCH OF RANDOM
QUESTIONS. WITHOUT SEEKING ANY
GUIDANCE FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THIS IS A CONTENTIOUS
ISSUE QUITE FRANKLY YOU KNOW IN
A COUPLE OF THESE COUNTIES AT
LEAST AND WE HAVE SEEN AND
HEARD OF THE STRUGGLES THAT THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ARE FACING
WHEN TRYING TO ACCESS A LOT OF
THIS INFORMATION AND SO OFTEN
TIMES. IT'S NOT ABOUT RUBBER
STAMPING BUT IT'S ABOUT
PROVIDING THE WEIGHT. AND THE
OVERSIGHT FROM THE STATE TO SAY
YOU KNOW THESE ARE OUR DOLLARS
THAT WE THEN PASSED ON TO YOU
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS REALIGNMENT OR THIS
INVESTMENT IS BEING USED
ACCORDING TO THE WISHES OF THE
NEEDS OF THE TAXPAYERS. AND
LASTLY I THINK AS WE ALL WOULD
HOPE I CERTAINLY DO I HOPE THAT
WHATEVER TRANSPIRES WITH THE
AUDITS ARE DONE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT I GOT YOU
BUT IN FACT THIS IS A THIRD ASK
TO SAY HOW ARE THESE DOLLARS
BEING USED BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY
CAN'T SEE THEM ON THE WEBSITE.
SO ARE THEY BEING USED WELL ARE
THEY YOU BEING USED AND IF NOT
WHAT ARE SOME COMMENDATIONS
THAT YOU ARE AND- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE- DOLLARS. WELL SPENT
AT THE END OF THE DAY I THINK I
WAS TAXPAYERS THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT WE WANT TO KNOW THAT WE
ARE GETTING A STRONG RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MENTAL AND
THE PHYSICAL HEALTH IN THE
CONDITIONS OF THOSE THAT ARE
BOTH INCARCERATED IN WORKING IN
THOSE FACILITIES. ARE BEING
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT BUT WE
CERTAINLY. GIVEN THE FACT THAT
REALIGNMENT HAPPENED WANT TO
KNOW THAT THAT'S- THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH OUR DOLLARS IS
WHAT WE SAID WE WANTED TO HAVE
DONE. AND ONCE AGAIN. YOU KNOW.
THEY'RE THE ARM OF THE STATE.
CAN BE VERY USEFUL AND HELPING
TO GUIDE THAT KIND OF. RESEARCH
WELL I THINK THE ME JUST MISTER
CHAIR IS ME JUST LIKE A FINAL
COMMENT. SO MRI THANK YOU YOU
AND YOUR AUDIT REQUEST JUST GOT
CAUGHT UP IN A LARGER
CONVERSATION. IT REALLY HAS
NOTHING TO DO FRANKLY WITH THE
NATURE OF THE REQUEST. FOR OR
THE VALIDITY OF THE REQUEST OR
PROBABLY THE NEED FOR YOU GOT
IT THIS JUST HAPPENS TO BE THE
SECOND TIME WE'VE HAD
RESPONDING ENTITIES COME. AND
SAY THEY FOR HAD VIRTUALLY NO
NOTICE OF REQUEST- AND THEN
WE'RE BEING ASKED TO DO WHAT I
DON'T KNOW. SO MY COMMENTS
REALLY YOU ARE- SIGNAL TO THE
PEOPLE THAT RUN THIS SHOP-
WHEREVER THEY ARE THAT MAYBE WE
NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS AT
THE STRUCTURAL. A MECHANISM BY
WHICH WE PROCESS AUDIT REQUESTS
AND THE NOTICE THAT WE GIVE TO
THE PEOPLE TO COME BEFORE US
BECAUSE IF WE WERE. ON THE
RECEIVING END. WE WOULD
PROBABLY WANT TO BE TREATED A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR YOUR
RESPONSE THAT WAS GOOD AND.
EURO YOUR NEXT. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON THEN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
RUBIO BUT LET ME REMIND THAT
THE COMMITTEE THAT WERE ALSO
BOUND BY THE RULES- BETWEEN THE
TWO HOUSES AND SO THIS IS SET
OUT IN THE RULES IF WE'D LIKE
TO CHANGE THAT MORE THAN HAPPY
TO DISCUSS THE CHANGES AS WE
MOVE FORWARD BUT THIS IS
OUTLINED IN THE RULES BETWEEN
THE JOINT HOUSES- FOR HOW THIS
COMMITTEE OPERATES SO WITH THAT
LET'S GO TO MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON THEM TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN REVIEW. HELLO
THINGS HERE THAT UP ARE I THINK.
ABSOLUTELY STRIKING. WE HAVE-
THE SHARE FOR FRESNO COUNTY
SITTING HERE SAYING THAT THEY
HAD NO NOTICE. NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO THAT THEY HAVE
DOCUMENTATION. WITH RESPECT
297% OF THEIR FUNDS BEING SPENT
THERE IS AN OVERSIGHT PROCESS
THAT HAS BEEN. UP ARTICULATED
AND THAT A THAT WELL REGARDED
DEEPLY RESPECTED AUDITING. FIRM
HAS IN FACT AUDITED. THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. HOW THIS
BODY COULD CONTINUE TO PUSH AN
AUDIT FOR A PARTICULARLY FRESNO
COUNTY AT THIS MOMENT WITH THIS
INFORMATION ON RESOLVED AND NOT
A PART OF THEIR DUE DILIGENCE
ON THEIR DELIBERATIONS.
HONESTLY STRIKES ME FAR MORE
MEDICAL THEN A REAL EFFORT AT
GETTING AT THE TRUTH. IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN GETTING AT THE
TRUTH WE HAVE INFORMATION THAT
CAN GET YOU THERE AND IT'S BEEN
PUBLICLY NOTED THAT FOR THE
RECORD I WANT TO JUST ALSO SAY
I'M I'M NEW TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND MY EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE FIRST OF ALL WAS WITH
A REQUEST FOR AN AUDIT OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL. IT TOOK
PROBABLY. TWO YEARS THREE YEARS
AGO APPROVED WE ARE UTILIZED A
GREAT DEAL OF HELP FROM A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF LEGISLATORS.
AND IT DID COME TO THIS BODY
THAT'S THE KIND OF PROCESS THAT
I THINK WE HAVE TO. AND HERE TO
IN ORDER TO BE ABSOLUTELY FAIR
THAT THOSE AGENCIES THAT ARE
BEING REQUIRE ARE REQUESTED TO
BE AUDITED. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF ENGAGING. WAY
PRIOR TO A NOTIFICATION OR WAY
PRACTICE AS HAVING TO SIT
THROUGH THIS. AND I REALLY AM.
RIGHT CONCERNED THAT SENSE I
SAT ON THIS COMMITTEE I HAVE
HAD THIS. REALLY SERIOUS UNDER
CURRENT OF DREAD THAT THIS BODY
IS ALLOWING ITSELF TO BE
POLITICIZED AND I WANT TO WARN
AGAINST THAT THE CREDIBILITY OF
THIS GROUP IS AT STAKE I AM NOT
SUGGESTING THAT WE DON'T DO
ANYTHING. WHAT I'M SUGGESTING
IS THERE IS NO NECESSITY TO
RUSH INTO THIS PARTICULARLY
GIVEN THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY OF
AT LEAST ONE AGENCY THAT HAS
LEGITIMATE CLEAR INFORMATION
READY AT HAND AND READY TO IT
AT THAT TO PREPARE TO BE. TO BE
PUT FORWARD SO- I I'M I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO VOTE NO ON THIS- BUT
I DO THINK THAT IT IS A
APPROPRIATE WARNING THAT OTHERS
HAVE BEEN GIVEN HERE. THAT WE
HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE COMING UNDER
THE PURVIEW OF IT A LOT OF
REQUEST. BE GIVEN A DUE PROCESS
OPPORTUNITY OF ENOUGH TIME TO
FULLY BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO THE
UNDERLYING QUESTIONS. MOST OF
THE A QUESTIONS COULD VERY WELL
BE ANSWERED WITHOUT OF THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. DOLLARS WORTH
OF INQUIRY IF WE WOULD JUST.
SLOW DOWN TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
AND ASK THE INFORMATION GIVE
PEOPLE PLENTY OF TIME AND THEN
GO FORWARD. THE DRESS PATTERSON
REMOVED TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FOR OUR YOUR
REQUEST- I THINK BEING FROM LA
COUNTY- I THINK THAT- WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT A COUPLE
DIFFERENT THINGS THE PROCESS
ABSOLUTELY HAS TO BE LOOKED AT
HOWEVER IN MY OPINION. IF I AN
AGENCY WITH WHOEVER MAY BE EVEN
IN MY OFFICE IF SOMEBODY IS
DOING THEIR JOB- AND THE
QUESTION IS ASKED YOU PULL OUT
AND I'M WITH A FILE AND PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION SOLD THE
ARGUMENT THAT THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION. LEADS ME TO THINK
THAT THERE OUGHT THEIR
PROCESSES ARE NOT NECESSARILY-
FLOWING PROPERLY BECAUSE IF YOU
NEED MORE THAN THAN YOU KNOW A
WEEK'S TIME TO PROVIDE PRODUCE
THAT INFORMATION THEN. WHERE
WHO IS WORKING ON THAT
INFORMATION NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO THIS IS MY FAVORITE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE GET TO
LOOK AT- DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
DIFFERENT- PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO IN THIS CASE WE HAVE
MULTIPLE AGENCIES THERE ARE
BEING AUDITED SO IF YOU GUYS
ARE DOING A GREAT JOB I WOULD
LOVE TO TAKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
AND PUT IN AN ALLEY COUNTY AS A
MODEL OF HOW LA COUNTY SHOULD
RUN THIS PARTICULAR- ITEM SOUL
IN IN AUDITING YOUR YOUR
SPECIFIC AGENCIES AND IF YOU
ARE DOING A GREAT JOB I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE THAT INFORMATION
SO THAT WE CAN GO TO LA COUNTY
AND SAY LOOK AT THE GREAT JOB
THAT THESE TWO AGENCIES ARE
DOING. CAN WE MODEL AFTER THAT
AND THE STATE AUDITOR'S. JOB IS
NOT A GOTCHA BUT STATE EITHER
JET AUDITOR'S JOB IN MY OPINION
IS TO- PRODUCE BEST PRACTICES
FOR WHATEVER AGENCY THAT WE
AUDITING AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO HOW OTHER
PROPHECIES CAN BE BETTER AND
WHAT BETTER WAY TO DO THAT THAN
TO SEE. OTHER AGENCIES THAT ARE
DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSE TO
BE DOING ANY AND IN LA COUNTY
TAKE YOU OF THE MODEL SO THAT
WE CAN SAY HATE THEY'RE DOING A
GREAT GREAT JOB LEADS DO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND THE OTHER- I
GUESS ISSUE IS THAT. WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT MONEY- THE
PUBLIC DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO AUDIT ANYBODY ANY
OF OUR THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
THE AGENCIES HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO GET THAT INFORMATION ON THE
WEBSITE. THEN THE NORMAL PUBLIC
HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION ON THE WEBSITE AND
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY THAT
WE PROVIDE IS BEING ACCOUNTED
FOR AND IN THIS CASE. AGAIN IF
THAT INFORMATION IS NOT
PROVIDED WHY IS IT NOT PROVIDED
DO THEY NEED A YEAR TO FIX
THAT. YOU KNOW SHOULD WE GAVE
THEM GIVE THEM A YEAR. IN
ADVANCE I HEADS UP THAT WE'RE
GOING TO I DID THEM SO THAT
THEY NOW THEY PUT IT ON THE
WEBSITE THAT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PROVIDE
ACCURATE INFORMATION. AND IF
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT THE MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY THAT WE DO TO AUDIT
THESE AGENCIES. SO IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE TAXPAYER AND
BEST INTEREST OF OUR MONEY I.
THINK THAT WE SHOULD ADDED
THESE PROGRAMS AND AGAIN TO THE
AGENCIES AFFECTED. YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO TAKE YOUR BEST
PRACTICES INPUT IN LA COUNTY
BECAUSE GUESS WHAT WE HAVE
ISSUES AN ALLEY COUNTY IS VERY
WELL KNOWN. AND IF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAVE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GET THAT INFORMATION
AFTER MULTIPLE REQUESTS THAN IT
TAKES US TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED. SO I
TO YOUR POINT I KNOW I DO
UNDERSTAND THE WHOLE TIME
FACTOR BUT IF YOU GUYS ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THAT. AND I WILL BE THE
FIRST ONE TO SEND OUT A LETTER
INTO A PRESS RELEASE ON YOUR
BEHALF AND HOW. ELLIE COUNTY
SHOULD MODEL AFTER YOUR
PRACTICES BECAUSE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN LA COUNTY IS NOT
GOOD FOR THE RESIDENTS. SO TO
THAT POINT YU KNOW THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR PROVIDING THIS
INFORMATION BUT TO YOU IT'S NOT
A GOTCHA WE WANT TO TAKE YOUR
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. AND MODEL
AFTER YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE OTHER AS- SHERIFF
DEPARTMENTS ARE DOING THE SAME
THING AND I JUST AN ALLEY
COUNTY BUT IF ACROSS THE STATE.
IF THERE ARE PROBLEMS IN THOSE
OTHER AGENCIES THAN YOUR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING SHOULD BE A MODEL
FOR THE STATE NOT JUST FOR
ELLIE MONEY. THANK YOU. I WANT.
THOSE WELL. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ALICE WOULD THE ASSEMBLY WILL
INVERTER INTO THE GUNS YEAH I
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE SOME MEMBER WILL BE THAT
WAS WELL. MAYBE THE- THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN GO THROUGH
AND KIND OF OUTLINE WHY YOU
CHOSE THESE THREE COUNTIES
BECAUSE CLEARLY OF ARTICULATED
THE PUBLIC ACCESS ISSUES WITH
THE INFORMATION FOR ALAMEDA AND
LA RIGHT RIGHT- MAYBE YOU CAN
ARTICULATE TO US WHY YOU'VE
INCLUDED FRESNO IN THIS IS IT
EXAMPLE OF THEY'RE DOING IT
WELL OR HOW THEY GOT INCLUDED
IN THIS AUDIT NOT HELP CLARIFY.
SOME OF THE INFORMATION BE
HAPPY TO WE- LOOKED AT THE
COUNTY- DEPARTMENTS THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE. AND DETERMINE THAT
WITH AN INCREASE IN DEATHS THAT
WERE HAPPENING WITHIN THE
COUNTY JAIL IN FRESNO THAT THAT
WAS A TRIGGER LOOKING OUT
ARTICLES AND RESEARCH THAT HAS
BEEN DONE ON SOME OF THE OTHER
COUNTY FACILITIES IN THE STATE
ALAMEDA IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HAVE BUBBLED UP REPEATEDLY.
EITHER FOR A GROWTH IN THE
SPENDING EVEN THOUGH YOU'VE
SEEN POPULATION DECREASES IN
THE COUNTY JAILS OR WITH A TUG
OF WAR THAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WITH REGARDS TO
BALLOONING- BUDGETS AND LACK OF
ACCESS. SO THAT'S WHY THOSE
THREE WERE SELECTED. IN FRESNO
COUNTY HAS A LEGITIMATE
VALIDATED. AUDIT THE DAY OF
RECENTLY COMPLETED. WE WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THAT WE WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE THAT BE SHARED WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR'S DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE THAT COULD INFORM A
NUMBER OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE ASKED IN THE SCOPE. AND
COULD ALSO PROVIDE SOME
INCREDIBLY RICH DATA TO BE
SHARED WITH THE OTHER COUNTIES
ARE ALSO BEING AUDITED THIS IS
NOT A GOTCHA BUT WE ARE
INCREDIBLY CONCERNED WITH THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT CONTINUES
TO GO TO EACH OF THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IT'S AN INORDINATELY
HIGH NUMBER. AND THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THE FUNDING
IS BEING USED IT DOESN'T MEAN
IT'S BEING USED POORLY. DOES
NOT AN INDICTMENT BUT IT IS A
REQUEST FOR THE INFORMATION AND
YOU CAN OFFER INFORMATION AND I
OBJECTIVE WAY IT'S CALLED DATA
AND THEN YOU USE THAT TO SAY
HOW CAN WE BE HELPFUL EITHER
THROUGH LEGISLATION OR
REGULATION TO HELP SHIP OR WORK
WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU'RE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
MAYBE INCREASING FUNDING AND
PROGRAMS THAT WORK DIVERTING
INTO PILOT PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
MAKE MORE SENSE GIVEN WHAT
MAYBE YOU'VE BEEN TRYING RIGHT
OR EXPERIMENTING WITH IN YOUR
OWN COUNTY. FOUR HUNDRED FOR
RIDE SOME. GLOBAL DECISION
MAKING AUTHORITY AROUND THINGS
THAT ARE NOT WORKING BUT YOU
KNOW THERE HAS TO BE A REASON
WHY FORTY SOME FOLKS DIED IN
THE COUNTY JAIL. WE WANT TO
KNOW WHY THERE'S OVER SPENDING
WITH REGARDS TO SOME OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND MAYBE
A DIVERSION AND PROGRAMMING AND
HATE MAYBE THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT
WE HAVE MADE. WILL TURN OUT NOT
TO BE TRUE BASED ON THE DATA
THAT WE RECEIVE BUT IT ALSO
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR US TO
SIT AROUND WITH ASSUMPTIONS
WITHOUT HAVING THE DATA TO
EITHER PROVE OR DISPROVE WHAT
WE'RE THINKING AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING AND WHAT WE'RE READING.
THANK YOU I AM A SENATOR
GONZALEZ PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
REQUEST I AM CERTAINLY MOST
CONCERNED WITH LA COUNTY BEING
IN LA COUNTY MEMBER- BECAUSE I
KNOW WE HAVE THE LARGEST SYSTEM
AND NOT ONLY THIS STATE BUT THE
COUNTRY AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THERE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND ARTICULATING THIS
IN A WAY THAT IS SO VERY-
RESPONSIVE TO OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THEY THEY'RE ASKING FOR
PAIN. NOW BUT I ALSO KNOW JUST
RESPECTIVE TO WHAT SENATOR ROBB
MENTIONED AND GIVEN THE
LANDSCAPE OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH IN THIS COMMITTEE
JUST TODAY. MYSELF INCLUDED-
WONDERING IF THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY I KNOW THAT. TO
YOUR- POINTS THAT FRESNO IN
ALAMEDA HAVE NOT BEEN
RESPONSIVE. ON'T WITH THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HAVEN'T BEEN
RESPONSIVE NECESSARILY. I'M
SORRY LOS ANGELES MY APOLOGIES
GOT THAT WRONG. SO IF WELL I
MEAN AS THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAD ASKED FOR IT
AND THAT WAS DENIED. OKAY SO
THAT WENT TO THE BOARD SO
ALAMEDA NOT TONIGHT OKAY.
WORKING FROM A PRIVATE COUNTY I
MEAN THIS STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
DAY WITH A NINE HUNDRED MEN'S
GROUP NO RIGHT OKAY A LOT NO
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL AFTER THAT.
SO GIVEN THE FACT THAT I THINK
ARE COLLEAGUES ALSO WANT TO BE
IN. INCLUDED IN THE DISCUSSIONS
GOING FORWARD POTENTIALLY. IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY DO- IS IT
POSSIBLE TO START WITH LA
COUNTY AND THEN PERHAPS FEES IN
FRESNO AND ALAMEDA AT LIKE A
THREE MONTH POINT. AFTER
THERE'S- STILL NO RESPONSE JUST
A SUGGESTION WELL I THINK WE
WERE CERTAIN WE WOULD BE OPEN
TO- THE STARTING WITH ALAMEDA
AND LOS ANGELES AND THEN
PHASING IN FRESNO GIVEN THEY
ARE THE ONLY COUNTY THAT. YOU
KNOW HAS COME HERE TO STATE
THAT THEY HAVE JUST COMPLETED
ON IT BUT ALAMEDA HAS NOT. OKAY
WHEN YOU HAVE LOS ANGELES.
RESPONSE NO RESPONSE OKAY.
GREAT PREP STATE AUDITOR YOU
COULD. SO I NEED TO BE CLEAR ON
WHAT THE EXPECTATION IS BECAUSE
OF THE AUDIT IS APPROVED WE CAN
CERTAINLY START IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SAN THE TEAM THEIR
FIRST. AND THEN SEND THAT THE
THAT HAVE THE TEAM GO TO
ALAMEDA COUNTY NEXT BUT WE
WOULD STILL GO TO FRESNO
COUNTY- AND CONDUCT THE SAME
PROCEDURES IT WOULD JUST BE
OUT. FOR A COUPLE MONTHS FROM
NOW AS FAR AS WHEN WE GET TO
FRESNO VERSES LA OR ALAMEDA. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE IT WAS
CLEAR TO THE COMMITTEE THAT WE
WOULD STILL BE AUDITING FRESNO.
BOB IF THE IF THE- THE
REQUESTED APPROVED BY THE
COMMITTEE. UNDERSTOOD REMOVED
HIS SOMEONE MEMBER PATTERSON
YEAH THIS CENTER BOARD JUST
HOPEFULLY BRIEFLY. HEY WE SEVEN
ADDITIONAL ITEM ON THE AGENDA.
FOR THE RECORD I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST MAKE SURE I WANT TO ASK
THE SHERIFF UP FROM FRESNO TO
REITERATE WHEN. WERE YOU
NOTIFIED THAT YOU ARE SUBJECT
OF THE AUDIT. I RECEIVED AN
EMAIL ON WEDNESDAY THE
NINETEENTH. WERE YOU AT THAT
TIME OR ANY TIME SUBSEQUENT TO
THAT. ASK FOR ANY SUPPORTIVE
DATA ANY DIRECT INFORMATION ANY
AUDITS OR ANY OTHER INFORMATION.
NO YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
UNDER ON TO THAT OUGHT TO BE
HONEST THAT THAT TO ME WE
REALLY. THIS IS NOT A FAIR AND
UNBIASED ASSETS FRESNO COUNTY
HAS BEEN THROWN IN TO TWO OTHER
COUNTIES THAT HAVE APPARENTLY
SOME. CONFLICT OR SOME SOME
KIND OF RIGHT SO I CAN'T VOTE
FOR THIS AND I REALLY WISH MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD SAY- YOU GOT
TWO OF THEM UP HERE YOU WANT
AUDIT FINE FRESNO COUNTY I
THINK SHOULD BE GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO RESPOND AND TO
BE A AT TO BE ABLE TO DIRECTLY
ANSWER THE BASIC. QUESTIONS AS
TO FIRST OF ALL WHAT DO YOU
SPENDING YOUR MONEY ON. 97% IS
GOING OUT THE DOOR. AND NUMBER
TWO. THAT THAT THE AUDIT IS IN
FULL VIEW EXCEPT HERE. THANK
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
EITHER WASN'T A QUESTION THERE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO CENTER
BORE GISTS BUT THOSE MISTER
PATTERSON'S REQUEST AND- WE
JUST COMMENT THAT NO WE USUALLY
GIVE DEFERENCE TO THE MEMBER
THAT REQUEST THE AUDIT TO
CHANGED SCOPE WITHIN THE
ALLOTTED TIME- SO WITH THAT
WILL LOSE CENTER BORDERS IN THE
HOME I'LL BE BRIEF. I THINK. I
THINK THAT INTO A CENTER
GONZALEZ HAD- PUTTING FORWARD
AN IDEA THAT. I THINK COULD
SATISFY EVERYONE'S INTEREST
YOUR DESIRE FOR INFORMATION AND
OUR DESIRE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S AN APPROPRIATE PROCESS
THAT IS HONORED- I THINK IT'S
CLEAR THAT. BASED ON THE- AN
INFORMATION SHEET WHICH
SPECIFICALLY REQUEST
INFORMATION ON WHAT STEPS TAKEN
WERE TAKEN. TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION THAT FORM THE BASIS
HAVING NOT GOTTEN RESPONSES
THAT FORMS THE BASIS OF THE
AUDIT. SO HOW ABOUT THIS. THAT
ARE YOU MENTIONED- THAT IN
AUDIT LIKE THIS WOULD TAKE
ABOUT SIX MONTHS THAT WE SAID
THAT'S CORRECT SENATOR HOW
ABOUT THIS WHAT IF WE WERE TO-
AUTHORIZE. THE AUDIT OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BECAUSE CLEARLY
THERE'S SOME HISTORY THERE
WHERE INFORMATION IS NOT BEEN
DISCLOSED. AND IN THE- IN THE
IN THE INTERIM OVER THE NEXT.
TWO MONTHS. THAT ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU ARE
REQUESTING BE PRODUCED BY BOTH
ALAMEDA AND FRESNO FRESNO
PARTICULAR BECAUSE I REPRESENT
THAT AREA- THAT THEY PROVIDE
ALL THE INFORMATION. THAT YOU
ARE REQUESTING IF FOR SOME
REASON THE DO NOT PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO YOUR
SATISFACTION. THEN WE'RE
MEETING HERE IN AUGUST IS THAT
THE NEXT AVAILABLE MEETINGS
THAT AUGUST GERMAN CORRECT AND
I HAD JUST CONFERRING WITH THE
RULES AS WELL AS WE CAN
ACTUALLY. IF IT'S UP TO THE
AUTHOR SHE WANTED TO EXCLUDE
ONE OF THE CONTY SETS HER PER
WHAT THE THAN FOR VICE LEE IT
IS IF YOU WERE JOKES COLLUDED
THAT. IN IF THEY'RE NOT
COMPLYING. BRING THIS MATTER
BACK IN IOWA ACTUALLY SUPPORT
THE AUDIT OF MY OWN COUNTY
UNDER THOSE VERY UNIQUE. BUT
HOT HARDLY FORESEEABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT I THINK GET
YOU EVERYTHING YOU WANT WELL IT
DOESN'T PENALIZE FOLKS. WERE
BLINDLY BEING BROUGHT INTO THIS
PROCESS. WHEN THEY WOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN WILLING TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO YOUR
PURSUIT OF IT. WAS SENATOR I
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO CONDUCT MY OWN
AUDIT IN MY OFFICE- AND IF I'M
HEARING YOU. THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
WHAT YOU WOULD BE ASKING OF ME.
ARE YOU HAVE NINE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU ARE PROPOSING THE
SCOPE OF THIS AUDIT. CERTAINLY
CERTAINLY. ARE A RESPONSE FROM-
FROM A COUNTY. WOULD BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THESE NINE QUESTIONS.
WITH RELATIVE EASE. THAT WOULD
BE MY HOPE TO BUT THAT IS- THE
HOPE THAT I'M NOT WILLING TO
PUT IN THE BANK I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A STATE AUDITOR'S
DEPARTMENT WHO IS GOT THAT
PROFESSIONAL. A CAPACITY AS
WELL AS THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
CONDUCT THIS AND I CERTAINLY
WOULD NOT WANT TO. OVERSTEP MY
PAY GRADE IN TRYING TO GO AHEAD
OF THE LEGISLATOR AND CONDUCT
AN AUDIT. I AM CERTAINLY
WILLING TO CONSIDER SOME DEGREE
OF FLEXIBILITY WITH REGARDS TO
THE AUDIT. AND HAVING ALAMEDA
LOS ANGELES BE PART OF THE
FIRST WAVE. AND THEN HAVE
FRESNO SENSE AS THEY MENTIONED.
THEY HAVE JUST COMPLETED AN
AUDIT IN HAVING 97% OF FUNDING
GO OUT THE DOOR IS ONE THING
KNOWING HOW IT IS BEING SPENT
AS SOMETHING ELSE AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU FIND WHEN YOU CONDUCT
AN AUDIT. SO I'VE I CAN I WOULD
LIKE TO COUNTER. YOUR OFFER- BY
ASKING FOR THOSE TWO TO BE
AUDITED FIRST. FOUR THANK YOU
THERE'S YOUR ANSWER ME THIS
BOERNER HORVATH IF WE COULD
MOVE QUICKLY WAS EVIDENT TIONAL
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA I KNOW WHEN
I'M LYING IS ON THE AGENDA TOO-
I APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. STAGGERING THAT
OUT AND SAYING ALAMEDA AND LA
WHERE CLEARLY. YOU THERE HAVE
BEEN A REQUESTED INFORMATION
HAS NOT COME BACK- HE'S- SO.
ALSO ADULT WAS THE TEST OF I'M
SORRY. PLEASE WAS BORDERLINE I
THOUGHT I HEARD FROM THE
REQUESTED- OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COMMA OTHER THAN
THAT INFORMATION IS REQUESTED
AND I AM GOING WITH WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAYS PLEASE DO NOT
INTERRUPT ME. AND I DO THINK
THERE'S A VALUE IF FRESNO IS
ALREADY DONE WE'VE WE'VE DEALT
WITH THIS ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS LAST YEAR IF
FRESNO IS ALREADY DONE THAT ON
IT MAYBE THE STATE ORDER CAN
CAN CHIME IN IF THAT
INFORMATION IS ALREADY THERE
YOU'RE NOT DUPLICATING THE
INFORMATION SORRY THERE YOU'RE
PROVING OF THAT INFORMATION
SATISFIES. THE REQUEST OF THE
IDEA IS THAT CORRECT IS NOT
ADDITIONAL AUDITING OF AN
EXISTING ARE ADDED THAT IS
CORRECT SO TO THE EXTENT AN
AUDIT HAS BEEN DONE WE WILL
LOOK AT THAT WORK DETERMINE
WHETHER WE CAN RELY ON IT IF
IT'S DONE BY A REPUTABLE FIRM I
WOULD ASSUME WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO RELY ON IT. WE WOULD WE
WOULD. WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
COULD RELY ON THE INFORMATION
IF WE DEEM THAT WE CAN RELY ON
IT THEN WE WILL NOT DUPLICATE.
THE WORK THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
DONE WE WILL USE THAT WORK TO
ANSWER SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN ASKED. SO IN
THEORY THIS COULD ACTUALLY
REDUCE ACTION THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF HOURS. IF THE WORK THAT
FRESNO HAS BEEN DONE. SATISFIES
THE QUESTIONS OF THE AUDIT AS
WELL CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT
OKAY. OR IF THANK GOODNESS ADAM
AT THE REALLY IMPORTANT UNLESS
IT WAS A DIRECT QUESTION TO YOU
WE NEED TO MOVE ON. OKAY AT
THIS TIME HEARING AND SEEING NO
MORE. QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE DíAS. LET'S GO TO MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JOHN LINDSAY POLAND
I'M WITH THE AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE A HERE IN
REPRESENTATION OF MORE THAN
FIFTY COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST. WE
HAVE WORKED FOR MORE THAN TWO
YEARS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY TO TRY
TO GET A PERFORMANCE AND
FINANCIAL AUDITS OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE THAT A
REQUEST HAS ALSO BEEN SUPPORTED
MORE THAN A YEAR AGO. BY A
LETTER FROM SENATOR SKINNER
WHOSE DISTRICT DICTION OF THIS
IS IN WHO ALSO CALLS FOR A FULL
PERFORMANCE AND FINANCIAL
AUDITS I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
USE ONE ON A AB ONE ONLINE
FUNDS. IS COMPLETELY OPAQUE IT
IS NOT AVAILABLE ON ANY
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE SITE. ED NOT
THAT LONG AGO SHERIFF A HER
THEMSELVES SAID PUBLICLY THAT
HE WELCOMES AN AUDIT. AND I
WOULD SAY FINALLY THAT- HOW THE
FUNDS ARE I DON'T AS MY
UNDERSTAND IT OTHER AUDITS AND
REPORTS AND POTENTIALLY EVEN
THE ONE FOR FRESNO. ARE NOT
ACTUALLY ASKING HOW ARE THE
FUNDS THAT THE SHERIFF'S ARE
USING FURTHERING THE PURPOSE OF
AB ONE ON THE LINE FOR NINE AND
QUIRK INCARCERATION
pOUT BY MISTER CLAYTON JOHNSON.
THAT IS ONE OF THE KEY POINTS
OF THE OF THE AUDIT REQUEST
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED FOR
ALL THREE COUNTIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
BIGGER PLEASE BE CONCISE WITH
THEIR COMMENTS SHORT KAELIN
DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR AT POLICY LINK
WE ARE IN STRONG COSPONSORED
SUPPORT OF THIS AND WE WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS REQUEST FORWARD. AND ALSO
THANK YOU REMEMBER RUBIO FOR
YOUR REMARKS TODAY WE REPRESENT
OVER TWO HUNDRED PARTNERING
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY. JOSH
DUGGAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
JUST WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH
TRANSPARENCY IN REALIGNMENT
SPENDING AND WELCOME THAT
CONVERSATION. HOWEVER WE DID
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE YEAR IT
THERE IS A ANNUAL REPORTING
FROM COUNTIES TO THE BOARD OF
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS AND
REPORTS POSTED ON THE- SEC'S
WEBSITE. I THINK THE REPORTS
YOU KNOW APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED PAGES INCLUDES
INFORMATION ABOUT. PROGRESS IN
ACHIEVING OUTCOMES IDENTIFIED
IN C. C. P. PLANS. ON
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE- TARGETED.
AND THERE IS THE ANNUAL FUNDING
AND THE ON BOARD OF SAYING
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS BUDGET
THAT FUNDS. THE GATHERING OF
THE C. C. P.'S IN EACH COUNTY
AND COUNTIES DON'T RECEIVE
THOSE FUNDS UNLESS THEY-
RESPOND TO ALL THE QUESTIONS
AND INFORMATION. REQUESTED BY
STATE. I WILL SKIP THE PIECE
ABOUT THE CONTEXT SETTING ON
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
I THINK WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT ALREADY
BUT- JUST ONE MAKE IT CLEAR
COUNTY STEPPED. UP TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE. TO HELP SOLVE A
VERY COMPLEX PROBLEM. AND THE
SOLUTION THAT WAS AGREED UPON-
DID NOT INCLUDE TRYING TO MAKE
EVERY. COUNTY IN THE STATE LOOK
LIKE EACH OTHER NOR LOOK LIKE
THE STATE SYSTEM- SO LIKE I
SAID- WE ARE. OPEN TO
TRANSPARENCY IN FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS BUT- JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE. IT'S CLEAR WHAT
INFORMATION IS OUT THERE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE. A MAKE A
MOTEL WITH THE YOUNG WOMEN'S
FREEDOM CENTER AND THIS IS TO
WORRY YEARS FREEDOM COALITION.
REPRESENTING FIVE HUNDRED
COALITION MEMBERS OF THAT ARE
HOLDING DOWN CHAPTERS IN EACH
OF THE- COUNTIES THAT AUDITS
WERE REQUESTED. OF ITS THE- OF
REQUESTS THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT- AND PROTECTION OF OUR
LOVED ONES ON THE INSIDE AND
ARE FORMALLY INCARCERATED WOMEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK YOU
NATIONAL TEST MONEY PLACE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS DENNIS
LET US ROMERO WITH ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF TIS
AUDIT REQUEST- ONE OF OUR
AFFILIATES ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN THE AUDIT- ALAMEDA
COUNTY REQUEST FOR THE PASS
OVER THE LAST PAST YEAR SO WE
STRONGLY URGE- THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THIS AUDIT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
WELL MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BRENDAN UP ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF. ONE WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
AUDIT REQUEST. TO IF WE WERE UP
PROVIDED THE NINE QUESTIONS WE
WOULD OF CERTAINLY RESPONDED
AND PRESIDENTIAL FLANK ONCE
QUESTIONS. AND NUMBER THREE- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO IF THIS IS
GRANT OF THE RESULTS BECAUSE
WHO KNOWS MAYBE WE'LL SHOW THE
LA COUNTY IS A MODEL COUNTY.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. MISSIONAL
TESTIMONY MISTER CHAIRMAN WRIST
CORSAGE ALONG HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
ON SUPPORTER IN OPPOSITION TO
THE REQUEST. BUT WE JUST NOTE
THAT REALIGNMENT WAS A
MONUMENTAL REFORM. THAT BROUGHT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE TOGETHER
IN PARTNERSHIP NOT ONLY AT THE
STATE AND COUNTY LEVEL BUT ALSO
COUNTY AGENCIES JUSTICE
PARTNERS WORKING TOGETHER. TO
ADDRESS NOT ONLY ALTERNATIVES
TO ARBITRATE PRISONER RELEASES
THAT WOULD HAVE RESULTED FROM
THE PRISON OVERCROWDING- BUT TO
ADDRESS LOCAL SYSTEM NEEDS WE
STARTED WITH FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT SPOTS. WE HAVE TO
REALIZE THAT FLEXIBILITY IN
THIS IS VITAL- THE PLANS FOR
EACH COUNTY ARE ON THE BSE SEE
WEBSITE. THEY ARE UPDATED- THE
BE A C. C. DOESN'T ANNUAL
REPORT THAT SHOWS HERE'S WHAT
THE COMMITTEE WITH THE COUNTIES
HAVE PUT TOGETHER. THE CCP
PROCESSES PUBLIC THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAVE ARE
THE ABILITY TO DIE I REQUEST
FOR FUNDING. IT'S ALL PUBLIC
IT'S ALL NOTICED. IT'S ON THE
BSE SEE WEBSITE SO WOULD
COMMEND THAT TO THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION- AND JUST ASK YOU
THAT AS YOU CONSIDER THIS AUDIT
REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT MASS BECAUSE THERE'S
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
HEARING AND SAYING NONO. RETURN
IT BACK TO THE DíAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES I WOULD. JUST LIKE
TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THOSE
WHO PROVIDED COMMENT WE- TO ARE
NOT SUGGESTING THAT EVERY
COUNTY LOOK LIKE EACH OTHER WE
JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THREE OF THE
COUNTY- AND HOPEFULLY WHAT
COMES BACK FROM. THE AUDIT OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WILL REVEAL
THAT SOME OF THE PRACTICES.
THAT THEY ARE EMPLOYING COULD
SERVE AS MODELS AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR OTHER DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. AND LASTLY. I
PRINTED OUT THE PAGE FOR THE B.
STC OF THE PLANS AND FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THERE
ONLY THREE PLANS ON THERE KERN
COUNTY CALAVERAS AND STANISLAUS
COUNTY. THOSE ARE ALMOST THE
SAME. UNTIL TWO THOUSAND.
TWELVE THIRTEEN SO YOU KNOW
FIVE YEARS IS A LONG TIME. A
LOT OF THINGS THAT HAPPENED IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS THIS ALL
THE REQUESTED ASKING OR THESE
NINE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR'S DEPARTMENT WHEN
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
YEAH I BELIEVE IN TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY BELIEVE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN ARTICULATED IT REALLY
WELL I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
GOTCHA BUT RATHER SING WHAT
BEST PRACTICES ARE OUT THERE IN
OF THE STATE ADDRESS DONE THAT
WITH A NUMBER OF AGENCIES IN
THE PAST- WE WILL REVISIT
PERHAPS WE HAVE TO ADJUST THE
JOINT ROLES BETWEEN THE HOUSES.
AFTER SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
AS WELL BUT THIS TIME I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE AUDITED THE
SECRETARY. CALDERON WE NEED A
MOTION. THE LET ME ASK FOR THE
MOTION WE WILL. HAS COME UNDER
LET ME MAKE SURE I GET THIS
CORRECT SO EMOTIONAL BE TO
APPROVE THE ODD IT. LOOKING AT
LOS ANGELES FIRST ALAMEDA
SECONDED FRESNO THIRD CORRECT
YES. OKAY WITH THAT DO I HAVE A
MOTION ON. MOVED BY MISTER WOOD
OF THE SECOND SECOND BY MISS
RUBIO- MISS SECTOR CALDERON.
CORRECT. THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE AUTUMN REQUEST NUMBER
TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE OF TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM LONGER.
REGARDING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND THREE FRESNO
COUNTY. SHERIFF'S OFFICES
REALIGNMENT FUND SPENDING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI SALAS
HI BOERNER HORVATH. HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI JAN.
PATTERSON PATTERSON NOW RUBIO
RUBIO HIGH VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD. WHAT I SENATOR ROTH.
BARGES BORDERS NOW GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I MINING. MORE LOCKED.
WIENER. OKAY THAT ITEMS ON CALL
LEAVE A FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THAT ON THANK YOU. OKAY MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE ONE FOR
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
PROGRAMS BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
AS A ROUGH FOR WHEN YOU'RE
READY TO BEGIN PLEASE. THANK
YOU. I AFTER AN AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON HAVE BEEN HERE SINCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
WE'RE HERE TODAY ON THE ISSUE
THAT IS NOT NEW TO ANY OF US
HERE IT'S ONE THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED- BOTH OPENLY AND
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS OF MY NINE
YEARS OF BEING HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S A ISSUE THAT HAS
ALWAYS RISEN ITSELF AND LOOKING
AT HOW EFFECTIVE WE ARE
ALLOCATING MONEY. TO
TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE PROGRAMS
AND TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
BUDGET FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION AND G. G. R. F.
MONEY WAS ALLOCATED TO CAR LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
IN TOTAL GARBAGE BIN OUT
ALLOCATED TWO POINT TWO BILLION
AGAIN TWO POINT TWO BILLION
FORCE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
THIS INCLUDES LIGHT AND HEAVY
DUTY EQUIPMENT PROGRAMS. THE
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE- RECYCLING
PROGRAM SCHOOL BUS REPLACEMENT
AND OTHER PROGRAMS AND YET THE
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATURE. HAS
NOT ORDERED A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF THE THIRTY TWO
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS AT CAR.
THERE ARE BE REVIEWS OF CERTAIN
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CALL CARL
MARKET MORE YOUR PROGRAM- BUT
THAT WAS OVER THIRTEEN YEARS
AGO. SOME CAR PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN SCOPED INTO MULTI AGENCY
AUDITS BUT NOT A SIMILAR AUDIT
AS IT RELATES TO CARPET SO. IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE ATTEMPTED TO ASSESS
THE COST IN GOLD THE VARIOUS
CAR PROGRAMS BY THE END OF THE
YEAR THOSE COMMUNITIES WERE
ABLE TO DO SO TO JUST FIVE OF
THOSE PROGRAMS. FOUR YEARS
LATER THEY'RE STILL NOT BEEN AN
OVER ARCHING REVIEW OF ALL
THESE PROGRAMS AND THEIR
AGGREGATED A FAX AS A RESULT.
AND AS OF- THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS TOLD US WE
DO NOT HAVE COMPLETE. A
COMPLETE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AND AS LEGISLATORS I
THINK WE WOULD ALL WANT TO KNOW
THE ANSWERS TO THAT. THE
REQUEST IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT THIS QUESTION TO BED ONCE
AND FOR ALL A MOVE FOR WHAT A
COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T. THE
ONLY GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW AGAIN IT ONLY MAKES SENSE
WE CAN ASSESS. THESE PROGRAMS
BASED ON THE COST OF EACH
METRIC TONS OF CARBON DIOXIDE
THE REDUCE. AND THAT MEASURE
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY SOME
PROGRAMS COSTS. LESS IS HUNDRED
ALL THE TIME WELL THERE'S OTHER
PROGRAMS IT'S COST AS MUCH AS
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A TODD
AGAIN WE SHOULD WANT TO KNOW
THOSE COST. BUT A FEW METRICS
DOESN'T GET THE UNDERSTANDING
TO THE QUESTIONS HERE. WHICH IS
HOW EFFECTIVE ARE THESE
PROGRAMS WORKING TOGETHER AS A
WHOLE. ALTOGETHER THESE
PROGRAMS REPRESENT A MASSIVE
AGGREGATE AND INVESTMENT IN LOW
CARBON FUTURE CARP HAS BEEN
AUDITED BEFORE BUT IT'S
TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE PROGRAMS
HAVE NOT BEEN ANALYZED IN
RECENT YEARS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TRIED TO TAKE
AN INITIAL SURVEY OF THESE
PROGRAMS. THE LACK OF
CONSISTENT POLICY EVALUATION
POTENTIAL FOR COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
I MISSION SHUFFLING AND SOME
AMOUNT OF ON QUANTIFIABLE
RESOURCES ARE BEING WASTED FOR
FREE RIGHTS WHAT CAR IS MADE
DATA AVAILABLE ON PROGRAM
SPENDING IT IS STILL UNCLEAR
HOW THEY INTERACT AND WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR NET CARBON REDUCTIONS
ARE. AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE
LECTURE CITY SECTOR SOMETIMES
PROGRAMS ARE COMBINED. SO
SOMETIME PROGRAM COMBINED
EFFECTS LEAD TO A MISSION
SHUFFLING RATHER THAN NET
REDUCTIONS IT IS ALSO UNCLEAR
IF WE ARE UNDER UNDER UNDER
FUNDING PROGRAMS. WITH
EFFICIENT ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
COST OR OVER FUNDING
INEFFICIENT PROGRAMS TAKE THE
PORT OF LOS ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT PORCH
LEAD TO STAY ON DEVELOPING SHIP
TO SHORE POWER. HOWEVER CARPOOL.
AT BIRTH. PROPOSED RULE ARE
SIGNIFICAN MORE THE EMPIRE
REQUIREMENTS IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT
IF ANYTHING CARP IS DOING WITH
THESE POLICIES TO ENSURE OUR
PORTS STAY COMPETITIVE TO
PRIVATIZE COST EFFECTIVENESS
REQUIREMENTS AND TO CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP A ROBUST LABOR FORCE
AGAIN MEMBERS WE WILL NOT BE
THE FIFTH LEADING ECONOMY IF
OUR PORCH SHUT DOWN. WHAT OUT
AUDIT WE WILL NOT KNOW IF CARBS
PROGRAMS ARE PRIORITIZE A LEASE
COSTS BEST FITS WHAT OUT OF
AUDIT WE WILL NOT KNOW WHETHER
THESE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM TO
HELP IN THE STATE DEVELOP AN
EQUITABLE AND DIVERSE WORKFORCE
FOR EXAMPLE IF SIT SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF INSTEAD OF DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO WEALTHY FREE
RIGHTS THEN THE POLICY NEEDS TO
BE CHANGED WE REFORM. THEIR UP
THE C. B. R. P. PROGRAM TO
FOCUS ON MIDDLE AND WORKING
CLASS FAMILIES BUT HOW MANY OF
THE OTHER PROGRAMS HAVE THE
SAME STRUCTURAL INADEQUACIES
ALL THIS AUDIT WOULD ALSO A
SENSE THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
GIVEN CAR A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITIES AND I SUPPORT
CARDS EFFORTS JUST LIKE I
SUPPORT CLIMATE INVESTMENTS. IF
FOR THESE READ ALONE. THAT I
CARE ABOUT THE CONTINUED
EXISTENCE AND I WANT THEM TO BE
FAIR AND EFFECTIVE BASED ON
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL COSTS AND
THAT'S WHY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR- MADAM HONOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AS AS A SENATOR BRADFORD
INDICATED THAT IT WOULD BE AN
AUDIT OF THE CAR PROGRAM AND T
WOULD BE SPECIFIC TO THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. SO
STARTING OUT IDENTIFYING THE
NUMBER AND TYPE OF PROGRAMS AS
HE INDICATED THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FOUR
PROGRAMS BUT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THIS THE TYPE. OF
PROGRAM AND WHAT WHAT THE
INTENT OF THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM IS AND THAT TIES TO THE
NEXT OBJECTIVE WHICH WOULD BE.
LOOKING AT THE EXTENT TO WHICH
ANY OF THESE PROGRAMS OVERLAP
ONE ANOTHER AND HOW THEY-
INTERACT WITH ONE ANOTHER. AND
THEN HE'S ASKING US TO LOOK AT
A SELECTION OF THESE PROGRAMS
OF THESE GHG ARM GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
AGAIN SPECIFICALLY IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR- AND
DETERMINE WHETHER FIRST OF ALL
WHETHER CARB DOES ANY
ASSESSMENT OR EVALUATION OF THE
EFFECTS OF THE PROGRAMS ON
COMMUNITIES. AND HOUSEHOLDS OUT
WHAT AFTER THAT AFTER THEY
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS. AND IF
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING WHICH IT
APPEARS THAT IT ISN'T FOR ALL
PROGRAMS- HE'S ASKING US TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE. ASSESS HOW
EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS AFFECT
HOUSEHOLDS IN COMMUNITIES WE
MAY NEED TO HIRE A CONSULTANT
TO ASSIST US WITH THAT BUT
WE'VE DONE THAT IN THE PAST. IN
ADDITION- SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL OBJECTIVES RELATED
TO THE SELECTION OF PROGRAMS
WOULD BE. AS CENTER BRADFORD
REFER TO IT AS SHUFFLING IS IT
REALLY A REDUCTION OR IS IT A
SHIFTING OF. THE MISSIONS
RATHER THAN AN ELIMINATION OF
THOSE PARTICULAR MISSION THAT'S
MOVING THE EMISSIONS ARE
SHUFFLING AS A SENATOR REFERRED
TO IT. ALSO LOOKING AT THE
PROGRAMS IN THEIR COST
EFFECTIVENESS- INCLUDING SOCIAL
BENEFITS AND COSTS AND COMPARE
THE PROGRAMS OUT TO ONE
ANOTHER. FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE.
ALSO LOOKING AT WHETHER OR NOT
CARP STRATEGIES ARE REDUCING
THE OCCURRENCE OF A PARTICULAR
ISSUE HOW WELL ARE THESE
PROGRAMS WORKING. AND
ENCOURAGING PARTICIPANTS TO
REDUCE. GREENHOUSE GAS.
EMISSIONS ARE. REDUCED AND
THEIR ACTIVITIES ARE
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
VEHICLES- ALSO A COUPLE OF
OTHER OBJECTIVES HE'S ASKED US
TO LOOK AT IS ASSESSING THE
PROCESS CAR MUSES WHEN THEY-
WHEN THEY DRAFT THEIR INITIAL
STATEMENT OF REASONS WHEN
THEY'RE PROPOSING A NEW
PROGRAM. FOR THE SPECIFICALLY
AGAIN FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR AND HE'S ASKED US A FEW
THINGS RELATED TO THAT. HOW
DOES CARB CONSIDER THE EFFECTS
OF THE PROGRAM ON AIR QUALITY
THE ENVIRONMENT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THE
OVERALL ECONOMY AND CERTAINLY
HOW WITH THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM AFFECT LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-
AGAIN. WITH RESPECT TO THE
INITIAL STATEMENT OF REASONS
FOR A NEW PROGRAM. HOW IS CARP
CONSIDERING POTENTIAL
INTERACTIONS AGAIN AND EFFECTS
WITH THE ALREADY EXISTING
PROGRAMS ARE THEY TAKING THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION. AND THEN
FINALLY- ASKING FOR SUGGESTED
CHANGES- WHETHER THERE NEED TO
BE ANY CHANGES TO ANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS- AND WHETHER THOSE
CHANGES CAN BE. CHANGED THROUGH
LEGISLATIVE ACTION OR THROUGH
REGULATION BY CARB THEMSELVES
OF THE AUDIT IS ABOUT TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED HOURS AS I
INDICATED- BECAUSE OF STE THE
TECHNICAL NATURE OF SOME OF
THIS WILL MAKE A DETERMINATION
IF THE AUDITS APPROVED. WE NEED
TO HIRE A CONSULTANT TO ASSIST
US WE CERTAINLY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT- AND THE
ABILITY TO DEATH WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR ALTERNATE BACK TO
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU. ARE
THE SAME GOING TO MOVE TO THE
AFFECTED AGENCIES. PLEASE.
ARE
A TIME THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S RICHARD
CORY I'M THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD I'M JOINED HERE WITH OUR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR DR DAVID
GARCIA. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S APPROACH TO
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND IT'S IMPORTANT.
AIR POLLUTION FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. THE
CHIEF STATE AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING HEALTH
BASED AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
CALIFORNIA USES A MIX OF
MANDATES INCENTIVES AND MARKET
MECHANISMS MEANING MANY OF
CARBS PROGRAMS ACHIEVE A TRIPLE
BANG FOR THE BUCK BY ONE.
REDUCING EMISSIONS OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES AND TRADITIONAL AIR
POLLUTANTS THAT DIRECTLY IMPACT
PUBLIC HEALTH TO REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THAT
AFFECT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THREE. CHEATING COST EFFECTIVE
AND EQUITABLE OUTCOMES NOW AS
FOR HOW CARBS MISSION RELATES
TO THIS AUDIT. AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMAN. GARCIA
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN EXTENDED
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY. AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT REQUIRED THE LA- TO
REPORT ON THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
AND BENEFITS OF CALIFORNIA'S.
GHG EMISSIONS GOALS THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LA- REPORT SPUR THE
AUDIT REQUEST FOR THIS
COMMITTEE BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
CAR WAS NOT AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY RESPOND. NOR WERE
EVEN AWARE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN POSED UNTIL. I
RECEIVED THE REQUEST TO APPEAR
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE LAST
WEDNESDAY. WHAT THE COMMITTEE
MAY FIND HELPFUL TO KNOW IS
THAT THE LA AUDIT REPORT IS
CONSTRAINED BY STATUTE TO FOCUS
NARROWLY ON GHG REDUCTIONS
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS IT
DOES NOT CONSIDER THE OTHER
STATE AND FEDERAL MANDATES ON
CARBS PROGRAMS. THE CONSTRAINT
ELIMINATES THE ABILITY OF THE
REPORT TO ADDRESS THE OTHER KEY
DRIVERS TO CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGIES
NAMELY. THE NEED TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE HEALTH OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY THOSE
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
SPECIFICALLY THE REPORT FOCUSES
ON GHG EMISSIONS RATHER THAN A
KEY DRIVER BEHIND THE MOBILE
SOURCE MEASURES WHICH REDUCE
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER. AS
WELL SMOG FORMING POLLUTANTS
ARE PREPARED TO RESPOND
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. BUT MY MAIN
RESPONSE IS WHEN A
DISAPPOINTMENT OVER THE FACT IT
WOULD NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS AND RESPOND TO THE
REQUEST. PRIOR TO APPEARING
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN SUMMARY. I
REQUEST OF THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER DIRECTING CARB TO WORK
WITH SENATOR BRADFORD TO
RESPOND AS QUESTIONS. SURE
ANSWERED BE INSUFFICIENT
COMMITTEE COULD CONSIDER
APPROVING A REVISED AND BETTER
INFORMED I REQUEST. AT THAT
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR.
RIGHT ADDITIONAL I THINK YOU'RE
THE ONLY AFFECTED AGENCY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AT THE
TIME WAS GOING TO TURN IT TO
MEMBERS ON THE DíAS FOR
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD THEN CENTER
BORDERS THANK YOU PLEASE VOTE
THANK YOU- SENATOR BRADFORD FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I THINK
THAT THE FACT THAT THERE WAS A
POTENTIAL AUDIT REQUEST- LAST
YEAR SHOULD HAVE GIVEN YOU
PLENTY OF WARNING THAT WE
WANTED ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS
ALTHOUGH THAT ARE DID MOVE
FORWARD SO THIS SHOULDN'T
REALLY BE A SURPRISE TO YOUR
AGENCY QUITE FRANKLY- AND- I
THINK THE QUESTIONS ARE VALID-
YOU TALK ABOUT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES I'M GONNA GET A
LITTLE LITTLE BIT ON THE SUB
SOAP BOX HERE BUT- I REPRESENT
SOME OF SOME POOR COMMUNITIES
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE
DON'T QUALIFY UNDER YOUR AND
YOUR DEFINITION OF ENVIRO OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE IN GENERAL MOST OF THE
YEAR UNLESS WE HAVE A WILD FIRE
WHICH YOU GUYS DON'T WANT TO
MEASURE THAT BY THE WAY- WE
DON'T WE HAVE CLEAN AIR WE ALSO
HAVE CLEAN WATER BECAUSE WE
SUPPLY WATER TO A HUGE PART OF
THE STATE. WE HAVE A LOT OF
TREES AND THEY HAD TEND TO BE
CARBON SINKS WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND MARK COMMUNITY THAT
ARE- THAT HAVE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE RETROFIT REQUIREMENTS
FOR TRACTORS FOR TRUCKS AND SO
ONE AND THEY DON'T QUALIFY FOR
A LOT OF PROGRAMS AND OTHER
PEOPLE IN OTHER STATES THAT
PART THE STATE DO AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT G. H. G. PRODUCTION
AS A STATEWIDE ISSUE WHY ARE
YOU GUYS DISADVANTAGED PUTTING
OUR COMMUNITIES AT A
DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE G. H. G.
IS A G. H. G WORDS GENERATED
IN. THROUGHOUT AND I THINK
THAT'S I THINK THAT'S A
DISSERVICE TO- TO A LOT OF US
IN IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M
NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO FEELS THIS
WAY THE WHOLE COALITION OF
FOLKS WITH THE BAY AREA- CAUCUS
THAT FEEL THE SAME WAY AND I
GET THAT WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
THE COMMUNITIES THAT MAYBE NEED
SOME OF THIS THE MOST BUT- I
WOULD SAY THERE'S AN IN EQUITY
FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES AND WE
GIVE AN EXAMPLE EVERYBODY FOR
X. THAT RURAL COMMUNITY. IT'S
THE TO LIVE IS LOW THEIR- IT'S
NOT. THE WE HAVE TO TRY. BY
TRUCK. EVERYTHING INTO MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE WE DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE A REAL PORT THAT
THAT BRINGS GOODSAND SERVICES
AND SO WE ARE INFLUENCED BY THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR SIX IT
MAY NOT BE SO THAT THE AIR IS
BROWN VISIBLY BROWN BUT WE ARE
INFLUENCED BY THAT. AND SO. YOU
THERE IS A FRUSTRATION AND IN
EQUITY PART OF THIS THAT
DOESN'T FEEL RIGHT. AND IN IF
YOUR DEPARTMENT AS WE'VE HEARD
FROM OTHERS IS OTHER PEOPLE
HERE IF. IF YOU'RE DOING
EVERYTHING GREAT YOU SHOULD
WELCOME THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOWCASE HOW GOOD WHAT A
GOOD JOB YOU'RE DOING. AND YOU
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON NOTICE
THERE BEEN MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS TO
TRY TO GET INFORMATION ABOUT
THIS AND YOU SHOULD OF BEEN ON
NOTICE THAT THIS MIGHT BE
COMING AT SOME POINT. BUT IT'S
HERE AND I PLAN TO SUPPORT
THIS- FOR THIS AND AMERICA BY
THE REASONS. THANK YOU. HELLO
MISTER WOULD YOU EXPECT A
RESPONSE IF NOT WE'LL MOVE ON
TO. PLEASE DON'T HI ACTION I
JUMPING BIKE A APPS. LIKED
RESPOND TO FEW FEW POINTS. ONE
YOUR POINT OF DISOBEY
COMMUNITIES. AND YOU'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT I BELIEVE G. G.
R. F. CAP AND TRADE FOR
EXPENDITURES WHICH ARE
APPROPRIATE BY THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT THEY ARE APPROPRIATE
ACCORDING TO STATE LAW STATE
LAW A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTY DEFINES
EXPENDITURES AND THE
PERCENTAGES THE NEED TO BE
EXPANDED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES NOW IT'S NOT ALL
THE DOLLARS ARE SIGNIFICANT. A
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING AND MANY
OTHER PROGRAMS THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATES THOSE DOLLARS TWO
DOZEN PLUS AGENCIES. THEY'RE
GOING UP AND DOWN THE STATE IF
THE POINT IS THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
MONEY ABSOLUTELY THE POINT IS
THOSE DOLLARS ARE MISSING
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES ARE NEVER
ENOUGH BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY
MULTIPLE EXAMPLES. OF A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS ACROSS THE
STATE IN TERMS OF HOW THOSE
EXPENDITURES ARE DETERMINED AND
I'D I'D SUBMIT AN THIS IS
IMPORTANT. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION WITH
FULLY FOLLOW IT WE FULLY FALL
LEGISLATION THAT CONCERNS
EXPENDITURESEXPENDITURE THOSE
DOLLARS THEN GO THROUGH A FULL
PUBLIC PROCESS YOU CAN TAKE A
YEAR IN TERMS OF THE
SOLICITATIONS THE GUIDANCE IN
THE ULTIMATE WHERE THOSE
DOLLARS. IN THOSE ALSO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE POINT YOU MADE
ABOUT THIS IS MUCH MORE THAN
GHGS IT'S DIESEL PM IN FACT THE
MENTIONED AT THE CENTER
BRADFORD MADE OF FIVE AT BIRTH.
BY THE PORTS THAT'S ABOUT
DIESEL THAT'S LOCAL EXPOSURE TO
DIESEL PM THE ADVERSELY IMPACTS
PUBLIC HEALTH RELEASE ANY OF
THE GHG ISSUE. SO PROCESS WISE.
I ALWAYS OPEN TO HIM AND MAKE
SURE THEM CLEAR AND HER OF LAW
WE FOR. THE PROCESS WE GO
THROUGH. IN THE FULL DISCLOSURE
ALL WHAT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
IN TERMS OF EXPENDITURES.
DOCUMENTED EVERY YEAR EVERY
YEAR TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ALL THOSE
EXPENDITURES THOSE APPROPRIATED
G.G. G. R. F. DOLLARS. REALLY
IMPORTANT IN MY CONCERN ON THE
SLEEVE WITH THE REQUEST. WASN'T
THE ONE CONCERN WITH THE
QUESTIONS ALL ABOUT GHGS WHEN
MANY OF THE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY ARE FOCUSED
ON DIESEL AND KNOCKS NGH
JENNINGS WAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY WORK FOR OF YOUR POINT
ABOUT LAST YEAR WE RESPONDED IN
WRITING I RESPOND IN WRITING
MULTIPLE TIMES TO EVERY
QUESTION THAT WAS RAISED AS
WELL AS MET WITH THE CHAIR A
FEW TIMES DOING OUR LEVEL BEST
MY TO BE FULLY RESPONSIVE AND
YOU'LL ALWAYS GET THAT FULL
COMMITMENT TO BE FULLY
RESPONSIVE. THANK YOU. CAN I
MISSED HER WHAT LEASE JUST JUST
YOU KNOW AS- A LITTLE BIT AT IS
ALL THIS INFORMATION THAT YOU
THESE REPORTS ARE THEY ALL
ELIGIBLE ARE THEY ALL.
TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC THIS
CAN PUBLIC SEE ALL THESE
REPORTS YES. THE CHALLENGE AND
I WANT TO BE CLEAR ON THIS
BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A
FAIR POINT BECAUSE THE POINT IS
BEEN MADE BEFORE. IS THE OTHER
AGENCIES FIFTY YEARS WITH FIFTY
YEARS OLD THE NUMBER OF MOBILE
SOURCE SPECIALS WHY DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER MOBILE SOURCE MEASURES
WE HAVE THIRTY VEHICLES OF CARS
TRUCKS AND VARIOUS EQUIPMENT ON
THE ROAD AGENCY. I HAS
STRINGENT FEDERAL APARTMENTS IN
TERMS OF IMPROVING YOUR QUALITY
WHICH BY THE WAY CALIFORNIA'S
AIR QUALITY IS VASTLY BETTER
THAN IT USED TO BE. OF COURSE
99% CLEANER TODAY THAT
INFORMATION'S AVAILABLE BUT ONE
THING IT WAS CLEAR IT WAS CLEAR
TO ME. IS CLEARLY ACCESSING ANY
INFORMATION ON THE WEB THAT CAN
BE HARD. THAT CAN BE DIFFICULT
WE'VE REVAMPED WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF REVAMPING THE
WEBSITES OF THE SEARCH ENGINES
MAKE IT EASIER TO FIND
INFORMATION. AND RELATED
BECAUSE I CAN BE TOUGH SO THAT
SO THAT IS AN AREA THAT WE TOOK
TO HEART. BASED ON THE LA OLD
REPORT AS WELL AS THE PARENTS
FOR THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR. I
WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT I'M I'M GLAD YOU ARE
BECAUSE- RECENTLY AT A AT A AT
A CONFERENCE I WAS ASKED I
ASKED THE CHAIR. WHY WHY- I
WENT TO A WEB BUT WHEN YOUR WEB
PAGES. AND SAID LAST REVIEWED
MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
I CAPTURED. THAT ON MY PHONE.
AND THE ANSWER I GOT WAS SOME
THIS. AND I'M- BY THAT FRANKLY.
BUT MIRACULOUSLY MONDAY THAT
WAS CHANGED IN THE LINKS I WAS
ASKING FOR WERE THERE AND IT
WAS IT WAS MIRACULOUSLY
UPDATED. BUT THAT TROUBLES ME.
THAT THAT ON SOMETHING RELATED
TO WILDFIRES AND YOUR YOU HAD
NO LINKS THERE WERE NO
HYPERLINKS THERE. AND IT'D BEEN
LAST REVIEWED AND SINCE. TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN. SO THAT
MAKES ME WONDER. AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASON I WANT TO SUPPORT
SENATOR BRADFORD. HOW MANY
OTHER INSTANCES OF THESE KINDS
OF THINGS AROUND THERE THERE
WERE THERE ISN'T THE
INFORMATION. THAT THAT THAT IS
A IS AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE. YEAH
I THINK AB. YOU KNOW AFTER IS
THAT THINK IT'S A IT'S A FOR
QUESTION THAT THIS COMMITTEES
LOOKED AT IN THE PAST AS WELL
MISTER WOULD YOU KNOW IN OTHER
COMMITTEES AND SPA REALLY IN
THE BUDGET HEARINGS AS WELL IN
BOTH HOUSES AT. CENTER BRADFORD
ALLUDED TO IS THE EASE OF WHICH
TO FIND ALL THE INFORMATION
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES IT WAS.
AND ONE PAGE THAT WAS RELATED
TO ANOTHER AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
MISTER COREY SAYING THEY'RE
TRYING TO REVAMP THE- THE
WEBSITE TO HELP MAKE THAT A
LITTLE MORE MANAGEABLE
HOPEFULLY AT. ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO RAISE YEAR IN AND
YEAR OUT IN THIS COMMITTEE- I
DON'T GET BOGGED DOWN LET'S
MOVE TO CENTER BORDERS. THANK
YOU. COUPLE RANDOM QUESTIONS IF
I MAY QUICKLY. CENTER BRADFORD
DO YOU HAVE A SCIENCE
BACKGROUND- OR SOME SORT OF-
RELEVANT. EDUCATION IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS. SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
NOT IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA BUT
I WAS OF ALL THE MAJOR IN
COLLEGE TO HAVE SUMMONS SALAS
GERMAN DO YOU HAVE A SCIENCE
BACKGROUND. NOT LICENSED ALL
RIGHT- THE REASON WHY I ASK IS
WE'VE HAD A COUPLE DISCUSSIONS
TODAY ON WHAT THIS BODIES
POLICIES SHOULD. BE LIKE IF
WE'RE ASKING FOR INFORMATION.
THIS IS A HIGHLY TECHNICAL AREA
OF INQUIRY. TO ME THAT RISES TO
THE LEVEL OF HAVING THE
RESOURCES THAT- IN YOUR OFFICE
CAN BRING TO BEAR ON SOMETHING
LIKE THIS IS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE.
IN THE EARLIER EXAMPLE THE LAST
YEAR YOU REQUESTED ON A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND WE HER JUST
RECENTLY THAT YOU WERE
RESPONSIVE TO OR YOU YOU
RESPONDED TO THE REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION. THAT TO RISE TO
THE LEVEL THAT THE MAKER OF THE
INQUIRY LAST YEAR WAS NOT
SATISFIED WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT HE GOT BACK. BOTH OF THOSE
SITUATIONS ARE CLASSIC EXAMPLES
OF NGUYEN SOMETHING'S HYPER
TECHNICAL RESOURCE DRIVEN AND
OUR EFFORTS HAVE BEEN MADE IN
THE PAST TO WARRANT AN AUDIT.
THIS IS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE OF
WHERE IN AUDIT IS MOST
APPROPRIATE MY OPINIONS SO I'LL
CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING IT WILL
OF COURSE THE WITH THE OUTCOME-
BRINGS ABOUT BUT THIS IS REALLY
WHAT THIS BOARD IS DESIGNED. ON
THIS COMMITTEES DESIGNED TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT THANK
SENATOR I BELIEVE THE AUDITOR
ACTUALLY MENTIONED AS WELL SHE
HAS RESOURCES AND CAPACITY TO
EVEN BRING IN CONSULTANTS IF
SHE NEEDS AT EXPERTISE AS WELL
TO CONDUCT THE AUDIT. RIGHT
WITH THAT LET ME ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS THE DíAS
HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE GOT
TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR ALEX
JACKSON ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED
AUDIT TODAY LET ME BE CLEAR WHY
THOUGH WE ARE CERTAINLY NOT
OPPOSED TO TRANSPARENCY. OR
RIGOROUS PROGRAM EVALUATION WE
HAVE TO KNOW WHAT WE'RE GETTING
FOR INVESTMENT DOLLARS. BUT AS
WE HEARD THROUGHOUT THE
DISCUSSION TODAY ON THE OTHER I
REQUEST WE FEEL LIKE THERE'S
BEEN A REAL BREAKDOWN IN THE
PROCESS WHERE YOU HAVE. THE
AGENCY BEING AUDITED GETTING
OUR NOTICE A WEEK AGO. A WEEK
AGO AND AS A RESULT WE'RE LEFT
WITH THE SCOPE THAT WERE
CONCERNED IS NOT GOING TO
PRODUCE. A AN AUDIT THAT'S
GONNA MATERIALLY IMPROVE THESE
PROGRAMS MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE
IT CLEARLY DOESN'T INCLUDE A
HUGE PART OF THEIR BEES MANDATE
RELATED TO REDUCING TOXIC AND
CRITERIA MISSIONS. IF WE HAD
HAD THAT PROPER NOTICE WHICH
WAS USED BY MEMBERS ON THIS
DíAS TO. YOU KNOW HOW THEY
WERE EVALUATING OTHER REQUESTS
WE COULD HAVE PRODUCED A MORE
RELEVANT INQUIRY WE COULD GIVEN
THE AGENCY A CHANCE TO RESPOND.
EL AND WE THINK THAT WOULD BE
WARRANTED MOVING FORWARD WE
ALSO ARE CONCERNED THAT THE
NATURE OF THE INQUIRY. AS
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE.
AS YOU NOTED SENATOR BOARD YES.
TECHNICAL AND REQUIRES FOLKS
WITH EXPERTISE IN AND
TRANSPORTATION POLICY- AND WE
ARE WORRIED THAT ADDING THIS
REQUEST IN ITS CURRENT SCOPE
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME AND
RESOURCES AWAY FROM THE AGENCY.
WHO DESPERATELY NEED TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE URGENT MISSION
OF REDUCING TRANSPORTATION
POLLUTION- AT A MINIMUM WE
THINK THE- BEAR THE BURDEN OF
ESTABLISHING THERE HASN'T BEEN
RESPONSIVENESS THAT THERE'S AN
ISSUE HAS A BIT MATT. AND AS
THE FOR THAT REASON WE OPPOSE
THIS REQUEST. THANK YOU IN ALL
FAIRNESS YOU KNOW THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP YEAR AFTER YEAR. PLEASE
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
CATHERINE PHILLIPS WAS SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA INDEED THIS.
AUDT REQUESTS IS UP FOR
ESSENTIALLY THE SECOND YEAR IN
A ROW AND DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD
GROUP. LAST YEAR THIS BODY
DECIDED NOT TO GO FORWARD WITH
AN AUDIT BUT INSTEAD DID AND- A
DIRECT CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE
CHAIR AND- AND THE- BOARD. AND
IT SEEMS THAT. DESPITE THAT
WERE COMING BACK NOW WITH THIS
AUDIT REQUEST AGAIN. AND THE
EFFECT OF THIS IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO IF WE GO FORWARD WITH
THIS AUDIT REQUEST WITH LIGHT
WHICH I. I MISSED HOW LONG MISS
HOWELL SAID IT WOULD TAKE BUT
I'M- GONNA GUESS IT'S GONNA
TAKE A LOT LONGER. THAN SHE
EVEN ESTIMATES BECAUSE THE
BREADTH OF THIS AUDIT REQUEST.
IS OF FAIRLY INCREDIBLE. THIRTY
FOUR TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
THIRTY FOUR PROGRAMS YOU'RE
GONNA LOOK AT WHAT THE GHG
IMPACTS COSTS AND BENEFITS ARE
FOR EACH OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
MANY MANY OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
HAVE NOTHING TO WERE NOT
INTENDED TO INITIALLY ADDRESS
GHGS THEIR ATTENDED TO PROVIDE.
PUBLIC YOU KNOW TO GO AFTER
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS. TO THAT
IMPACT PUBLIC HEALTH. SO
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE GHG
BENEFITS IT'S A CO BENEFIT IS
GOING TO BE PRETTY TECHNICALLY
DIFFICULT- FOR AN AUDIT BUREAU.
UNLESS YOU'RE BRINGING IN
ENGINEERS AND AS AS WAS ALLUDED
TO BY OF THE PREVIOUS TESTIFY
ARE. BRINGING IN PEOPLE WHO
ARE- VERY SKILLED AT- PUBLIC
POLICY AT THE TRANSPORTATION
POLICY. BUT I'D LIKE TO NOTE
SOMETHING ELSE. RIGHT NOW. THIS
IS MINUTES THIS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. IS SPENDING AN
AWFUL LOT OF TIME. IN OF IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY TE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY AND THE AND CERTAIN
AUTOMAKERS THEY'RE SPENDING A
LOT OF TIME GOING AFTER
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO CONTROL
AIR POLLUTION FROM VEHICLES.
AND THE WAIVER THAT ALLOWS
THIS. STATE THE CONTROL IS HERE
POLLUTION TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH IS BEING CHALLENGED. AND
MY CONCERN IS THAT ONCE MORE
WE'RE GOING TO BE PUT INTO A
LEGISLATIVE BODY WILL BE SAYING
PUBLICLY WE DON'T TRUST. WE
DON'T TRUST THE AGENCY THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR CONTROLLING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
TRANSPORTATION. I WOULD BEG YOU
TO NOT DO THIS THIS YEAR. DON'T
GIVE DONALD TRUMP ANOTHER
TALKING POINT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT YOU WILL BE DOING. AND
THIS IS NOT THE YEAR TO DO THIS
KIND OF AUDIT THE AUDIT IS FAR
TOO BROAD AND ONE MORE THING. I
WANT TO COMMENT ON THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE ABILITY TO FIND
INFORMATION I'M ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT GOES IN AND USES
CARBS WEBSITE ON A REGULAR
BASIS. WE GIVE IT IS CANCER
OVER IT IS COMPLEX IT IS
CLUMSY. AND I'M I'M HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
IMPROVE IT BUT THAT BEING SAID
IF YOU SPEND THE TIME YOU CAN
ULTIMATELY FIND THE ANSWER TO
MOST OF THE QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN
RAISED TODAY. M. MR WHAT I'D
LOOK DOCTOR WHAT I'D LOVE TO
COME IN AND TALK TO YOU ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR
DISTRICT BECAUSE I THINK I
THINK THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT WE SHARE IN COMMON IN OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT- THE ABILITY OF
YOUR DISTRICT TO GET ACCESS TO
CERTAIN KINDS OF FUNDS. THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET ME ASK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME HEARING
AND SEEING NON- I DO BELIEVE
PROBABLY MEMBERS ON THIS DíAS-
DON'T SHARE THE SAME
INTERPRETATION AND IN REGARDS
TO THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE OUT A REQUEST AT THIS
TIME MISTER BRADFORD IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I
THINK BASED ON WHAT WE'VE
HEARD. THIS AGAIN IS AUDIT
THAT'S WALL OVERDUE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY DESERVING- WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THE COMPLEX ISSUES
THAT CARP HAS DEALT WET BUT
PART OF THE PROBLEM THAT OF
PART OF THE CONFUSION IS THE
CONSTANT MOVING OF THE GOAL
POST ON. WHAT OUR GOALS ARE OR
WHAT THEIR GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
ARE TO SAY THAT THIS IS GONNA
HAND- WASHINGTON A WIN AND I.
TEND TO DISAGREE WITH THIS IF
ALL WHAT CARNOSINE IT'S TRUE.
AND THEY'RE DOING ALL THESE
FANTASTIC GROUND IN JUST A- FOR
THE- THIS AUDIT WILL SPELL THIS
OUT ANY TO HELP BUTTRESS UP
THAT WHAT YOU WERE DOING. AND
HELP PUSH BACK ON THE CRAZY
PROGRAMS THAT WERE SEEN FROM
WASHINGTON DC OR THE STOP GAP
MEASURES THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
PUT FORTH. SO AUDIT HELPS
CONTINUE THE GREAT WORK THAT
THIS AGENCY CLAIMS TO BE DOING
BUT AGAIN I WANT TO SPEAK TO
WHAT. ASSEMBLYMAN WOULD STATED
ABOUT. LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AN IMPACT TO COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT MONOLITHIC
THEY DON'T LOOK ALIKE. AT I AM
REALLY TIRED OF CARP TALKING
ABOUT LOW INCOME PEOPLE WHEN
VERY FEW OF THOSE PROGRAMS EVER
REACHED THOSE COMMUNITIES
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THE MONEY
IS BEING SPENT. AND I TOO WAS
AT A CONFERENCE AND WE HEARD
THE DIRECTOR STATE THAT. LOW
INCOME PEOPLE WANT ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. LOW INCOME
PEOPLE WANT CLEAN AIR THEY WANT
CLEAN WATER THEY WANT CLING
SOIL BUT I'VE YET TO HEAR ONE
SAY I WANTED ZERO EMISSION.
VEHICLE THEY SAID I WANT A JOB
SO IF THAT IS WHAT THOSE PEOPLE
WERE SEEING WERE IS THE DATA
FROM THOSE SURVEYS THAT SAY
THIS IS WHAT LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WANT BECAUSE I'VE YET TO HEAR.
NOT ONE LOW INCOME PERSONS AB
ONE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE. I'VE
HEARD LOW INCOME FOLKS IN THE
REASON I DRIVE MY TWENTY YEAR
OLD FORD EXPLORERS BECAUSE I
CAN'T FIT MY FAMILY A SIX IN
THERE AND I CAN'T AFFORD TO US
ALL. AND THEY WON'T FIT INTO A
PRIUS. SO CONTINUE TO USE POOR
PEOPLE AS WHY WE DO A LOT OF
THESE PROGRAMS BUT AGAIN THEY
DO NOT DIRECTLY SEE THE
BENEFITS OF THESE PROGRAMS. I
THINK THE AUDIT WILL X. EXPOSED
ALL OF THAT. AND I THINK THIS
AUDIT ONLY FURTHERS. JUSTIFIES
THE WORK THE CARBS DOING BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE WORK THAT
IS LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN DOING I
THINK IT'S A COMMONSENSE
MEASURE I THINK IT'S LONG
OVERDUE BECAUSE AGAIN AT. THE
INFORMATION THE CARPETS. I HAVE
PUT PUTS OUT BE IT ON THEIR
WEBSITE IS PEACE MILLET BASS IS
SCATTERED IT'S NOT
COMPREHENSIVE. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE STATED YOU ALMOST
HAVE TO BE A SCIENTIST TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WHICH YOU DO
MAKE AVAILABLE SO. THE
ARROGANCE OF THIS AGENCY TO ME
IT IS JUST SAYING NO IS LONG
OVERDUE I AM NOT THE FIRST
MEMBER TO ASK FOR THIS AUDIT I
WON'T BE THE LAST. AND I THINK
IT'S TIMES COMES OUT RESPECT
LAST RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD- BUT LET ME JUST MAKE
A COUPLE COMMENTS BEFORE WE
MAKE THE MOTION- FIRST THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS AUDIT
OBVIOUSLY WE- WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND THESE
ARE NOT ISSUES THAT ARE DUE TO
THE LEGISLATURE EVEN TO THIS
COMMITTEE- WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT AN AGENCY THAT'S BEEN AROUND
EVELYN BEST COURSE IT FOR FIFTY
PLUS YEARS. HAS NEVER HAD A
COMPREHENSIVE AUDIT OF THE TWO
POINT TWO BILLION PLUS DOLLARS
THAT. HAVE BEEN SPENT I DO
APPRECIATE THAT IN YOUR LETTER
YOU DO TALK ABOUT BUILDING OFF
OF WHAT THE LA JOH. RELEASED IN
AND THEIR REPORT AND THEN
LOOKING AT THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
THOSE HEAVILY BURDENED
COMMUNITIES WHEREVER THEY EXIST
WHETHER THEY EXIST UP. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT- WE HOPE THE OUTER
CAN SHED SOME LIGHT ON IN TERMS
OF. HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD-
COST EFFECTIVELY BUT WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE EVEN WORKING AT
CARVE THAT WE CAN. PERHAPS A
REPLICATED OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE OF THE ART. HAVING THE
TARGETED RESULTS THAT WERE
LOOKING FOR SO WITH THAT I'LL
ASK FOR A MOTION ON CENTER
BRADFORD'S- AUDIT. SECOND MOVE
BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO SECOND
BY MISTER WOOD. MISTER SECTOR
KALRA. THE MOTION ANSWER
APPROVAL. QUOI TWENTY TWENTY
DASH ONE FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION PROGRAMS. BY
CENTER BRADFORD. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SALAS. SALAS HI BOERNER HORVATH
NO. BOERNER HORVATH. NO CHEN.
PATTERSON RUBIO RUBIO I VOEPEL
NOT VOTING VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
WHAT WHAT I. CENTER ROTH. MORE
JUST FOR JUST AYE GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG MORNING. MORE LOCKED.
MORE LOCK HI WIENER. OKAY THAT
ITEMS ON COMMERCE REDFORD THANK
YOU AS CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
THIS TIME I LET'S CALL IT A
CALL OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
THIS IS ON FILE ITEM. NUMBER
ELEVEN TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE
OH FOUR CALIBRATE COLLEGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NEED SOMEONE
EVER MEDINA WHEN YOU'RE READY
TO BEGIN PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AND FOR THIS MEETING. I
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- QUIRK SILVA
AND SENATOR WIENER SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THIS COMMITTEE APPROVED AN
AUDIT THE CALIFORNIA ONLINE
COLLEGE WHICH IS ALSO KNOWN AS
CAL BRIGHT COLLEGE. CALIBRATE
COLLEGE WAS DEVELOPED AND
IMPLEMENTED UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION. THROUGHOUT ITS
DEVELOPMENT MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
VOICE SEVERAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THE STRUCTURE AND PROGRAMMING.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I HOPE THAT
THIS AUDIT REQUESTS CAN
ACCOMPLISH SEVERAL THINGS.
FIRST WE WOULD LIKE THE ADDED
TO REVIEW THE CURRENT STATUS OF
CAB RIDES COLLEGE EFFORTS TO
MEET ITS GOAL OF PROVIDING
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. FOR WORKING
ADULTS WHO LACK EASY ACCESS FOR
TRADITIONAL FORMS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. SECOND WE WOULD LIKE
THE IDEA TO REVIEW THE STATUS
OF KEY MILESTONES SUCH
ACCREDITATION. AS WELL AS
EXPENDITURES OF APPROPRIATED
FUNDS TO ENSURE THE COB RIGHT
COLLEGES PROGRESSIVELY
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
MEETING ITS GOAL. FINALLY WOULD
LIKE THE AUDITOR TO REVIEW THE
REVISED APPROACH BEING PROPOSED
BY THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AS IT RELATES FIRST TO
THE ACCREDITATION PATH. SECOND
TO COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THIRD DEFICIENCY
OF INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF SCALINGUP ADULTS
TOO MANY IMMEDIATELY ENTER THE
WORKFORCE. AS THE CHAIR OF
HIGHER EDUCATION AND A FORMER
EDUCATOR I AM COMMITTED TO
ENSURING ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. HOWEVER WE MUST
ENSURE THAT STATE INSTITUTIONS
AND PROGRAMS CREATED TO PROMOTE
ACCESS ARE IN FACT ACHIEVING
THESE GOALS. THIS IS DONE IN A
COLLABORATIVE WAY AND THE
STUDENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL. WE
HOPE THAT THE STATE AUDITOR
FINDS THAT THE STAFF WAS SPENT
OF THE CUP RIGHT COLLEGE IS
PROCEEDING IN AN EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT MANNER. IF CHANGES
ARE NEEDED WE BELIEVE THAT IS
BEST TO IDENTIFY. THESE CHANGES
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS JIM MAILER
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNCIL AND
CARLOS TURNER CORTEZ PRESIDENT
OF SAN DIEGO CONTINUING
EDUCATION. THANK THANKFUL FOR
THEM JOINING ME AND THEY WILL
BE ON HAND TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS GREAT THANK
YOU YOU HAVE TESTIMONY AS WELL
OKAY IF YOU HAVE LIMITED TO TWO
MINUTES SIR. I'M JIM MILLER
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COUNCIL OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS HOPEFULLY THIS AUDIT
REQUESTS WILL BE LESS
CONTENTIOUS AND SOME OF THE
PREVIOUS ONES- I THINK IT'S
VERY TIMELY THAT WE ARE HAVING
THIS SITE REQUEST IN THAT AND I
HOPEFULLY THAT THE COMMITTEE
WILL. VOTE TO PERFORM THE
AUDIT- IT COULD BE MORE OF A
BETTER SPEND THAT AUDIT I THINK
IN TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE FEEL TAXPAYERS ARE
CURRENTLY- ON THE HOOK FOR AND
I THINK THE STATE IS MISS
SPENDING QUITE FRANKLY- WITH
RESPECT TO FUNDING CALIBRATE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE FUNDING. PER
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENT
FOR CAL BRIGHT AND THIS IS NOT
AN EXAGGERATION I TEACH MATH
SAN DIEGO CITY COLLEGE WHEN I'M
NOT DOING THIS JOB- THEY'RE
BEING FUNDED AT A RATE OF ONE
THOUSAND TIMES WHAT THE RIVER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
GETTING FOR. OUR TRADITIONAL
COLLEGE AND A SITTING THE BACK
OF THE ROOM LOOK AT THE OTHER
OUT OF YOUR I JUST DID QUICK
OUT THE AMOUNT WERE FUNDING FOR
CALIBRATED AN ON GOING BASIS
EACH YEAR WHAT FUND THREE TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF ALL OF THE ODD
IT'S BEEN REQUESTED TODAY'S
DOCKET SO YOU COULD FIND FORTY
EIGHT AUDIT REQUESTS THAT THE
AMOUNT OF. FUNDING WE'RE
FIGHTING. FOR THIRTY EIGHT.
COSTS COULD STUDENTS. IN
CALGARY NOW SO. IT'S QUITE
BOGGLING IN THE AMOUNT EVERY.
IT'S BEING SPENT THE SERVER SO
FEW STUDENTS- DUPLICATION IS
ANOTHER BIG ISSUE THERE ARE
THREE PROGRAMS BEING OFFERED
AND CAL BRIGHT ALL THREE OF
THOSE PROGRAMS WE CURRENTLY
OFFER IN FIFTY ONE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- SO THERE'S-
THERE'S NOT REALLY A NEED TO.
REPLICATE THOSE DESPITE CAL
BRIGHTS CLAIMS THAT THEY'RE NOT
BE A DUPLICATE OF. THEIR EXTRA
EXTREMELY DUPLICATIVE WHAT WERE
ALREADY OFFERING. ANOTHER MAJOR
ISSUE THAT I HOPE THE IF THE
AUDITOR WILL FOCUS ON IS THE
ACCREDITATION STATUS. ALL
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN COLLEGES
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
ARE ACCREDITED BY ONE AGENCY.
THE ACC J. C. AND THAT PROVIDE
THOSE STUDENTS TO TAKE COLLEGE
COURSES TO. TRANSFER GET
FINANCIAL AID IT CETERA
CALIBRATE IS NOT ACCREDITED NOT
ONLY THAT THEY'RE SEEKING
ACCREDITATION. FROM AN OUTSIDE
ENTITY THAT'S NOT A TO SEE JC-
BECAUSE IT'S BASICALLY A LOWER
BAR TO PASS BUT IT'S NOT GOING
TO HELP OUR STUDENTS. IF THEY
ARE SUCCESSFUL AT THAT
ACCREDITATION. LASTLY ON THAT
POINT IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL DISTANCE EDUCATION.
THERE HAS TO BE REGULAR AND
SUBSTANTIVE CONTACT BETWEEN
STUDENT AND TEACHER THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING AT CAL BRIGHT THE
STUDENTS ARE. DOING NOW PRETTY
MUCH OFF THE SHELF COURSES
LEARN AS YOU GO KIND OF THINGS.
AND YOUR GIVE ME THE I. LIKE
I'M OUT OF TIME YOU ARE. I
THANK GOD AND I LEADERS QUITE
THAT WAS HIS BABY ARISE. FROM
THAT COMMENT AS WELL THANK YOU
ESTATE. IF YOU MAY BEGIN WITH
YOUR PRESENT. RIGHT GIVEN
ADDITIONAL PERSON TO GET LEASE
WE CAN. CARLIST COURT TO PRESS
SAN DIEGO CONTINUING A- OF AN
EDUCATOR FOR TWENTY YEARS A CEO
FOR OVER TEN YEARS. I'VE BEEN
AT THE HELM OF SAN DIEGO
CONTINUING EDUCATION A LARGEST
ADULT NOT CREDIT ORGANIZATION.
IN THE STATE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN I WAS APPOINTED TO THE
FLOW COMMITTEE. AT THAT TIME I
DISCLOSE THAT CYNICAL
CONTINUING EDUCATION HAD BEEN
IN THE PROCESS FOR THE PAST
FIVE YEARS OF DEVELOPING A
FULLY ONLINE EDUCATIONAL.
INSTITUTION THAT WOULD HAVE MET
THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST I SHOULD
STATE THAT I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE.
OF FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN'S
REQUEST TO EXPAND DISTANCE
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES JUST
NOT HOW IT WAS OPERATIONALIZED
BY OUR SYSTEMS LEADERSHIP- I
WAS ON THE FLOW COMMITTEE I
BROUGHT FOR THE ONLY PROPOSAL
TO CREATE A FULLY ONLINE
ORGANIZATION. AND THAT PROPOSAL
WAS NOT ACKNOWLEDGED NOT AT
THAT TIME I DID SHARE THAT WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF LAUNCHING
A WE WILL LAUNCH THIS SUMMER.
THE INTERACTIVE COMPETENCY
BASED ONLINE MICHAEL
CREDENTIALING A CAT ACADEMY- IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY WHICH
WILL PROVIDE. FULLY ONLINE
DISTANCE EDUCATION ADULT
EDUCATION CERTIFICATES. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE DUPLICATIVE OF
PROGRAMS OF THE CURRENT
PROGRAMS OFFERED BY CULPRIT ARE
DUPLICATIVE OF THOSE IN PLACE.
ON THERE ALSO CHARGING THAT THE
NEED FOR CAL BRIGHT IS A NEW
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION
WHICH WE ALREADY DO WOULD NOT
CREDIT EDUCATION. THE KEY
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN OUR
APPROACH AND THE CALIBER TO
APPROACH FIRST IS THE ROLE OF
FACULTY FACULTY ARE INVOLVED
FROM THE OUTSET AND DEVELOPING
THE CURRICULUM. AND DESIGNING
THE PROGRAM AS THEY SHOULD BE.
SECOND IS THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN FACULTY AND STUDENT
THERE WAS REQUIRED SICKNESS
FACE TO FACE INSTRUCTION WHICH
DOES NOT OCCUR IN THE
COUNTERPART ORGANIZATION. AS
WELL AS THE REQUIREMENT PER
STUDENT THIS. TO COLLABORATION
REQUIRE COLLAB WORK IN STUDENTS
TO ME ALL. OF TIME WEEK TO FACE
AS WELL MOST IMPORTANTLY I
SHOULD STATE. THAT THE COST OF
LAUNCHING I COME ACADEMY IS
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
LESS THAN 1% AND I REITERATE.
THAN 1% OF THE INVESTMENT PUT
IN CALPERS. WE COULD DO A LOT
MORE TO. COME TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS. PORT THE EXPANSION IT
IS THAT YOU CATION BY REINVEST
THAT FUNDING IN EXISTING
DISTRICTS THAT ARE. AIMING TO
EXPAND DISTANCE EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THEIR
STUDENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
ALSO OVER THE STATE OUT OF
PRESIDENT PLEASE YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR VERY QUICKLY. AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. INTO LOOKING AT
CAP RIGHT. FIRST OF GIVE IS
ASKING A TO I BY. STUDENTS IN.
IN THE OFFER AND VARIOUS PER.
THAT ARE OF THROUGH CAL BREAK
ASKING US FOR SOME DEMO. AND
REAL ARE RELATED TO ETHNIC
DIVERSITY AGE INCOME THEIR
REASONS FOR ENROLLING DID THEY
HAVE OTHER OPTIONS OR WAS THIS
THEIR BEST OPTION. ALSO WHETHER
OR NOT THE STUDENTS ARE
ACTUALLY PROGRESSING AND IN THE
VARIOUS COURSES AND PROGRAMS.
WITH RESPECT TO THERE ARE
CERTAIN KEY MILESTONES AND THE
ACT IT'S CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
ONLINE COMMUTER COLLEGE ACT. ON
AND HE'S ASKING US TO EVALUATE
THEIR EFFORTS IN ACHIEVING
THOSE KEY MILESTONES THAT FIRST
ONE IS ACCREDITATION. ON THE
SECOND ONE IS RELATED TO
FACILITATING INTERNSHIPS AND
JOB PLACEMENTS WORKING WITH
EMPLOYERS AND INDUSTRY GROUPS.
TO GET THE STUDENTS
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE IN AN
INTERNSHIP WHICH HOPEFULLY
TRANSLATES INTO A JOB. ALSO ARE
THEY ARE PREPARING TO RECEIVE
AND EDUCATE STUDENTS WHO ARE
THEY RECRUITING FACULTY. ARE
AND QUALIFIED FACULTY TO SERVE
THE STUDENTS- THE OTHER.
OBJECTIVES ARE RELATED TO
OUTREACH- WHAT EFFORTS HAVE
THEY- ARE ENGAGED IN TO REACH
OUT TO THE TYPES OF STUDENTS
THAT THIS. TYPE OF ONLINE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WAS INTENDED
TO SERVE ARE THEY MEETING THEIR
ENROLLMENT GOALS- ALSO- WITH
RESPECT TO DUPLICATION. HE'S
ASKED US TO LOOK AT THEIR
PROGRAMS AND COURSES AND
COMPARE THOSE TO A SELECTION OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ONLINE.
PROGRAMS AND DETERMINE THERE
ARE NOT THEY ARE IN FACT CLICK
IF. AND THE FINAL CUT OF. CAR
YOU CAN SHOW THAT. ALBRIGHT
COLLEGE IS COMPLY WITH LAWS IN
RAGS WITH RESPECT EMPLOYMENT
PER TO THE TIP THINGS AS A AND
THAT'S UP AND THEN THE
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
HOW THEY'RE USING THEIR
RESOURCES- AND COMPARING THAT
THE ONLINE PROGRAMS THAT
CALIBRATE HAS TWO OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN FINALLY
LOOKING AT A SAMPLE OR
SELECTION OF SOME EXPENDITURES
FOR REASONABLE NESS AND
APPROPRIATENESS THE USE OF
THOSE FUNDS- THE BUDGET TO
START IT'S ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED HOURS AGAIN THAT'S
ABOUT A SEVEN MONTH THOUGHT IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME OF GOING TO
MOVE TO THE AFFECTED AGENCIES.
THE. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIRMAN
SALAS INVASIVE AT CHRISTMAS
ROTH IS IN HERE MET UP MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- LEASE THAT
STATE YOUR NAME I AM ALSO FOR
THAT'S MY NEXT LINE THANK. I'M
TIME IT'S NINE PRESENT BOARD
CHEST OF A CABARET CABA. AND
THIS IS. SORRY THEIR CHOICE SIR
CHIEF FINANCIAL BOB OF CAP
BROUGHT AND GET OKAY. BUT WE
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS REQUEST FOR NOT OF
CAL AND EXPLAIN THE PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE SO FAR. WE SHARE THE
DESIRE OF ASSEMBLYMAN MEMBER
MEDINA TO ENSURE THE CAB RIGHT
IS OPERATING IN AN EFFECTIVE
AND TRANSPARENT MANNER WE
WELCOME YOUR SUGGESTIONS ABOUT
HOW WE CAN BETTER ACHIEVE OUR
MISSION OR IMPROVE OUR METHODS.
RESPECTFULLY THOUGH WE FEEL AN
AUDIT IS PREMATURE AND ITS
SCOPE COVERS MANY AREAS WHICH
CALIBRATED STILL DEVELOPING AND
TESTING AS A RESULT WE GOT
WE'RE CRESCENT OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATORS TO ASK FOR THE
AUDIT. TO MODIFY ITS TIMING AND
SCOPE. WE'RE STILL IN THE VERY
EARLY STAGES OF LAUNCHING THIS
COLLEGE CABARET WAS ANNOUNCED
TO THE PUBLIC ONLY LAST MAN
BEGAN ACCEPTING APPLICANTS FOR
ADMISSION IN OCTOBER. WE HAVE
ONLY FOR ME FORTY PERMANENT
EMPLOYEES AND OF SPENT A SMALL
FRACTION OF OUR INITIAL
ALLOCATION. WE ARE PLEASED THAT
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
AND HAVE ENROLLED AND LET ME
JUST- RESPOND TO ONE OF THE
COMMENTS EARLIER THE NOTION
THAT WE'RE SPENDING A THOUSAND
TIMES MORE PER STUDENT IS
REALLY NOT CREDIBLE GIVEN. THE
EARLY STAGES THAT WE ARE IN IN
THE FACT THAT WITH THE- THIS IS
JUST A PILOT OF AN INITIAL.
COHORT OF STUDENTS THAT WE'RE
JUST LEARNING FROM. A THIS
PILOT GROUP WILL HELP US
IMPROVE OUR CURRICULUM SUPPORT
SERVICES AND TECHNOLOGY BEFORE
WE EXPAND MORE BROADLY THIS
SUMMER. WE BELIEVE IT WOULD BE
FAR MORE FRUITFUL. TO AUDIT
CALIBRATE AFTER THE START UP
PHASE HAS BEEN COMPLETED AND
THE RESULTS CAN BE EVALUATED.
TODAY WE MET ALL THE MILESTONES
REQUIREMENTS LAID OUT FOR THE
COLLEGE IN THE AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION. WE ARE CRIER TO
BEGIN ENROLLING STUDENTS BY THE
END OF Q. FOUR LAST YEAR AND
ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL THREE
MONTHS EARLY. WE ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE THREE PROGRAM PATHWAYS
IN PLACE WITHIN TWO YEARS OF
OPENING OUR DOORS. BUT WE'RE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT. AT OUR
LAUNCH A FEW MONTHS AGO. WE
ALSO HAD A CLEAN EXTERNAL AUDIT.
LAST WE'RE WORKING DILIGENTLY
WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE STATE
ACADEMIC SENATE TO QUICKLY HIRE
FACULTY POSITIONS AND PLAN TO
FINALIZE THE TIRES IN THE
COMING MNTHS THE ACADEMIC
SENATE'S LEADERSHIP HAS
TESTIFIED PUBLICLY THAT THEY
ARE PLEASED WITH OUR CURRENT
PROGRESS. NOT WITHSTANDING
THOSE SUCCESSES WE RECOGNIZE
THERE WERE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INITIAL LEADERSHIP TEAM AND CAL
RIGHT. I'M PLEASED TO SHARE
WITH YOU TODAY THE CALVERTS NEW
INTERIM CEO A G. TO TELL WALKER
MEN AND STARTS TODAY. MS MEN
AND LED THE ADVANCE TEAM THAT
IMPLEMENTED THE LEGISLATION
CREATING CALIBRATE AND HAS A
DEEP COMMITMENT TO THE MISSION
OF THE INSTITUTION. SHE SERVED
AS A KEY HIGHER EDUCATION
ADVISER IN THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE AND THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS WELL AS ROLESIN
CONGRESS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELP
STUDENTS. AS INTERIM CEO SHE'S
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE CONTINUE
BUILDING CALIBRATE FROM THE
GROUND UP. SHE UNDERSTANDS THE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED ABOUT
HOW BRIGHT AND WILL DEFINITELY
TAKE THOSE CONCERNS TO HEART.
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO GIVE SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION TO I REQUEST THAT
THIS AUDIT BE DELAYED. IF IT IS
WE PROMISE TO WORK HAND IN HAND
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
INTERESTED MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. TO PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION THAT IS NECESSARY
FOR YOUR GUIDANCE AND OVERSIGHT
OF COUNT RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. KAYLA THIS TIME WAS
GONNA MOVE TO QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM- MEMBERS OF THE DíAS MR
DATA IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT.
YOU'D LIKE TO PROCEED WITH THIS
AUDIT REQUEST CONTINGENT ON TWO
FACTORS ONE IS A CONTINGENT
THAT THERE'S FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET FOR CALIBRATED WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND AS
SUCH A DELAYING THE AUDITOR
LOOKING AT THIS REQUEST UNTIL
AFTER JULY FIRST SO THAT WE
KNOW WHAT THE BUDGET ACTION IS
AN- AND- THIS. THIS HOUSE I
WOULD I WOULD SAY THAT THAT.
BRING IN THIS AUDIT FORWARD WAS
TO MAKE BEST USE OF THE STATE'S
OF LIMITED RESOURCES. HAVE
SALAH I AM VERY AWARE OF THE
HEARING THAT THE SENATE HAD-
JUST- LAST WEEK CORRECT- AND
THE- QUESTIONS OR- THE- TO ME
A- WATCHING IT YOU KNOW THE
LACK. OF CAL RIGHT ACTUALLY-
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION BUT I DO REALIZE
THAT THAT THEIR- BEEN IN
OPERATION FOR PERHAPS A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME. I THINK IT IS
IN THE INTEREST OF THE
LEGISLATURE- THEREFORE TO VERY
NOT VERY MUCH NO- HOW THEY'RE
DOING BUT I WOULD NOT BE
OPPOSED TO- DELAYING- THE
AUDIT. IN IN THE SEQUENCE OF
THE OF THE AUDITS AS YOU
SUGGEST THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER- MEDINA APPRECIATE THAT
OKAY HEARING NO QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
HEARING AND SEEING ON LET'S GO
TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. I'M
SORRY WAS OUR QUESTION. BUT
ALSO TO PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS AUDIT
WE'VE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE DUPLICATION OF PROGRAMS AND
ALSO THE USE OF THE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING. I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD
THAT THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INDEPENDENCE CAN BE
HERE TODAY BUT THEY ASKED ME TO
SHARE THEIR ALSO PART BECAUSE
ON TO THIS THANK YOU. DOES YOUR
MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS REQUEST AND- WITH THE PORT
WHAT CODES COMMITTEE AND THE
AND ALONG WITH THE MEMBER.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
HEARING AND SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC I'LL RETURN
IT BACK TO THE DíAS- DO I HAVE
A MOTION TO APPROVE SOME OF
EVER MEDINA IS I REQUEST WITH
THE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL JULY ONE CONTINGENT ON
THE FACT THAT IT'S CONTINUE TO
BE FUNDED IN THE STATE BUDGET.
SO WILL BY ASSEMBLY WILL
BOERNER HORVATH TO HAVE A
SECOND SEC BY MISTER VOEPEL
PROJECT CALDERON. DR A
CONTINGENT ON. THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE ATER QUEST TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE OH FOUR
CALIBRATE COLLEGE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA- WITH THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE THE AUTO REQUEST
BUT DELAYED UNTIL JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY CONTUSION UPON-
BUDGET FUND FURTHER FINDING OUT
THE BUDGET WORK OUT RIGHT
COLLEGE AS A MEMBER SALAS AYE
SALAS AYE BOERNER HORVATH I
BOERNER HORVATH HI GEN.
PATTERSON RUBIO RUBIO AYE
VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD. CENTER
RAFI. GORGEOUS GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERGMORNING. MORE LOCKED.
WIENER. THAT MOTIONS ON CALL
THANK YOU MISTER DATA THANK YOU
RIGHT AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER%
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE
OH NINE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM FUNDING BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BOERNER HORVATH
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WHEN YOU ARE
READY TO BEGIN PLEASE BEGIN.
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO BE IN
SETTLEMENT WHERE WHERE FOR THE
WITNESSES. PLEASE. BUT. OKAY.
SO I'M GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
APPROVE A STATE AUDIT TO
EXAMINE EXPENDITURE OF STATE
FUNDS ALLOCATED TO COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES I HSS PROGRAM WE ALL
KNOW OUR STATE ALLOCATES FUNDS-
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT AYE HSS
THAT ARE COMBINED WITH LOCAL
COUNTY DOLLARS AS WELL AS
FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS TO
PROVIDE IN HOME DOMESTIC AND
RELATED SERVICES SUCH AS
HOUSEWORK TRANSPORTATION AND
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES TO
ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME AGED BLIND
AND DISABLED PERSONS. THE GOAL
OF THE PROGRAM IS TO PROGRAMS
TO HELP INDIVIDUALS MEET REMAIN
IN THEIR HOME AND PREVENT MORE
COSTLY INSTITUTIONALIZATION
HOWEVER IT IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THERE'S A SORT SHORTAGE OF
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WITH THE PROBLEM BEING MORE
CUTE CONCERNED COUNTIES SOME
HAVE ATTRIBUTED THE PROBLEM TO
THE LESS COMPETITIVE WAGE BEING
OFFERED AND THE LACK OF
BENEFITS OF A JUMBO PROVIDERS.
THE OTHERS APPOINT A- TO THE-
IN LENGTH OF TIME IT TAKES FOR
TO BE APPROVED. AT HSS PROVIDE
AS I AGES AS PER. WITH AN
AVERAGE WE TIME OF SIX FOR
PROVIDER TO RECEIVE THEIR FIRST
TIME SHE'D LET ALONE THE FIRST
PAYCHECK. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU BUT I COULDN'T DEAL WITH
THAT. THE SHORTAGE IS ONLY
GOING TO GROW WORSE AND WITH
THE COMING SUMMER TSUNAMI THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ESTIMATES
THAT OVER. THE NEXT FORTY YEARS
OUR STATE SIXTY FIVE OF THOSE
OVER SIXTY FIVE YEARS AND OLDER
FOR INCREASED FROM FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION TO THIRTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION. BY TWENTY SIXTY.
WITH THAT IN MIND I AM
REQUESTING THE APPROVAL OF THE
STATE ORDER TO LOOK AT WHETHER
COUNTIES ARE MAXIMIZING THESE
FUNDS TO ENSURE. THE MOST
ROBUST SUPPLY. OF IHS WORKER I
EACH AS AS WORKERS POSSIBLE
INCLUDING PROVIDING WAGES THAT
PREVENT ATTRITION WERE
POSSIBLE. SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE
TO REQUEST THE STATE ORDER OF
VALUE AND SELECTION OF FOR
COUNTIES. OF VARYING
POPULATIONS REGION'S URBAN
RURAL MAX AND PROVIDER
CONTRACTS STATUS IN THEIR
ADMINISTRATION OF I. H. S. S.
FUNDING WITH THE FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS IN MIND. OUR COUNTY
IS FULLY EXPANDING THEIR HSS
DOLLARS OR FUNDS BEING LEFT ON
SPENT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. WHAT
PERCENT OF THE FUNDS ARE BEING
ALLOCATED DIRECTLY TO PROVIDER
WAGES AND BENEFITS. HOW ARE AYE
HSS FUNDS STATE FEDERAL COUNTY.
ACCOUNTED FOR AND TRACKED IN
THE COUNTY BUDGETING PROCESS.
OUR AYE AGES AS FUNDS BEING
USED FOR ANYTHING OTHER THAN I
AGENTS AS PROVIDER WAGES AND
DIRECT ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR
THE PROGRAM. THE COUNTY LEVEL
IF SO WHERE THOSE FOLKS GOING
TOWARD THEM WHY. ARE THE NUMBER
OF I. PROVIDERS INCREASING OR
DE. WITHIN THE COUNTY AT WHAT
RATE. WHAT IS THE SHORTAGE FOR
EACH COUNTY IN TERMS OF HSS
PROVIDER PROVIDER HOURS NEED TO
MEET EXISTING DEMANDS. WHAT IS
THE AVERAGE MINIMUM WAGE FOR
EACH COUNTY AND HOW DOES IT
COMPARED TO THE I. H. AS AS
PROVIDER RATE FOR THAT COUNTY
AND HOW DOES IT COMPARE THE
COST OF LIVING. WITHIN THAT
COUNTY. WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES
WITH THING IHS PROVIDER WAGES
IN EACH COUNTY WHAT IS THE%
ESTIMATED COSTS FOR RECRUITING
AND TRAINING NEW PROVIDERS.
WHAT IS ESTIMATED IMPACT IN
EACH COUNTY OF LOW WAGE
BENEFITS ON ABILITY OF IHS
CONSUMERS. TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN I JUST PROVIDERS WITH A
SPECIAL EMPHASIS ON CONSUMERS
WITHOUT FAMILY SUPPORT THAT'S A
VERY BIG ISSUE. WHAT IF
ANYTHING A ONE OF ANY HAS BEEN
THE IMPACT OF THE TIMELINE FOR
NEW PROVIDERS TO BECOME
ENROLLED. IN AYE AGE INTO AYE
HSS RECEIVE THEIR FIRST TIME
SHEET. WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT
OUR CRISTINA BASS HAMILTON
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND MARKETS
RUBIO A U. D. W. MEMBER. AND I
HSS PROVIDER FROM BAKERSFIELD.
WHO HAS TO PEOPLE SHE CARES FOR
UNDER THIS PROGRAM SO TURN OVER
CRISTINA I THINK WE'VE HAD A
LONG HEARING SO MAYBE KEEP ALL
COMMENTS TWO MINUTES OF A-
OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU FORGET
MAKE IT CONCISE TO STATE YOUR
NAME FOR THE RECORD PLEASE. A
SOMEONE YES GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERY. I'M LIKE A YOU MY NAME
IS MARK THE YOUR- I. NOT A- HM
IT'S AS PROVIDE IN BAKER. MANY
MANY WISH AS- ARE FORMALLY
GIVERS BUT I AM CARE FOR MEMBER
INDICUM WHO HAS NOT ONE HOURS
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM. THIS IS
ONE OF MICHAEL HIS NAME IS. MR
J. BROWN. WE ARE CRITICAL PART
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES WE
MAKE IT'S POSSIBLE FOR SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WHO DISOBEYED IT IS
TO. LEAVE OUR HOME EVERYONE THE
SERVICE THE RICE TO LEAVE OUR
HOME BUT THERE IS NOT ENOUGH OF
OUT BECAUSE THERE. PAY IS SO
LOW. LAST YEAR IN MY COUNTY.
THEY WERE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND I H. SS HOURS
THEY WORK I KNOW ME. ALMOST
HALF A MILLION HOURS OF CARE
THAT PEOPLE NEEDS. THAT THEY'D
NEVER CAUGHT WHAT HAPPENED. TO
ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T GET
THEIR DAILY NEEDS MET. MADE
SOME OF THEM WHEN INTO A
NURSING HOMES AGAIN THERE WILL
AND THEY'RE GREAT EXPENSE SO TO
TAXPAYERS SOME MAY BE BECAME
HOMELESS ARE PASSED AWAY. I'VE
AS YOU ALL I'M SO THE SENIORS
PURPLE AND THEY SAID GNARLY. BY
TWENTY THIRTY WHO WILL CARE FOR
ALL BOTH. THERE IS PLEASE
CRISIS IN WE NEED THE ADDRESS
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS RIGHT
AWAY BEFORE THE MORE PEOPLE
SUFFER OR DIE. WE NEED TO RE
CREATE AND RETAIN RETAIN A
HIGHER POVERTY CARE FOR WORSE
FORCED. THE ONLY WAY TO DO THIS
IS TO PAY I SSA. CARE GIVERS
THE NAFTA THEY WILL WANT TO DO
THAT THESE THESE WORK. PLEASE
UPLOAD APPROVED THESE OUT THERE
SO WE CAN FIND OUT WHY I H. SS
MAY REMAIN SOLO. WE NEED TO
MAKE THESE DONNA WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU I THAT I. H.
S. SAYS FARMS ARE BEGIN. WHICH
IS MY SECOND THERE WERE NO
YOU'RE FINE IT'S ALL FOR
JOINING US. I'M SO NERVOUS
THAT. THEY GET IT THEY MISTER
JAMES. LOGAN WAS WORTH LIKE A
COMMERCIAL I'M SORRY I'M LIKE
IT'S GETTING. OKAY YEAH MOVE TO
THE STATE PRESENTATION PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
INDICATED AN AUDIT OF AYE HSS-
AND LOOKING AT FOR COUNTY SHE'S
OF COURSE WILL GO LARGE SMALL
RURAL URBAN TO GET A GOOD
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
QUICKLY GO THROUGH THE
OBJECTIVES LOOKING AT THE
EXPENDITURES OF AYE HSS FUNDING
BY THE COUNTIES TO ADMINISTER
A- I HSS HOW MUCH OF THAT IS
GOING TOWARDS PROVIDER WAGES
AND BENEFITS VERSUS OTHER
EXPENSES ARE THE COUNTY
SPENDING ALL OF THE AYE HSS
FUNDING THAT THEY RECEIVE EACH
YEAR. AND AGAIN HOW MUCH OF
THAT IS GOING TOWARD PROVIDER-
WAGES VERSES ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
SUPPLY OF PROVIDERS MS
BOERNER HORVATH IS ASKING AS
IDENTIFY TRENDS SO WE'LL HAVE
TO LOOK AT A CERTAIN TIME FRAME
IN HE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS AND
RECIPIENTS WITHIN EACH OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND ASSESS WHETHER
THE COUNTY HAS A SHORTAGE OF
PROVIDERS AND TRY TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE REASONS ARE FOR THAT
PARTICULAR SHORTAGE AGAIN AS A
MEMBER INDICATED SHE WANTS US
TO LOOK AT THE AVERAGE MINIMUM
WAGE OF EACH COUNTY COMPARE
THAT TO THE AVERAGE WAGE FOR
PROVIDERS AND THEN ALSO LOOK AT
THE COST OF LIVING WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY TO TRY TO GET A- AN
OVERALL PICTURE. OF THE
SITUATION- IN EACH OF THOSE
COUNTIES ASSESS CHALLENGES TO
INCREASING WAGES WITH ANY TO
THE COUNTIES- LOOKING AT COUNTY
EFFORTS TO RECRUIT AND PROVIDE
TRAINING TO NEW INDIVIDUALS NEW
PROVIDERS AND THEN. AGAIN THE
MEMBER INDICATED TRYING TO
IDENTIFY THE CHALLENGES THAT
EXIT PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WHO
DO NOT HAVE FAMILY TO SUPPORT
THEM WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO
HIRE AND RETAIN UP. ON AND
REALLY SING ON SS ACTIVELY
CHOOSE ONE RECRUITING AND
HIRING AND LEE RETAINING
FIGHTERS AND FAST QUESTION IS
REALLY TO THE SHEETS TO HOW IT
TO NEW ON OUR TO GET A NEW TIME
SHE SO THAT THEY DO GET. FOR
THIS THAT PROVIDING THAT'S TRUE
THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT AND PASSED
ON SO IT WOULD BE A FOLLOW OF.
THEM FALL APART NOT F. THREE
YEARS AGO. BUDGET ABOUT TWENTY
SEVEN OUR- MEANS THAT PRODUCT
TO ABOUT SEVEN ON TO COMPLY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET ME MOVE TO
BACK TO THE DíAS LET ME ASK IF
THERE'S- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS ON DíAS. OKAY
HEARING AND SEEING THEM PRETTY
STRAIGHT FORWARD. LET ME ASK IF
THERE'S PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. REVIEW PLEASE BE CONCISE
WITH THE PUBLIC COMMENTS
BECAUSE WITHOUT A VERY LONG
HEARING. HI MY NAME IS YOLANDA
TOLIVER I AM I JUST PROVIDER
FOR CENTER CANTONI HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF OUR HOURS AND I IT
JUST SAYS CARE IN THE COUNTY
ARE GOING ON MATT. PLEASE
APPROVE THIS AUDIT SO WE CAN
FIND OUT HOW TO COVER THAT MEET
THANK YOU. NATIONAL PUBLIC TO
COMMENT PLEASE HI MY NAME IS
MARCEL LOWER AND I'M I JUST AS
PROVIDE FOR BIãU PLEASE
APPROVE THE SITE SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT AGES AS PROGRAM AS
HEALTHY AND VIABLE FOR THE
FUTURE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NATIONAL PUBLIC COME HI MY NAME
IS A MAJOR HERNANDEZ AND I AM
AN HSS PROVIDER FOR BUTTE
COUNTY THERE AREN'T ENOUGH CARE
GIVERS IN MY COUNTY BECAUSE
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO WORK FOR
SUCH LOW PAY. IS APPROVED AUDIT
SO WE CAN MAKE SURE ENOUGH I IT
JUST SAYS FUNDING IS GOING
DIRECTLY TO PROVIDING CARE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALEXANDER GO
DEAN S. I AM HERE WITH UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS- PLEASE
APPROVE THIS AUDIT THIS THE I
JUST AS AS A VITAL PROGRAM THAT
KEEPS PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES.
BUT IT ONLY WORKS IF THE P. IF
THE PROVIDERS ARE GETTING PAID
FAIR WAGES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
PLEASE ME NOBODY'S MONTGOMERY'S
SO THERE'S- PROVIDE OR ARE THEY
YEAH CHASEZ SAME THAT GONZALEZ
SADDAM. MITCHELL SUNLIGHT A
SINGLE. IT'S NOT OUT OF THE
DEAL MINIMAL DISASTROUS
ENQUIRING YOU THIS IS THE MOST
AS THOUGH THE INSEPARABLE THIS
QUOTED COMPONENT THAT IS
ALLOWED TO THE LAST PERSONAS
COMO. CASSETTE BRICKELL BUT
BOND AS THE MASS WHICH
ADDRESSES CLASSES BUT US IRAQI
CAN ALSO THROWS. PLEASE DIGITAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. AT SO IN
TRANSLATION FOR MARK THAT MY
NAME IS MARK THE RUSE I'M A- I
JUST AS PROVIDER AND SUTTER
COUNTY- RP HAS BEEN MINIMUM
WAGE FOR. FIVE YEARS AND WE
NEED DECIDED SO WE CAN FIGURE
HOW TO RAISE. THE PAY FOR FOLKS
LIKE ME WHO. CARE FOR OTHERS
THANK YOU. I WANT IS IAN ON THE
PROVIDE IF YOU PLEASE APPROVE
THIS AUDIT. HI JEFF THIS IS A
VITAL PROGRAM TO KEEP PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES BUT IT ONLY WORKS
IF PEOPLE ARE PAID ENOUGH TO DO
THE WORK. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NATIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT. A
DOCTOR REVEREND MINISTER CIVIL
RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS SAID
PLEASE APPROVED DECIDED JOSH
WHAT DOCTOR REFERENCE. JOSH
LOOK MUCH OF. THANK YOU. PLEASE
DOCTOR ROBIN JUMBLE CAMACHO AND
I'M HERE RIPPLES OF THIS AUDIT
PLEASE. HUMAN RIGHTS AND HUMAN
DECENCY. THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT TIFFANY RIGHT
WITH THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF THE
REQUEST THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS AMY DAY I'M WITH
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS I
SUPPORT THIS AUDIT. THERE ARE
SOBRE FOLKS IN BOTH- CENTER AND
YOU COUNTIES THAT ARE GOING ON
WITHOUT CARE BECAUSE HOME CARE
WORKERS CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE
ON THE WAGES THAT THEY ARE
RECEIVING RIGHT NOW. MINIMUM
WAGE IS NOT A LIVABLE WAGE
THESE FOLKS ARE SUFFERING AND
SO I WOULD STRONGLY SUGGEST
THAT YOU BUY SUPPORT THIS
AUDIT. THANK YOU. THERE'S NO
PUBLIC COMMENT. HELLO MY NAME
IS HANA CARBALLO I'VE BEEN IN
AYE HSS PROVIDER FOR ALMOST
FORTY YEARS I WORK FOR NON
FAMILY MEMBERS. THIS IS MY
CAREER THIS IS MY CALLING THIS
IS MY LIFE. AND I AM NOT GOING
ANYWHERE I'M HERE IN FRONT OF
YOU AS I HAVE BEEN IN FRONT OF
LEGISLATIVE BODY SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX ADVOCATING FOR
HIGHER WAGES FOR AYE HSS
WORKERS. I HAVE SEVERAL STORIES
TO TELL YOU WHEN I WILL TAKE MY
FULL TWO MINUTES THANK YOU.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO TELL YOU
ABOUT MY OWN PERSONAL HOUSING
STORY WHICH IS THAT IN THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN I
LOST MY HOUSE RIGHT RENTAL HOME
DUE TO AN OWNER MOVE IN
EVICTION I LIVE IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA RENTS ARE VERY HIGH.
MY FAMILY COULD NOT AFFORD TO
GET A NEW HOME IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE BAY AREA MY DAUGHTER
WAS GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL WENT
TO COLLEGE. SHE HAS HER COLLEGE
TUITION PAID FOR AND HER
HOUSING THANK GOODNESS SHE'S A
VERY BRIGHT GIRL AND SHE'S GOT
SCHOLARSHIP. MY PARTNER. IS NOT
WORKING BECAUSE HE WAS TO SAVE.
AND HE MOVED TO SOUTH AMERICA
BECAUSE HE COULD NOT LET HIS
IMPORTANCE WOULD NOT. A LOT
THEM TO STAY IN THE BAY AREA. I
HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE TO HAVE A
LIVING ROOM OFFERED TO ME SO
THAT I CAN REMAIN IN THE BAY
AREA AND DO THE WORK THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO ME AND MY
COMMUNITY. OKAY THE NEXT STORY
I WANT TO TELL YOU IS NOT ABOUT
ME. I'M SORRY PLEASE LET ME
INTRODUCE MYSELF AGAIN I AM A
MEMBER OF HAND IN HAND WHICHIS
PART OF THE NATIONAL DOMESTIC
WORKERS ALLIANCE IT IS THE
EMPLOYER. ARM OF THAT MOVEMENT
AND I AM AN ALLY WITH THE
ATTENDANT EMPLOYERS I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF SEIU TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND I AM ACTIVE IN MY UNION.
AND ARE VERY PROUD OF THAT. I
ALSO WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT MY
FRIEND TOM WHO WAS IN. GOT SICK
AND WENT INTO THE HOSPITAL AND
HAD TO HAVE A TRAE TAKE. HE
WAS FINALLY WELL ENOUGH TO GO
HOME AFTER FIVE MONTHS IN THE
HOSPITAL BUT HE HAD NO
ATTENDANTS HAD LOST ALL OF ITS
INDEPENDENCE. AND HE SPENT
THREE MONTHS TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER A STAFF AND FINALLY HE
WAS ABLE TO GO HOME AND THE
STAFF. ONLY LASTED A FEW MONTHS
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT MENTALLY
STABLE HIS LIVE IN ATTENDANCE
WAS NOT. STABLE ENOUGH TO
PROVIDE THE CARE THAT HE NEEDED
AND HE ENDED UP BACK IN A
FACILITY FOR SEVERAL MONTHS CAN
YOU TELL ME HOW MUCH THAT WOULD
COST. THE STATE TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WELL AND CAN REMAIN IN THEIR
OWN HOMES IS ABSOLUTELY
OUTRAGEOUS I HAVE VERY GOOD
NEWS HE IS HOME NOW HE'S BEEN
HOME FOR SEVERAL MONTHS. BUT
THAT WAS AFTER AT SECOND
INSTITUTIONALIZATION THAT WAS
CAUSED ONLY BY THE LACK OF.
QUALIFIED CARE GIVERS THANK YOU
I ALSO IF I HAVE JUST ONE MORE
MOMENT I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT
SOMEBODY ELSE WHO I KNOW WHOSE
ATTENDANTS ARE HOMELESS VERY
QUICKLY THEY'RE WORKING. SIXTY
HOURS. EVERY TWO WEEKS SHE HAS
TWO SMALL CHILDREN HER HUSBAND
ALSO WORKS AND THERE'S NO WAY
THEY COULD AFFORD A HOME IN AN
IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA.
ATTENDANTS ARE PAID FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AN HOUR WHICH IS
ALAMEDA COUNTIES WAGE BUT
MINIMUM WAGE IS FIFTEEN FIFTY
NINE SO YOU CAN BET PEOPLE ARE
GOING AND SELLING. SELLING
THINGS AND DOING OTHER JOBS SO
I AM THAT'S MY COMMENT A
FABERGE THAT IN THE WORK THAT
YOU DO. ALL RIGHT ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. I'M GONNA BE
VOICING FOR HAIL SURFACED THIS
IS HELD TO KISS HI ALL ITS BEEN
AND I IT JUST SAYS CONSUMER
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO HE
IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
ARCHITECTS OF THE PROGRAM HE IS
A GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY WITH
TWO BACHELOR'S DEGREES ONE IN
RUSSIAN ONE IN MATHEMATICS HE
HAPPENS TO HAVE BEEN A
CLASSMATE OF. A SOME
ASSEMBLYMAN OR SENATOR BIDEN
MINING YES HE WENT TO SCHOOL
WITH SENATOR MINING AND- WANTED
TO MAKE NOTE OF THAT- HAIL. HAS
RECENTLY- BEEN APPROVED FOR
FUNDING THROUGH THE- REGIONAL
CENTER TO HAVE. A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR ATTENDANT SERVICES HOWEVER
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND PEOPLE
AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING
LITERALLY NIGHT AND DAY. I PAID
TO TRY TO FIND HILL SOME HERE
HOME CARE WORKERS WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH COUNTLESS INTERVIEWS WE
HAVE TRAINED PEOPLE WHO STAY
TWO DAYS AND THEN LEAVE. IT
SAYS AND I'M- I'M TENABLE
SITUATION OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THE TRIP UP
HERE. I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAT WE NEED TO SAY
AND I'M SORRY THAT I'M NOT
FULLY PREPARED- HALE ALSO
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW THAT-
THIS IS NOT A UNIQUE SITUATION.
AND THERE'S THIS PROJECTED
SURPLUS OF JET SEVERAL BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL FUND AND
HE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME OF
THAT GO TO PAY HIGHER WAGES FOR
AYE HSS WORKERS. THANK YOU AND
THAT'S PROBABLY BETTER SUITED
FOR OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS AS
WELL WHERE THE B. ALLOCATED THE
MONEY IN THE STATE BUDGET FOR
TO AUDIT I UNDERSTAND YOUR
SUPPORT OF SOMEONE-
BOERNER HORVATH. AUDIT AS WE
LOOK AT THE AGES US IN THAT THE
RATES OF WHICH IT'S- ACTUALLY
AFFECTS DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
STATE IN THE REGION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIGHT WITH THAT LET
ME ASK IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. HEARING AND
SEEING MAN LET ME RETURN IT
BACK TO THE DYESS SOMEONE WOMAN
BOERNER HORVATH WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT THE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCISE CLOSE. I WITH THAT I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS AUDIT I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR- FOR
BRINGING THE OUT A FORWARDED
I'VE- I DO VALUE THE WORK THAT
EACH OF THESE MEMBERS- THAT
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY- DO DO AND
I ACTUALLY FOR TO THE RESULTS
OF. THE STATE AUDITOR AS WELL
WITH THAT LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
A MOTION. MOVE BY SENATOR
WIENER SECOND BY MISTER VOEPEL-
THE SECTOR CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE ATER
REQUEST NUMBER TWENTY TWENTY
DASH ONE OH NINE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM
FUNDING BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALAS AYE. SALAS HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I GEN.
PATTERSON RUBIO. VOEPEL VOEPEL
I WOULD. CENTER ROTH. GORGEOUS
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG MORNING
MOORLACH MOORLACH AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE. RIGHT YEAH MOTIONS
ON CALL AND WILL ALLOW TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO FAT I
THINK THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT AT THIS TIME- I
DO SEE SENATOR HER TITLE HERE I
DON'T SEE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER SO
PREP SO HER DAUGHTER IF YOU'D
LIKE T COMMENT WORLD THIS WILL
BE ITEM TWENTY TWENTY DASH ZERO
FOUR CITY OF LINDSAY. YES.
CENTER THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
OKAY IF YOU'D LIKE TO- OPEN
SENATOR THAT BE GREAT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I'M JUST HERE IN
SUPPORT OF TWO REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CITY OF LONDON I'LL
JUST GO AHEAD AND HAD THE MIKE
OVER TO THEM TO THE OPTION TO
SPEAK PERHAPS BEFORE WE GIVE IT
TO THAT WE CAN HAVE THE STATE
AUDITOR- GIVE A PRESENTATION ON
THE CITY OF WHIMSY CERTAINLY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN HER
AND HANDED OVER TO MR CHILDREN
BUT THIS IS ONE OF THE ARTISTS
THAT WE REQUESTED- AUTHORITY
TO. CONDUCT AFTER WE CONDUCTED
AN ASSESSMENT WE WENT OUT TO
THE CITY OF LINDSAY SPENT A
COUPLE OF WEEKS MEETING WITH
OFFICIALS LOOKING AT SOME
DOCUMENTS ARE CONDUCTED THE
ASSESSMENT. THE WAY OUR PROCESS
WORKS IS WE DO GIVE THE ENTITY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO
OUR ASSESSMENT THAT IS INCLUDED
IN THE MATERIALS THAT WE SHARED
WITH THE MEMBERS WHAT I'D LIKE
MISTER CHILDREN TO DO AND A
VERY HIGH LEVEL AND HE'S
PREPARED TO DO THAT WILL KEEP
IT HIGH LEVEL WHAT THE KEY
ISSUES WORK THAT WE IDENTIFIED
AND WHY WE STILL BELIEVE THAT
IT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL FOR.
THIS COMMITTEE TO APPROVE NOT
IT THANK YOU THANK YOU. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE RECORD MY NAME IS. STILL
NOT. PARTNER SO IS MISS HOW
INDICATED WE ANALYZE THE CITY
LYNSEY'S FINANCES WHEN WE
ISSUED OUR DASHBOARD AND WE
DETERMINED THAT THEY WERE THE
FOURTH. MOST FISCALLY
CHALLENGED CITY IN THE STATE
AND ESSENTIALLY THAT WAS
BECAUSE- THEY ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTIES IN TERMS OF THEIR
CASH POSITION AND RESERVE TO
PAY THEIR BILLS. AND THEY ALSO
HAVE INCREASING RETIREMENT
COSTS. SO WHAT'S GOING ON THERE
IS THEY'VE BASICALLY BEEN
INCURRING- REGULAR OPERATING
LOSSES AND SEVERAL OF THEIR FOR.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT THEY- IS
THAT THE GENERAL FUND HAS LOAN
SAID STANGEL AMOUNTS OF MONEY
TO OTHER FUNDS INCLUDING
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. TO
ANOTHER FUND TO BUILD AN INDOOR
SPORTS COMPLEX. BECAUSE THAT
COMPLEX DIDN'T GENERATE ENOUGH
REVENUE TO BASICALLY TO PAY THE
LOAN OFF. CITY COUNCIL FOR GAVE
THAT LOAN WHICH RESULT IN A
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL HIT THE
GENERAL FUND. BECAUSE OF THAT
AT THE OPERATING LOSSES THE
LOANS THAT WERE WRITTEN OFF.
THE CITY WHEN'S THE GENERAL HAS
A VERY SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT.
GENERAL RESERVES. I AND FROM WE
TO THE DASHBOARD THE CITY OF
LINDSEY'S. NEGATIVE FIVE.
GENERAL FUND RESERVE WAS THE
SECOND LARGEST IN. THE ENTIRE
STATE AT NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION. BECAUSE OF THE ISSUES
THIS THESE EXTERNAL HAS A-
GOING. ABOUT AND BASICALLY HAS
SAID THE CITY HAS SUBSTANTIAL
DOUBT ABOUT THE CITY'S ABILITY
TO CONTINUE AS A GOING CONCERN.
IN THE MOST RECENT AUTO REPORT
THE ORDER WENT SO FAR AS TO
CALL THE CITY FUNCTIONALLY
BANKRUPT- SO WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT- AUDIT OBJECTIVES
BUT TO KEEP IT BRIEF
ESSENTIALLY IF THE AUDIT IS
APPROVED- THAT WOULD GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO A DEEPER DIVE
AND REALLY- PUT TOGETHER A FULL
ACCOUNTING OF THE CITY'S
FINANCIAL OPERATIONAL
MANAGEMENT RISKS. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE DETAILED
AND PRACTICAL RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE CITY THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO CREATE A CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN ESSENTIALLY TO
ADDRESS THE FINDINGS. AND WE
HAVE ESTIMATED THAT THE ART IT
WOULD TAKE ABOUT ONE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED NINETY SIX HOURS
TO COMPLETE. AND THAT WOULD
EQUATE TO ROUGHLY FOUR FIVE
MONTHS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY THAT GETS US TO THE
AFFECTED CITIES A MEASURE
REPORT YOUR AND YOU HAVE ANY
MORE TO ADD TO THE REPORT NO NO
THANK YOU OKAY WELCOME CITY OF
ANTI. YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN NAME
IS PAM CAMPBELLI'M MAYOR OF
THE CITY LINDSEY AND- WELCOME
THIS OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TO
YOURSELF AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONCERN ABOUT OUR
FINANCES. AS A SMALL VERY
DISADVANTAGED. OF AG BASED
COMMUNITY WE HAVE BUILT MOSTLY
ALONE AND- DEALING WITH OUR
WITH OUR DEEP CHALLENGES. AND
THEY'VE GONE BACK FOR DECADES-
WE ARE IN THE CITRUS SPELLED WE
FACED A NUMBER OF DEVASTATING
FREEZES WE'VE HAD BUSINESSES
CLOSE AND LEAVE WE- ARE
POPULATION IS PRIMARILY-
HISPANIC FARM WORKER. WE HAVE
LOW GROWTH THERE'S A FEW WAYS
TO RAISE FUNDS IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY BUT- WE DON'T THINK
OUR STRUGGLES ARE THAT UNIQUE
TO US THEIR SHARED BY MOST
CITIES IN OUR AREA WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE FACT THAT WE
DID. HAVE A MAJOR EFFORT
UNDERTAKEN TO TRY TO RISE ABOVE
OUR POVERTY. ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO IN CREATING THIS.
REGIONAL SPORTS AND RECREATION
FACILITY IN AN OLD ABANDONED
PACKING HOMES. AND AT THE SAME
TIME WE DID DOWNTOWN
IMPROVEMENTS TRYING TO INVITE.
PEOPLE BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITY-
FOR VARIOUS REASONS THIS MAJOR
EFFORT. WAS DID FAIL- SOME OF
THEM ARE CALDERON WEAKNESSES
AND SOME OF THEM WERE THINGS
LIKE THE GREAT RECESSION THAT
HIT OUR AREA VERY HARD AND WE
WERE A LONG TIME CLIMBING OUT
OF. OF THE RE SENDING A
REDEVELOPMENT WHICH WE HAD
RELIED UPON AND THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT WERE SOMEONE OUT OF
OUR CONTROL BUT IT LEFT US WITH
A BIG HOLE ULTIMATELY- WHICH WE
HAVE ADMITTED TO IN OUR GENERAL
FUND. AND I BELIEVE MADE THE
RIGHT DECISION IN. FORGIVING
ORLEANS TO OURSELVES SO THAT WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD WE BELIEVE
THAT WAS THE RIGHT DECISION WE
HAVE OTHER HELLO THAT WE'VE HAD
TO. PAY BACK ON SOME GRANTS
THAT WERE DEEMED BY THE STATE
TO BE. NOT PROPERLY
ADMINISTERED AND WE HAVE WORKED
THROUGH THOSE ISSUES AS WELL
AND MAYES SETTLEMENTS ARE A
REALLY CLOSE TO SETTLING WITH.
IN AND ALL OF THOSE INSTANCES
SO WE FEEL LIKE WE HAVE. TAKEN
THE STEPS WE NEED TO CLIMB OUT
OF THIS SITUATION WE HAVE
MANAGED TO AVOID BANKRUPTCY
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS IT'S
BEEN HARD WORK WE'VE DONE.
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE MADE CUTS
TO THE BONE WE HAVE RAISED
REVENUES THROUGH A ONE CENT
SALES TAX THAT WE WERE.
SUCCESSFUL IN PASSING. ON BUT
WE ARE A POOR COMMUNITY AND
THERE'S LIMITS TO REVENUES THAT
WE CAN REYES AND THERE'S LIMITS
TO SERVICES THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
SO BUT WE FEEL WE MOVED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION WE DON'T
DISPUTE A LOT OF YOU KNOW THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT NECESSARILY
BUT WE DO THINK THAT THAT V. I
REQUEST LETTER DOES NOT
ACCURATELY REFLECT OUR CURRENT
SITUATION AND EFFORTS THAT WE
HAVE MADE. THE PAST WE THINK
WE'VE OVERCOME BUT WE HAVE MANY
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FUTURE WE
HAVE MANY NEEDS FOR THE FUTURE
THAT WE DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MEET SO WE'RE STILL IN
A PRECARIOUS SITUATION. FOR
EXAMPLE OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A BIG CONCERN
FOR US THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED
A NEW WATER TREATMENT PLANT FOR
EXAMPLE AND WE HAVE NO WAY TO
FIND IT- STIGMA IS EVEN A BIG
BURDEN WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO. PAY FOR PLANS THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY HURT OUR AG ECONOMY
AND THOSE ARE ON CITY FINANCES.
SO IT'S THINGS LIKE THIS OF
DESERT AREA STRUCK THE SHOWING
WITH ADEQUATELY STAFFING PUBLIC
SAFETY DEPARTMENTS. WE DO THE
BEST WE CAN WE OUT OF NECESSITY
COMBINED POLICE AND FIRE AND
CROSS TRAIN THOSE OFFICERS JUST
SO THAT WE COULD HANDLE THESE
ISSUES- I MEAN WE WELCOME AT
AUDIT IF IT CAN GIVE US ANY ANY
IDEAS ON HOW TO DO THINGS
BETTER THANK GOD I THINK-
THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE HEAR
ABOUT AS WELL AS WE FIND BEST
PRACTICES. SO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S LOOKED AT A NUMBER OF
CITIES ALREADY UNDER THE HIGH
RISK SO PERHAPS IT. IDEAS THERE
THAT MIGHT BENEFIT THE CITY OF
LINDSAY AND ONE OF THE THINGS
ABOUT HAVING AN AUDITOR GOODWIN
IS LOOK AT SEE WHAT CITY OF
LINDSAY FOR INSTANCE IN THIS
CASE IS DOING SAYING OUR FAXES
MADE ANOTHER SMALL CITY OR CITY
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE ACTUAL
SOMETHING MAYBE YOU MIGHT NOT
HAVE CONSIDERED OR SOME OTHER
FINANCE MECHANISM. HELPED A OUT.
SO I THINK THAT'S THE SCOPE AND-
IF YOU WANT TO HONOR WE HOPE
CAN GET SOME OUT OF WE DO THINK.
A YOU FROM NOW. YOU'LL SEE SOME
VERY DIFFERENT THINGS BECAUSE
WE HAVE PUT A LOT OF THINGS IN
PLACE. THANK YOU. ALRGHT LET
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
FOR MEMBERS ON THE DíAS CENTER
MORLOCK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MAYOR THANKS FOR COMING. THANK
YOU AND YOU SAID IT WAS PAM
CAMILLA CAMPBELL CAMPBELL THANK
YOU. THERE ARE A FEW CITIES ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY- I HAVE
REVIEWED YOUR KAFIRS. AND JUST
DID A SIMPLE METRIC AND- THE
STATE AUDITOR HAS HER OWN DEEP
DIVE SHE LOOKS AT ABOUT TEN
CRITERIA I ONLY LOOK AT ONE-
AND THAT IS YOUR OWN RESTRICTED
NEXT POSITION WHICH CURRENTLY
IS A DEFICIT- BUT I DIVIDE THAT
BY YOUR POPULATION. AND OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO CITIES-
YOUR IN- THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE. THAT'S FOR YOUR
RANK TO THE OTHER CITIES AT
TODAY THE OTHER FOUR ARE
ACTUALLY IN WORSE SHAPE. THAN
YOU ARE BASED ON MY METRICS.
BLYTH IS AT THREE SEVENTY SIX
WEST COVINA IS A. FOUR FOUR
FIVE EL SERENO IS A FOUR FIVE
FOUR AND THEN GABRIEL IS A FOUR
FIVE FIVE. SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
CITIES. IN YOUR POSITION AND
WORSE AND SO YOU CAN LOOK AT
ALL THE OTHER CITIES AND HOW
THEY RANK ON MY WEBSITE. BUT
IT'S SYSTEMIC OF WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE STATE AND IT'S BEEN
FRUSTRATING FOR ME MISTER CHAIR
AS A SENATOR IN THE LEGISLATURE
THAT WERE SET NOT TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE SURPLUS.
IN OUR CITIES HAVE NO WAY OF
RAISING REVENUES YOU CAN'T
TOUCH THE PROPERTY TAX YOU
COULD TRY DO AN ASSESSMENT OR
PARTIAL TO ACT YOU CAN DO A
SALES TAX INCREASE BUT WE'VE
GOT CITIES COMING HERE ASKING
TO GO WELL BEYOND THE 2% THAT.
WE CAP THE MAT SO- THE DESERT
RELISHING TIMES FOR OUR CITIES
AND OUR COUNTIES- OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DON'T EVEN GET
ME STARTED ON THE NINE HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BUT- I'M JUST CURIOUS AS HOW-
HOW MANY OF THESE TYPES OF
AUDITS HAVE YOU DONE. HIGHER
YEARS FOR CITIES. IN A AND
WHAT'S BEEN THE WORK PRODUCT
THAT'S BEEN GIVEN TO THE CITY'S.
WELL WE'VE AUDITED AT LEAST
FOUR OR FIVE CITIES ARE VIA
THIS LOCAL HIGH RISK PROGRAM
THAT WHERE THAT WE'VE REQUESTED
AUTHORITY FROM THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE AS
I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
REMARKS THE FIRST TWO WE DID
WERE THE CITY OF HAMILTON CITY
MAY WOULD. THEN WE ALSO LOOKED
AT THE CITY OF MONTEBELLO AND
LYNN WORK SO WE AT LEAST FOUR
ON MY LAST- AND WE MAKE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE CITIES
WITH RESPECT TO- OPPORTUNITIES
TO RAISE REVENUE AREAS WHERE
THEY CAN CUT COSTS- LOOKING FOR
EFFICIENCIES HELPING THEM WITH
JUST. BASIC MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES INTERNAL CONTROLS THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTALS ARE AND NO
DISRESPECT TO THE C. ANY THE
CITY'S JUST GIVING THEM SOME
ADVICE FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE
STAFF THE TYPICALLY WORK ON
THESE AUDITS LIKE MR CHILDREN
ARE FISCAL EXPERTS FROM MY
OFFICE WHO EITHER WORK ON THE
AUDIT THAT WE DO ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS OF THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS. THEIR CPA'S- OR
THEY HAVE THAT TYPE OF A
BACKGROUND SO WE THINK WE
REALLY COULD PROVIDE A SERVICE
TO CITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK IF YOU SPOKE WITH THE
CITIES THAT WE'VE AUDITED THUS
FAR- NOBODY LOVES TO BE HAUNTED
THAT'S FOR SURE I'VE BEEN DOING
IT FOR. TWENTY YEARS AS THE
STATE AUDITOR AND NOBODY LIKES
US CALM BUT I THINK AFTER THE
FACT. WE CONDUCT THE WORK THEY
THINK FAIR AND REASONABLE AND
HAVE BEEN THEM SOME SOME FOOD
FOR THOUGHT AS AS THINGS THEY
CAN DO TO TRY TO. STRENGTHEN
THEIR FISCAL POSITION I'M
OPTIMISTIC ALL UP. USING BERMAN
ALL G. K. WITH CALL IT AN AUDIT.
AB CALL IT MAN COACHING. OR A
SYSTEM BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE NOT
SCHOLAR BEING I JUST GIVE YOU
AN EXAM MISTER CHAIR I DID THIS
PROCESS OF CALLING IN TRYING TO
GET KAFIRS FROM COUNTIES WHEN I
WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD
IN TWENTY TWELVE AND I CALLED
MODOC AND I SAID YOU'RE KAFFIR
IS NOT ON YOUR WEBSITE. COULD
YOU HAVE YOUR AUDITOR
CONTROLLER CALLED ME BACK AND
LET ME KNOW HOW I CAN OBTAIN A
COPY AND THE SECRETARY SAID
WELL YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
GIVE US A TOLL FREE NUMBER.
BECAUSE WE DON'T MAKE LONG
DISTANCE PHONE CALLS WERE
PROHIBITED. IS IT KIND OF GIVES
YOU A CLUE OF HOW TIED. THE
BUDGET WISE THERE'S LIKE ALL MY
GOODNESS SN'T YOU CAN EVEN PUT
A PDF ON YOUR WEBSITE. YOU CAN
EVEN CALL ME BACK UNLESS THEY
GIVE YOU AN EIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBER- SO THERE'S SOMETHING
GOING ON MISTER CHAIR. AND SO.
WE NEED TO HELP. AND SO I'M
WONDERING ARE YOU ALSO GOING TO
REVIEW THE MO USE FOR ALL THAT.
AB A BARGAINING UNIT
NEGOTIATIONS. I DON'T KNOW
SENATOR IF THAT IS A SPECIFIC
OBJECTIVE ACTIVELY MINISTER
TOLD HIM BUT WE DO LOOK AT. THE
EXPENDITURES AND AS THE MAYOR
INDICATED THIS IS A CITY THAT
HAS HAD TO. COMBINED POLICE AND
FIRE SO ESSENTIALLY AS WE
DESCRIBE IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS. THE POLICE OFFICERS
ARE SERVING AS POLICE OFFICERS
A FIRE BREAKS OUT THERE
SHIFTING GEARS IN THEIR
BECOMING. ESSENTIALLY
FIREFIGHTERS SO WE WOULD LOOK
AT SOME OF THAT. THE
CONSTRAINTS THAT THE CITY IS
UNDER WE HAVE LOOKED AT THAT
SITUATION. IN OTHER CITIES
PARTICULARLY SOME OF THE CITIES
THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED TODAY
WHERE. THERE HAVE BEEN- SALARY
INCREASES AND THERE HASN'T
REALLY BEEN A CONSIDERATION AS
TO HOW THOSE SALARY INCREASES
ARE GOING TO BE PAID FOR. AND
WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS ARE WITH
RESPECT TO RETIREMENT BENEFITS
AND CERTAINLY- PAP. IT'S NOT
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED IN THE
OBJECTIVES THAT I CAN SEE
QUICKLY- BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD LOOK. ANYWHERE IN
THE CITY IT STICK. THAT THAT
HELP. IS YOU'RE YOU'RE A GOT A
FEW OF THESE ARE. SO AND YOU
SHOULD BE DOING THE SAME THING
BUT RIGHT. I INTO THOUSAND SIX
I WORKED ON. NEGOTIATING WITH
OUR BARGAINING UNITS TO ADDRESS
OUR RETIREE MEDICAL LIABILITY
IT WAS. PRETTY COUNTY TIMES ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN.
AND ARE ANYA REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTION WAS JUST. LOST
SOUL LARGE WAS LIKE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY. MILLION A YEAR. AND
SO WE NEGOTIATED AND WE MADE
SOME MINOR CHANGES LIKE
INTEGRATE WITH MEDICARE- REDUCE
THE COLA IN A FEW. KEY THINGS
VERY SIMPLE BUT WE WERE ABLE TO
REDUCE THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY
BY 71% BY A BILLION DOLLARS.
AND IT REDUCED OUR AND REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTION DOWN TO LIKE A
HUNDRED- IS THE REASON LIKE A
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR. THEY
WANT IF PROVIDES BY THE TIME I
WAS SUPERVISOR SABLE WE LOSS IN
THE BANKRUPTCY DESPITE THAT
ONE- OPPORTUNITY. AND SO IT YOU
KNOW IF WE CAN PROVIDE THOSE
KINDS OF. A BENEFITS WERE YOU
CAN SAY HERE'S HERE'S OF YOU
CAN ACTUALLY CHANGE- I KNOW YOU
CAN'T CHANGE THE PENSION. YOU
KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT LAWSUITS IN
STATE SUPREME COURT ON THAT
BUT- BUT BOY IF WE TO WALK AWAY
FROM THESE ASSIGNMENTS WHERE WE
WERE ADDED SOME VERY. AND THEN
MAYBE WE NEED TO. DO SOME KIND
OF PUBLICATION TO ALL THE OTHER
CITIES. BECAUSE MISTER CHAIR
YEAH I KNOW WHAT THE LIKE
ESCONDIDO THEY HAD A THEY HAD A
WHOLE WORK STUDY SESSION FOR
THEIR CITY COUNCIL AND HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO MAKE THEIR
PENSION PAYMENT. YOU KNOW I'VE
I'VE GOT CITIES. THAT CAME OUT
TO CALPERS. WHEN I ASKED FOR
JUST SOME. ACTUARIAL DATA AND
THEY STARTED GIVING CALPERS
FINANCE ADMINISTRATIVE
COMMITTEE THE DATES THEY'D RUN
OUT OF CASH. AND HOW THEY
REDUCE THEIR POLICE DEPARTMENTS
IN THEIR FIRE DEPARTMENT. BY
25% WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE GOT WE
GOT A WHOLE STRUCTURE THAT IS
OUR SIT THERE ARE SUBSIDIARIES
BETTER ARE HAVING A DIFFICULT
TIME SO I WOULD MADAM MADAM
MAYOR I WOULD LOOK AT THIS AS
AN AUDIT I WOULD LOOK AT THIS
IS A VERY HELPFUL IF YOU WOULD
CALL IT AN AUDIT. PERCEPTION
BUT LITERALLY WERE FINDING BEST
PRACTICES THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN
OTHER HIGH LOOK AT THEIR
RESIDENT STATUS FROM THIS DATE.
TO PROVIDE SOME ASSISTANCE TO
YOU IN YOUR CITY MANAGER.
BECAUSE MISS HOW IS A
CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL YOU'RE
GONNA GET ONE OF THE BEST
TEAMS. COMING INTO YOUR CITY
THE REVIEWER KAFFIR. AND YOUR
BALANCE SHEET AND YOUR
CONTRACTS. AND I WILL I WILL I
WILL TELL YOU A BIT I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU BUT I WILL TELL
YOU'RE GOING TO GET. SOME REAL
VALUE ADDED FROM THAT EXERCISE
AND I WOULD NOT FEAR THAT
WOULD. EMBRACE THANK YOU
SENATOR LET ME ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
DíAS. HEARING AND SEEING NONE
LET'S GO TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SAYING MAN
LET ME ASK IF THE AUTHOR WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE HELLO MR TELL
CHILDREN SURE ONE MORE COMMON
GETTING BACK TO THE ANIMAL USE
WHEN WE WORK ON THE LOCAL HIGH
RISK AUDITS WE DO TYPICALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT THE BARGAINING
UNIT AGREEMENTS. AND THE REASON
WE DO THAT IS OBVIOUSLY THE
PERSONNEL COSTS THOSE ARE
REALLY SIGNIFICANT EXPENDITURES
FOR ALL THE CITIES. SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY HAVE.
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE COVERED BY
UNIONS WE WANT TO LOOK AT THOSE
FAMILY USE AND WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS. THE SALARIES
THAT ARE PAID TO THE
MISCELLANEOUS EMPLOYEES PUBLIC
SAFETY EMPLOYEES IN A
PARTICULAR WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
PENSION BENEFIT BECAUSE WHAT WE
FIND SOME SKIS. THERE WAS A
TIME WHEN. HE WAS ACTUALLY
MAKING THE EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTION TO PENSION COSTS
WE WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT. THE
OTHER THING IS THE- THESE HAVE.
RETIREMENT FOR WAS SOME CITIES
FOR. EVEN FOR MISCELLANEOUS
EMPLOYEES IT'S TWO POINT SEVEN
AT FIFTY FIVE. FOR OTHERS IT'S
TOO AT FIFTY FIVE SO WE ALWAYS
LOOK AT THOSE ARGUED
AGREEMENTS. BECAUSE THOSE ARE
REALLY DRIVING SOME OF THE
COSTS THAT WERE SEEN. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I THINK THAT WAS OUR
LOWS. OF WILL OKAY WELL I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THERE WAS A STYLE
DRIFTED JUJU DRIFTED FROM YOUR
CORE. RESPONSIBILITIES WITH THE
SPORTS. CENTER BUT THAT'S
PASSED SO NOW WE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO. RUN FREE HOW WE DID
IT WE PAID A LOT OF MONEY FOR
REALLY GREAT RECREATION
DEPARTMENT YEAH. OKAY SO WITH
THAT MSTER CHAIR WITHOUT FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. CAN YOU
HAVE A MOTION. TO APPROVE- ITEM
TWENTY TWENTY DASH ZERO FOUR
CITY LYNSEY. MOVE I CENTER
MORLOCK SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL- MISTER
SECRETARY KALRA. THE MOTION IS
TO APPROVE ATER REQUEST NUMBER
TWENTY TWENTY DASH EIGHT OH
FOR- HIGH RISK LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY AUDIT PROGRAM BY FOR THE
CITY OF LINZ THE REQUESTED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS HI. SALAS HI
BOERNER HORVATH. GEN PATTERSON
RUBIO RUBIO I'D VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD WOULD I. SENATOR ROTH.
GORGEOUS GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG
MORNING. MORE A LOT MORE LIKE
AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE OKAY
WELL THAT OPEN A- THAT ITEM
WILL BE HELD OPEN SO OTHER
MEMBERS CAN ADD ON RIGHT THIS
TIME I BELIEVE WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY HERE WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE OH SIX
STATEWIDE HOMELESSNESS FUNDING
ABBAS KILEY WHEN YOU'RE READY
TO BEGIN. PLEASE. HI HOW ARE
YOU. DOING ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SAID
EXCEPT FOR GERMANY JAPAN CHINA
AND THE UNITED STATES ITSELF
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE PRODUCES
MORE WEALTH THAN EVERY COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD YET ON ANY GIVEN
NIGHT AT LEAST A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND OF OUR PEOPLE ARE
HOMELESS MANY OF THEM VETERANS
MANY OF THEM CHILDREN. OF THE
FIVE CITIES IN THE COUNTRY WITH
THE WORST HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM
FOR OUR IN CALIFORNIA IN
201-810-0040 SEVEN HOMELESS
PEOPLE DIED ON THE STREETS OF
LOS ANGELES TWICE AS MANY. AS
JUST A FEW YEARS EARLIER. IN
HIS STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
GOVERNOR NEW SUMMER RIGHTLY
CALLED OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
A DISGRACE. AND IT'S GETTING
WORSE WELL HOMELESSNESS
DECLINED IN MOST STATES OVER
THE PAST YEAR THEY WANT MORE
THAN 16% IN CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
TWENTY THOUSAND MORE
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT A HOME.
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNOR.
TOTAL STATE FUNDING ACROSS
MULTIPLE AGENCIES HAS GROWN TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE PAST TWO YEARS ALONE WITH
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION. PROPOSED THIS YEAR.
NOW GOVERNOR NEWSOME DESERVES
CREDIT FOR FACING THIS CRISIS
WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY IT
DEMANDS. BUT WE CANNOT WAIT
MONEY SPENT WITH PEOPLE HELPED
THAT'S NEITHER PRUDENT NOR
COMPASSIONATE. A RECENT REPORT
BY THE NONPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST WARNS THAT NEW FUNDING
COULD QUICKLY DISSIPATEWITHOUT%
DEMONSTRATING MUCH PROGRESS IT
INVESTMENTS ARE MADE WITHOUT A
CLEAR PLAN. THE REPORT
CONCLUDES THAT WITHOUT DATA AS
GUIDEPOSTS SPENDING IS LESS
LIKELY TO MAKE A MEANINGFUL
ONGOING IMPACT ON THE STATE'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. MISTER
CHAIR THE GOVERNOR UNDERSTANDS
THAT WE NEED TO DO BETTER THAT
WE NEED AN EVIDENCE BASED
STRATEGY THAT'S WHY HE
EXPLICITLY CALLED FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE AUDIT IN HIS
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS. IN
ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
HOMELESSNESS TASK FORCE LED BY
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG LA COUNTY SUPERVISOR
MARK LUCE GOOD RITAM RIDLEY
THOMAS MADE THE SAME POINT. ITS
REPORT CONCLUDES THAT IN ORDER
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THE
STATE SHOULD WORK IN TANDEM
WITH COUNTIES TO ENSURE THAT
EXISTING FUNDING. ALIGNS WITH
THE STATE'S GOALS TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO TREATMENT. TO GUIDE
ANY ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS WE
NEED TO ASK THE BASIC YET
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS. WHERE ARE
THESE DOLLARS GOING HOW ARE
THEY BEING SPENT AND WHAT
OUTCOMES ARE WE ACHIEVING.
THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS I SEEK
TO ANSWER IN THIS REQUEST FOR A
STATE WIDE ON IT OF
HOMELESSNESS SPENDING TO HELP
US BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
AND IS NOT WORKING IN OUR USE
OF EXISTING RESOURCES NOTE WHAT
IS IT. IS NOT THERE'S A LOT
TEMAS I'M SURE BEING DONE THAT
ARE WORKING QUITE WELL AND WE
WANT TO IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE
ARE. SO WE CAN DO MORE OF THEM.
THE AUDIT ONE SURE THAT
SPENDING IS TRACKED AND RESULTS
ARE MEASURED TO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE. THE
MOST EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES IT'LL
HELP US. TO MEASURE PROGRESS IN
THE WAY THE MAPS. HELPING OUR
FELLOW CALIFORNIANS ARE
CONSTITUENTS. TRANSITION OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS. OR AVOIDED
ALTOGETHER. THIS PROPOSAL HAS
OVERWHELMING PUBLIC SUPPORT.
THE US THE SCHWARZENEGGER
INSTITUTE AND PRICE SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC CALL UPON THE SEA. JUST
CONDUCTED A POLL THAT TESTED
THIS SPECIFIC AUDIT REQUEST.
EIGHTY SEVEN POINT 5% OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE IN SUPPORT.
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE POINT 5%
THAT'S WELL ABOVE ANY OTHER
PROPOSAL AND FRANKLY A LEVEL OF
CONSENSUS RARELY SEEN IN
POLITICS. AND OF COURSE RECENT
SURVEYS CONSISTENTLY SHOW THAT
CALIFORNIANS YOU HOMELESSNESS
AS THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUE FACING THE STATE. IN
OTHER WORDS THIS PROPOSAL IS
WHAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
C. AS THE MOST PROMISING STEP
FORWARD FOR OUR STATE MOST
SERIOUS PROBLEM. THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS THIS AUDIT CAN
PROVIDE THE FOUNDATION FOR A
SMARTER AND MORE COMPASSIONATE
APPROACH THE HOMELESSNESS. AND
THE GOVERNOR UNDERSTANDS THAT
TOO AS HE SAID IN THE STATE OF
THE STATE MORE MONEY IS NOT
GOING TO SOLVE THIS ALONE WE
NEED REAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR HIGH THAT.
THANK YOU- MATTER MONITOR
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KILEY INDICATED THIS IS A AN
AUDIT OF HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY LOOKING AT
FUNDING AND THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THAT FUNDING SO WHAT HE HAS
ASKED US TO DO IS TO LOOK AT A
THREE YEAR WINDOW AS FAR AS THE
STATE BUDGET STARTING WITH
FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
A CONTINUING THROUGH NINETEEN
TWENTY LOOKING AT HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING INCLUDING ANY EMERGENCY
A PROVIDED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ALSO LOOKING AT APPROPRIATIONS
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED A
REFERENCED IN RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
AND A VARIETY OF THINGS HE'S
ASKING US IDENTIFY RESPONSIBLE
STATE AGENCIES LOCAL ENTITIES
THE FUNDING SOURCE OR COMPONENT
FOR EACH OF THOSE ENTITIES. THE
PERCENTAGE OF FUNDING THAT IS
BEING DIRECTLY OR PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON REDUCING THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION ARE THE
HOMELESS POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA IN ADDITION THE
DEPLOYMENT CLIMATE OF THESE
EMERGENCY AID FUND IT ARE THOSE
FUNDS ACHIEVING MEASURABLE
RESULTS CERTAINLY IN THE SHORT
TERM ALSO LOOKING AT A
SELECTION OF LOCAL AGENCIES GET
IT TO THE LOWER LEVEL IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE **** WAS
ACTUAL TO KILEY INDICATED
PREVENTING AT RISK IN THE- FROM
BE. HOME I LAST US TRY TO BUY
IN A TO MAKE COST POSIT COM AT
BY THE OF FUN. AND WHETHER OR
NOT THESE CAN BE TRACK AND CAN
BE PER SEEN TOWARDS BEAT
MEASURABLE GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN
A STE I'M. IN THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER WHETHER OR NOT THE STORE
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
DEFINING. THEIR MEASURES OF
SUCCESS WHETHER OR NOT FUNDING
IS ACTUALLY TIED TO OUTCOMES-
AND- FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
AND INDIVIDUALS AT RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS. A WHETHER OR
NOT THE STATE LOCAL ENTITIES
ARE ACTUALLY CALCULATING AND A-
ASSESSING AND EVALUATING COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE- THE
MEASURES THAT THEY'VE PUT INTO
PLACE TO TRY TO ADDRESS OTHER
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS OR THOSE
AT RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS- A
COUPLE OF OTHER OBJECTIVE SEIZE
ASSETS. IS THE TRANSPARENCY CAN
THE PUBLIC TRACK THESE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES BY A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT- SPECIFIC POPULATIONS
CAL WORKS FAMILY SENIORS YOUTH
FOSTER YOUTH. UP FOLKS WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS AND OTHERS-
SUFFERING ARE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN ADDITION
MR KILEY IS ASKING US TO LOOK
AT STATE LOCAL ENTITIES AS FAR
AS COORDINATION. ARE WITH
RESPECT THE DECISION MAKING IS
THAT ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT
COORDINATION AND TRACKING OF
EXPENDITURES THAT OUR CURRENT
BOTH AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL. ARE THERE ANY IT
REDUNDANT IS THAT EXIST ON
EARTH TING. THE COORDINATED
RESPONSE THE EXPENDITURES AND
THEN AGAIN TYING BACK TO
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS A
DETERMINING WHETHER THESE
METRICS ARE ACKLES. ADEQUATE
EXCUSE ME TO MEASURE THE
SUCCESS OF EXPENDITURES NOT
ONLY TODAY BUT IN THE FUTURE
ARE THESE THE RIGHT MEASURES
THAT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE USING. TO
DETERMINE WHETHER NOT THE STATE
IS A CHEAP. THE GOAL OF
REDUCING AND- FULLY SOME
ELIMINATE HOMELESS CALIFORNIA
AND THEN HIS LAST QUESTION IS
ASKING FOR SUGGESTIONS. AND
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
NEED TO BE SOME LEGISLATIVE OR
EXECUTIVE POLICY CHANGES- TO
STRENGTHENED. CALIFORNIA'S
APPROACH TO ACHIEVING
MEASURABLE RESULTS WITH RESPECT
TO REDUCING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA THE BUDGET FOR THIS
AUDIT ABOUT THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED HOURS- THAT WOULD TAKE
US ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS TO
COMPLETE- WE COULD REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF TIME- IF WE PUT MORE
TEAMS. ARE ON THIS PARTICULAR
AUDIT REALLY WILL DEPEND UPON
HOW MANY ON IT'S THE COMMITTEE
APPROVED TODAY WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR ALTERNATE BACK TO YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM WATER LET'S GO
TO MOVE TO THE AFFECTED
AGENCIES. PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MAP UNDER THE SUN KEPT. MATT
BETTER ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION OF
DTS IS INVOLVEMENT HOMELESSNESS
BEGAN SEVEN WEEKS AGO WHEN THE
GOVERNOR ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY UNDER
THAT ODER DTS WAS DIRECTED TO
REFUSED STATE OWNED PROPERTY TO
IDENTIFY SITES. THE COULD BE
USED BY LOCAL PARTNERS FOR
SHORT TERM EMERGENCY SHELTER
FOOD NAG REVIEWED FAIRGROUNDS
OFSHE FED ASSIST BACON
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES CALTRANS
DEVELOPED A MODEL LEAST
TEMPLATE FOR ITS PROPERTY.
WE'VE IDENTIFIED TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX STATE OWNED
PROPERTIES MOSTLY CALTRANS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL
PARTNERS INTERESTED PROVIDING
EMERGENCY SHELTER. GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED THE AVAILABILITY THE
MAP ON FRIDAY. ADIDAS IS ALSO
PROVIDING NINETEEN I TRAVEL
TRAILERS TO LOCAL AGENCIES TO
ASSIST PROVIDING SHELTER OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER CALLS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS AND
REGULAR POSTING OF DATA
GOVERNOR STAY THE STATE LIKE
WAS EMPHASIZED. METRICS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MATCHING
RESOURCES TO RESULTS THAT'S
SOMETHING ALL OF US TAKE
SERIOUSLY- WITH RESPECT TO THE
AUTO REQUEST WE OFFER THE
FOLLOWING COMMENTS FIRST AND
FOREMOST WILL COOPERATE FULLY
WITH ANY AUDIT REQUEST BY THE
COMMITTEE THAT'S TRUE OF DTS
AND I THINK IT'S- TRUE THE
OTHER DEPARTMENTS HERE TODAY-
THAT SAID WE KNOW THAT WE JUST
START IMPLEMENTING THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER SEVEN WEEKS AGO
SO IT MAY BE. A LITTLE EARLY TO
ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
EFFORTS ANOTHER FACTOR TO
CONSIDER IS THAT THE BUDGET
PROCESS IS ALREADY UNDER WAY
BUDGET COMMITTEES ARE RIVER.
ARE REVIEWING ALL THE STATE'S
PLANS PRIORITIES WITH RESPECT
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING ASSEMBLY
SUB SIX HELD A HEARING TWO
WEEKS AGO ASSEMBLY JUST SUBS
WANT FOR LAST WEEK AND A SENATE
FULL BUDGET IS MEETING TOMORROW
ON THIS. UNFORTUNATELY IN ORDER
TO PROVE TODAY AS THE AUDITOR
INDICATE WOULD NOT BE READY IN
TIME TO INFORM THE IMPORTANT
BUDGET DECISIONS MADE BEING
MADE THIS YEAR- WITH RESPECT TO
THE ISSUES THE COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN HAVING A DISCUSSION ON
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING- DTS
FIRST EARNED ABOUT THIS REQUEST
FROM THESE LETTER A WEEK AGO.
ADEN ANOTHER REQUEST YEARS HAD
CONTACTED DTS A RIVER IN THIS
REQUEST. EXECUTIVE OR OR- SINCE
THE EXECUTIVE WAS. I ALSO.
WOULD LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO A
READ THE FULL SECTION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S STATE OF THE STATE
THAT I BELIEVE WAS QUOTED IN
PART. THE GOVERNOR- WAS. WELL
INTO HIS SPEECH AT THIS POINT.
SOME OF REQUIRE THE YEARS WHAT
HE SAID SOME OF RECOMMENDED A
LEGAL RIGHT TO SHELTER IT'S A
PROVOCATIVE IDEA WHICH FORCED
THE STATE TO EXPLORE THE LIMITS
OF WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
BE COMPELLED TO DO. RIGHT NOW
OUR IMPERATIVE MUST BE BRING
GOVERNMENTS TOGETHER AS WORKING
PARTNERS NOT SPARRING PARTNERS
IN A COURT OF LAW. SO INSTEAD
WE ARE PROPOSING STRICT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMPREHENSIVE
AUDITS AND A DO IT OR LOSE IT
POLICY TO HOLD LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RESPONSIBLE FOR
RESULTS TAKE ACTION OR LOSE
ACCESS TO THIS NEW FUNDING I
MENTION THIS ONLY TO NOTE THAT
THE ISSUE OF COMPREHENSIVE
AUDITS WAS REYES SPECIFICALLY
RESPECT WITH RESPECT TO STATE
AND LOCAL RELATIONS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
PLEASE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME I AM ERIC ROSE OKAY
AND THE ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. AS FAR AS I
UNDERSTAND- I'VE BEEN INVITED
TODAY TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF
UPDATE ON OUR ROLE IN THE- A
RECENT EXECUTIVE ORDER. SO PER
THE JANUARY NINE- TWENTY TWENTY
EXECUTIVE ORDER OFSHE BID
CONDUCTED AN INITIAL ASSESSMENT
OF THE APPROPRIATENESS AND
AVAILABILITY OF VACANT AND
DECOMMISSIONED HOSPITALS. AND
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES FOR USE
BY LOCAL PARTNERS ON A SHORT
TERM EMERGENCY BASIS. TO
PROVIDE SHELTER FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE HOMELESS. IN JANUARY
TEN AWESOMENESS OFSTED BEGAN
THE PROCESS TO IDENTIFY.
POTENTIAL CANDIDATES THAT MIGHT
BE AVAILABLE FOR THIS PURPOSE-
A JANUARY FOURTEEN ARCH BIDS
INITIAL ASSESSMENT WAS
COMPLETE. WITH FORTY TWO
POTENTIAL ADDED SITES IN
EIGHTEEN COUNTIES WERE
IDENTIFIED THAT HAVE ONE OR
MORE BUILDINGS THAT ARE EITHER
VACANT. OR WHOSE CURRENT USE
COULD NOT BE EASILY DETERMINED.
AND WE'RE STANDING BY- IN THE
EVENT UP FOR THE FOLLOW UP IS
NEEDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE SMELL TEST RUN THE PLACE
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE TARA BROUGHT US
DEPUTY SECRETARY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. MY COMMENTS ARE
SIMILAR TO THOSE OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM POSH PENDANT
FROM CAL TRANS WE WERE TASKED
TO THE SPECIFIC ASSESSMENT. OF
THE FAIRGROUNDS. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS- ALI MY
COMMENTS AT THAT AND JUST MAKE
MYSELF AVAILABLE IF THERE'S ANY
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS THANK.
THANK YOU PLEASE MISTER CHAIR
MY NAME IS JIM OF THE CHIEF
DIRECTOR AT CALTRANS IN HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT LET'S- RETURN IT BACK TO
MEMBERS ON THE DíAS FOR
QUESTIONS. RIGHT HEARING AND
SEEING ON THAT MEANS IT'S VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD WE DID TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES
ALREADY AN AGENDA ITEM- TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE ONE TWO AS
WELL. SO WITH THAT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FOR MEMBERS OF FROM THE DíAS
LET'S GO TO TURN TO. PUBLIC
COMMENTS. PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM. HI MR KILEY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- YES I JUST-
I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION- AND I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS RIGHT NOW THE
GOVERNOR HAS RECOGNIZED AS A
TOP PRIORITY- CALIFORNIA'S OF
ALL PARTY AFFILIATIONS
IDENTIFIED AS THE MOST PRESSING
ISSUE FACING THE STATE AND WHEN
IT COMES TO THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SPENDING MONEY AND SPUN
SPENDING AND EFFECTIVELY.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE THAT
REALLY MATTERS FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING WITH
HOMELESSNESS THAT CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH THAT CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TURNING YOUR
LIFE AROUND AND STARTING A
FAMILY IN PURSUING YOUR DREAMS
OR- YOU KNOW WITH THE RING TO
MENTAL ILLNESS OR DRUG
ADDICTION AND SO IF WE CAN HAVE
THE DATA THE WILL HELP US
IDENTIFY WHAT STRATEGIES ARE
WHAT. AND WHICH ONES ARTS YOU
CAN GET THAT HIGHEST IMPACT AND
DO THE MOST GOOD WITH THE FUNDS
WE HAVE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S WELL WORTH
THAT AT THE TIME OF THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE IT WOULD BE A
VERY VALUABLE TOOL TO INFORM
OUR POLICY MAKING FOR THE REST
OF IT THE ARMY ON BUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT. OR
THANK RISK KILEY. CAN I ASK MAY
ASK YOU A QUESTION AND I'M
SORRY TO GIVE YOU A HEADS UP ON
THIS BUT GIVEN THAT WE PASSED
TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE ONE TWO
ALREADY LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
HOMELESS SERVICES WHICH WE HAD
A DISCUSSION ABOUT- WOULD YOU
BE AMENABLE TO HOLDING YOUR
REQUEST OVER TO MAYBE THE NEXT
HEARING TO SEE WHAT WE
ASCERTAIN AND LEARN FROM THE
AUDIT THAT THIS COMMITTEES
ALREADY VOTED ON I MEAN HOW
QUICKLY ARE WE GONNA HAVE THE
RESULTS OF THAT ON IT. IT'LL BE
OVER OUR NEXT SCHEDULED HEARING
FOR J. LACK TENTATIVELY IS
PROPOSED FOR THE FIRST WEEK OF
AUGUST. BUT WE MAY HEAR. WE MAY
DO A HEARING- BEFORE THAT. OKAY
I'M AYE AYE THAT'S NOTIDEAL.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
AS A- WE ALL RECOGNIZE HIM AS
THE GOVERNMENT AND FACTLY
STATED THIS IS A VERY URGENT
MATTER AND WE'RE ALREADY GONNA
BE LOOKING AT- UP TO EIGHT
MONTHS POTENTIALLY FOR THE
AUDIT TO BE CONDUCTED- I WILL
SAY THAT. YOU KNOW I SUPPORT-
SOMEONE WILL READ THIS IS.
AUDIT REQUEST I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO YIELD USEFUL
INFORMATION BUT IT'S-
INFORMATION OF A VERY DIFFERENT
KIND- THAN THAT WHICH WERE
SEEKING WITH THIS REQUEST I
THAT IS LIMITED. TO THIS SEE.
IT I IS I. CONCERNED WITH
SPENDING AND I EVEN IF IT WERE
IT WOULD ONLY- EVEN POTENTIALLY
COVER ABOUT TWO PERCENT. OF THE
OVERALL SPENDING THAT TIME THIS
AUDIT WOULD LOOKING AT AND THAT
WOULD NOT BE SOME SORT OF
REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE WOULD
ONLY BE ONE. HI SO THAT.
FRIENDS I'D LOVE. THE
COMMITTEES. TODAY OF COURSE
FAT. IF I IN THE IN THE WISDOM
OF THE MEMBERS I'D THE VOTES
ARE NOT THERE AND YOU'D LIKE TO
TAKE IT UP. AT SOME POINT DOWN
THE LINE I'D BE VERY EAGER TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT. OKAY
YEAH I DON'T BELIEVE THE VOTES
ARE THERE FOR YOUR AUTO. SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BULLETIN WRAPS
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
MISTER REVERSES. THAT MAY
CHANGE- THE MIND OF SOME OF THE
MEMBERS ON THE DíAS. SO THIS
TIME WOULD YOU LIKE TO TABLE OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO. MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE MOTION WELL I MEAN I
WOULD LIKE TO GET FOLKS CAN'T
DEVOTE WE CAN ALWAYS REVISIT IT
UNDER CONSIDERATION IS THAT
RIGHT. THE RULES ARE DIFFERENT
LET ME CONSULT WITH. WHITE
RULES FOR THE TWO COMMITTEES
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE TWO HOUSES.
OKAY BUT YOU CAN ALWAYS.
RESUBMIT A LETTER. YES WHAT DO
WE DO THAT ONE WE DO ABOUT. I'D
I'D LIKE JUST TO. YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
DIFFERENT MEMBERS AND I THINK
THIS IS. AN URGENT MATTER AND
DIE. YOU KNOW I DON'T. I VERY
MUCH URGE A YES VOTE TODAY. AND
IF THINGS GO OTHERWISE THEN WE
CAN TAKE FROM THERE. ARE THANK
YOU. KILEY APPRECIATE THAT- YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE SCOPE IS.
VERY LARGE THE COST IS VERY
LARGE FOR THIS. THIS TIME I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT.
BUT I. NOT SAYING I WOULDN'T
SUPPORT IN THE FUTURE I DO WANT
TO SEE WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PREVIOUS
BUDGET INTO. TWENTY DASH ONE.
TWO AND FOUR BEYOND WHERE WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT. SAYING
THAT. AT THE FORMA BASIS. AS
WE- FOLLOW. I WITH THAT LET ME
ASK IF THERE'S A MOTION. FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY THOUGHT IT.
RIGHT MOVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
JAY SECOND BY MISTER MISTER
SECTOR COLOR. THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE OUR REQUEST TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE OH SIX
CONCERNING STATEWIDE
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY. SO
NUMBER SALAS. BOERNER HORVATH
NO BOERNER HORVATH NO GEN GEN
HI PATTERSON PERSON HI RUBIO.
VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD. SENATOR
ROTH. GORGEOUS BEEN DOLLARS
HERTZBERG. MINING. MORE LOCKED.
WIENER. OKAY THAT ITEMS ON CALL
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU.
WHERE THIS TIME WILL BE WILL
MOVING TO OUR LAST AGENDA ITEM.
THIS IS A CHEN ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWENTY DASH
ZERO FIVE CITY OF SAN GABRIEL.
AND OVER AGAIN WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION AND I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE CANCER TO OPEN
AGAIN. THAT'S CORRECT AGAIN
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THIS IS A NOT IT WE'RE ASKING
AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT THE CITY
OF SAN GABRIEL- OUR OUR OUR
STAFF WENT AND CONDUCTED AN
ASSESSMENT IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY NINETEEN- COMPLETED THAT
IT ASSESSMENT IN DECEMBER
SHARED THE RESULTS WITH THE
CITY. BUT CERTAINLY RECEIVE
FEEDBACK FROM THE CITY THAT
AGAIN IS CONTAINED IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT. WE PROVIDED TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- BUT I
WILL ASK MR CHILDREN TWO AGAIN
A VERY HIGH LEVEL. OVER THE
ISSUES WE IDENTIFIED THAT WE
BELIEVE ARE. SUPPORTS THE
COMMITTEE'S APPROVAL OF THE ART
REQUEST WE HAVE FOR YOU TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PLEASE
OKAY AGAIN FOR THE RIGHT MY
NAME IS MIKE TILTON I'M A
DEPUTY STATE AUTO. SO SINK
PEARL THE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
THAT WERE SEEN THERE REALLY
BOILS DOWN TO INSUFFICIENT
RESERVES IN CASH TO PAY FOR
THEIR ON GOING BILL AND- ALL.
FOR THEIR- WERE. BECAUSE
BASICALLY AREN'T SAN SAN
GABRIEL CHOATE N. AS IN TWO. IN
FOURTEEN. THEIR CITY K. OF. A
LAW. AND PART OF THE- AGREEMENT
WITHOUT LOANS THE CITY HAD TO
SET ASIDE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF ITS GENERAL FUND CASH AS
COLLATERAL FOR THE LOAN FOR TEN
YEARS. SO CONSEQUENTLY TODAY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF SAN
GABRIELS CASH. IS CURRENTLY NOT
AVAILABLE FOR SPENDING ON TOP
OF THAT OVER THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR YEARS SAN GABRIEL ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES. HAVE EXCEEDED
THEIR REVENUES WHICH AGAIN IS
PUTTING FURTHER STRESS ON THEIR
GENERAL FUND AS A RESULT OF
BOTH THE LOAN AND YOU DEFICIT
SPENDING SAN GABRIELS GENERAL
FUND RESERVES. DECLINE FROM A
POSITIVE TEN MILLION DOLLAR
BALANCE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN ALL THE WAY DOWN TO AN
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT IN. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. IN RESPONSE
TO. THESE FINANCIAL CONDITIONS
THE CITY'S EXTERNAL AUDITOR HAS
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE CITY'S
FINANCIAL CONDITION AND WITH
ITS CONSTITUENTS OUR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE AS A GOING CONCERN.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
CITY'S RESPONSE TO THAT IS THEY
ARE RELYING ON THE VOTERS TO
PASS. A NEW TAX MEASURE NEXT
MONTH AND ALSO RECEIVING
INCREASE REVENUE FROM A NEW
HOTEL THAT'S IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING BUILT. SO BASED ON THAT
WE LOOKED AT THE CITY'S
HISTORIC REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES AND WE PROJECTED
THOSE OUT INTO THE FUTURE FOR
THREE OR FOUR YEARS AND WHEN WE
DID THAT. WE ALSO FACTORED IN
SAN GABRIELS OWN TESTAMENTS OF
THE NEW REVENUE THAT THE SALES
TAX MEASURE WOULD GENERATE IF
IT ACTUALLY PASSES. IN THE NEW
HOTEL AND WHEN WE DID THAT. OUR
ESTIMATE SHOWS THAT THE CITY'S
GENERAL FUND WOULD STILL HAVE A
NEGATIVE RESERVE BALANCE IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. WE ALSO LOOK AT THE
CITY'S BUDGETING PROCESS SEES
AND BASICALLY WE FOUND THAT
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS THERE
BUDGETS HAVE AN OVERLY
OPTIMISTIC. AND THAT'S RESULTED
IN SIGNIFICANT REVENUE
SHORTFALLS AND- EXPENDITURE
OVERRUNS. THIS IS A QUICK
EXAMPLE THERE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUT DID INCLUDE PROJECTED
REVENUE OF SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FROM THE TAX
MEASURE THAT HASN'T EVEN PASSED
YOU. SO IF YOU'RE DE PASS. IT
LOOKS LIKELY THE CITY'S
EXPENSES ARE GOING TO WORK.
AGAIN EXPERTS REVENUES. AREA
FOR BERMAN THE COST ANOTHER
AREA THAT'S STE ON THIS CHIU
FUND. THEY HAVE AN UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITIES SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS CALPERS
PROJECTS AT THEIR ANNUAL
WRITTEN. REQUIRED CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THAT PLAN ARE GOING TO
INCREASE BY 30% OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS. IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE CITY HAS NOTHER
SIGNIFICANT UNFUNDED LIABILITY
FOR ITS POST EMPLOYMENT HEALTH
BENEFITS. AND THAT'S FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT
LIABILITIES ALSO INCREASING
BECAUSE THE CITY IS NOT FULLY
OF FUNDING. THE COST OF THOSE
BENEFITS. IN TERMS OF AUDIT
OBJECTIVES THAT THE AUDIT
ANALYSIS CONTAINS A NUMBER OF
OBJECTIVES BUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT
IT BOILS DOWN TO IS IF THE
AUDIT IS APPROVED WHAT WE'LL DO
IS EVALUATE SAN GABRIELS
CURRENT FINANCIAL CHALLENGES.
AND FINANCIAL CONDITION AND
ABILITY TO MEET ITS SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM OBLIGATIONS WHILE
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO ITS RESIDENTS. WE ALSO LIKE
TO IDENTIFY THE INVENTORY OF
CAUSES OF SAN GABRIELS
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES AND FIGURE
OUT WHETHER THE CITY. HAS
DEVELOPED AN ADEQUATE PLAN FOR
DRESSING THOSE CHALLENGES THE
THIRD THING THAT WE WANT TO
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS SAN GABRIELS
BUDGETING PROCESS SEAT. TO
FIGURE OUT IF THEY ARE
COMPLYING WITH BEST PRACTICES
AND IS A PART OF THAT WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THEIR PROCEDURES AN
UNDERLYING ASSUMPTIONS FOR
PROJECTING FUTURE REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES. TO REALLY
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
ARE RESULTING IN BALANCED
BUDGETS AND ACCURATE FINANCIAL
FORECASTS. WE ESTIMATE THAT THE
AUDIT WITH. TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED FORTY HOURS AND
PROBABLY WOULD TAKE ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS TO COMPLETE. THANK YOU
WELL IT'S GOING TO MOVE TO THE
AFFECTED CITIES PLEASE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS MARK
LAZARETTO AND THE CITY MANAGER
FOR THE CITY OF SAN GABRIEL-
KENNETH LEWIS OUR INTERIM
FINANCE DIRECTOR. I HAD SOME
PREPARED REMARKS THAT I WILL
SPARE YOU ALL FROM GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT YOU SPENT-
SITTING HERE TODAY PLEASE THINK
IT WILL GIVE ME A LITTLE CREDIT
FOR NOT GOING INTO THE DETAIL
THAT IT WOULD HAVE ALREADY GONE
INTO- I'LL TELL YU THAT I'VE
ONLY BEEN ON BOARD WITH THE
CITY FOR LESS OR A LITTLE. MORE
THAN TO JUST OVER TWO YEARS
WHEN I CAME INTO THE CITY I
FOUND OUT THAT THE- FINANCIAL
POSITION THAT THE CITY.
ADMINISTRATION WAS FOR TRYING
TO THE COUNCIL NICK ANY WAS
THERE NAY GREASE DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT THE ACTUAL YOUR CURRENT.
pEVERYTHING THAT HE SAID THIS IS
EXACT TROOP AND WHEN WE FOUND
THAT OUT- I INFORM THE COUNCIL
THE COMMUNITY AND SINCE THAT TO
BE THE CASE THE COUNCIL HAS
TAKE PRESTIGE STEPS TO. SIZE
ARE IS IT I'M CHEN YOUR- BECOME
X. OF FINANCE THE TRANCE. OF
MAKING SURE THE NEWS ARE BACK
HERE THE PROJECT. AND THERE
POINT I'M SORRY THE BE. AND
TECH BUT I NEED TO CRY HIS OPEN
FOR RECORD ON POINT. A AND I
TAKE PRIDE IN THIS BIG I'M WITH
FOR NINETEEN BUT- AND NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
TO OUR REVENUES. WERE PETER
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A SALES TAX
MEASURE THAT WAS ON THE NOT
CORRECT THAT WAS FOR THE SALE
LOW PRO. EIGHT POUNDS WE IS LAW
MONTH WHEN OUR HOUSE APPROVED
SAID. TECH IS ON FOR THIS MONTH
AND WE DON'T HAVE A THE- FUN
OUR CURRENT BUDGET FOR THAT ARE.
BUDGET IS BALANCED. I AM PROUD
TO SAY AS WELL WOULD PUT IN.
BACK OUR OUR RESERVE LAST. YEAR
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A DE. ONE
THE STATE. CONTACT US IN. WE
WERE ALREADY WORKING AND
STEALING BEST PRACTICES AND
PROCEDURES AND PROCESSES IN
ORDER TO HAVE THE INTERNAL
CONTROLS THAT BETTER CITIES
HAVE. A WERE INCREDIBLE CITY
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE INTERNAL
CONTROLS BECAUSE OF THE WORK
THAT HAS BEEN NEGLECTED OVER
THE YEARS. AND WE ARE PUTTING
THOSE INTO PLACE. EVERYTHING
THAT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
AUDITOR WERE ALREADY WORKING
ON. THE AUDITOR AS WAS
DISCUSSED IN IN DISCUSSIONS OF
CITIES BEFORE OURS WE LOOK AT
THIS AS A VERY COLLABORATIVE
COOPERAIVE PROCESS WE LOOK AT
THAT AS BEING A PARTNERSHIP.
EVERYTHING THAT- MISS HOW HIS
STATED ABOUT COMING AND GIVING
US MANAGEMENT COACHING IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD WELCOME
OUR ISSUES ONLY ONE OF TIMING
ARTS CITY COUNCIL IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE AUDIT TO. GIVE
US A CLEAN BILL OF HEALTH AND
ALSO TO FIND ANY AREAS WHERE WE
CAN GET BETTER. ON THE ISSUE
AGAIN IS ONLY TIMING I TELL YOU
WHY THAT IS A TIMING ISSUE AND
IT'S TWO FOLD. ONE IS BECAUSE
OF THAT LOAN THAT MR TILDEN
STATED- THAT IS IN FACT THE
CASE THAT WE HAVE A LOAN THAT'S
PUTTING A BURDEN ON OUR GENERAL
FUND. AND WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF REFINANCING THAT LOAN AS WE
SPEAK- WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
THE- STIGMA OF AN AUDIT EVEN
THOUGH IT'S MANAGEMENT COACHING
IT'S AN ODD- IN TERMS OF THE
LENDING WORLD. AND WE FEEL THAT
THAT WOULD. HINDER CANCER OF
REFI UP LOW TAKE. OFF OF OUR
GENERAL FOR. THE BIGGER REASON-
OR EQUALLY A BIG REASON IS THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON ALL OF THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THE
AUDITOR HAS. OUT OF WE A VERY
SMALL BUT MY SO. HAVE A SIX
MA'AM OF. IN A FIGHT DEPARTMENT.
AND HAVE BEEN SPENDING ALL OF
THEIR- GET READY A BUNCH
PROCESS THIS YEAR AS AS ADOPT
HIS NEW. IMPROVE. MOVED THE
REQUEST TO BE MOVED TO YOUR
AUGUST MEETING AT THAT TIME WE
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER OFF AND
AGAIN AS I SAID OUR COUNCIL IS
WELCOMING. THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
TO COME IN AND CONTINUE THAT
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE'VE HAD. AND
AT THAT TIME WE WOULD HAVE A
REFINANCE THE LOAN TAKING MORE
THAN SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AWAY
FROM OUR- GENERAL FUND DEFICIT.
AND THEN WE WILL HAVE INSTALLED
A MANY OF THE TEAM PRACTICES WE
FEEL THAT MISS HOW THIS. HAS
ALREADY IDENTIFIED AND WE
IDENTIFY BEFORE YOU CAME INTO
TOWN SO WITH THAT I WOULD REACH
ACTUALLY. IT NOT BE VOTED ON A
AS A- THAT IT BE PUT OFF. AND
WE CAN AFTER ALL MADE THAT I'M
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
LET ME TURN IT. MEMBERS ON THE
DIE FOR QUESTION. A CENTER MORE
LIKE PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER A
REPEAT. YOU KNOW. THE LAST BUT
BUT WORLD AND IS FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTH FIFTH POPS OUT OF FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO CITIES
TWENTY SEVEN FROM THE BOTTOM.
AND A WOULD THINK IT THE WAY
WOULD BE. IN A BY. I THINK WE
NEED TO HELP AND WE SHOULD GET
IN THERE SCHOOL AS WE CAN WITH
PERFECT. TEAM SO WHEN IT'S TIME
TO OPEN TO PROPER LEFT TO MAKE
THE MOTION THANK YOU MUCH CHAIR
THANK YOU RIGHT QUESTIONS FOR A
MEMBER OF THE DIE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO WOMAN RE PLAY YEAH IT
JUST. THAT YOU KNOW I. SO A
SEVERAL OF MY ARE IN THAT LIST
I YOU KNOW I WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER A SOME SOME. I A I SHARE
EARLIER HELD IS MY FOR
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I HAVE THE UP
MORE OF RESPECT AND COME IN THE
AUDITOR'S THIS IS NOT A GOTCHA
TYPE OF <c.cyan>0C A MY PIN IT'S</c>
NOT A TO COMMIT WHAT IT FOR ME.
IS TO ASSIST THOSE PEOPLE THAT
OR THOSE ORG AN ENTITY THAT
NEED THE SO FROM THE I. THAT
OFFICE IS A ME AND WHEN WE'VE
DONE AND WE RECEIVE THE AUDIT
REPORT IT'S ALWAYS WITH THE OF
WHAT TO DO. AND I YOU KNOW I
WILL MY SPORT IT'S NOT CITY I
KNOW THAT THE RUBIO. I'M THE
WHAT I WANT IS IT YOU NEED ANY
KIND SUPPORT OUTSIDE OF YOU
KNOW NINETY TWO COMMAND THE
CITY FOR X. THE I COMMEND YOU
FOR THE WHAT HOW FAR COME SINCE.
WHATEVER AN OFFER HELP I BUT
FOR ME TO BILLION FOR THAT HAVE
PROFESSIONALS LIKE THE I
AUDITOR'S ON TO YOU EVERY IN
ANYWAY THAT WE CAN. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FROM NUMBERS
ON A DIET HERE AND IN A THAT.
WE'LL TRY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
THE IN. GONNA BE IT IS JUST TRY
TO SOME OF THE PRESSURES AND OF
TIME. PERCENT SHE HASN'T OF
SAID AND PRESS OF SOME THAT YOU
CAN. ON WITH THE STATE ON AS
AND LIKE WE SAW PRETTY YOU KNOW
THIS IS HOPEFULLY. THE BEST AND
THINGS THAT MAYBE CAN SEE A
OTHER CITIES ACT COULD POSSIBLY
THE CITY OF SAN GABRIEL WELL SO
WITH THAT LET ME ASK FOR A
MOTION THOSE WERE BY SEN MORE
ON I'M SORRY LET ME ASK A
PUBLIC COMMENT. HEARING SAYING
NO PUBLIC. ATWATER WHICH LIKE
CLOSE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION SENATOR. LOCKED
WITH. SUBSTITUTE. A SUB TO
MOTION. ALL RIGHT FEDERAL DO A-
BOTH. SEC RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE
IT'D HAPPEN MAKE THE MOST AND
THE COMMITTEE DECIDES THERE%
SUBS TO MOTION IN SUBSIDY
MOTION IS THAT WE DO UNTIL
AUGUST AND LET THEM BRING BACK
I WAS THE MAYOR ANISE COUNCIL
IN A VERY SMALL CITY. A QUARTER
THE SIZE A SAYING DURING BUT
DURING BY TIME I KNOW. THE CHIU.
THAT THAT'S THAT SMALL CITIES.
OF THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT SIX
PEOPLE. LIKE A DREAM TRUE FOR
CITY OF A- THOUSAND BUT WE DID
HAVE THAT. SO THE FACT THAT
THEY LOOKING TO. THEIR THEIR
LOAN AND THEY ARE WORK ON THESE
I JUST WOULD HAVE THAT WE CAN.
IT OKAY UNTIL AUGUST SAYS OF
SUPER. TO TABLE THIS ITEM UNTIL.
OUR IS THERE A SECOND ON THE
OCEAN. ALL RIGHT SIR BY BEST.
CALL. THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE
ATER ONE TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE
HI RISK LOCAL AID OUGHT PROGRAM
CITY SAN GAY RIVER BY THE
AUDITOR. WITH AYE DEFERRAL
UNTIL AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY
CORRECT. SO THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE THE AUDIT IF HE GETS
APPROVED IS TO BRING IT BACK
FOR CONSIDERATION THE TABLE TO
TABLE THE MOTION IS ON THE
TABLE THE ITEM UNTIL UNTIL
AUGUST. UNTIL AUGUST. THE
CURRENT MOTION IT'S THE TABLE
THE AUTHOR REQUEST TWENTY
TWENTY DASH EIGHT OH FIVE THE
CITY OF SAN GABRIEL REQUESTED
BY THE STATE AUDITOR. THE
COMMITTEE WOULD RETAIN THE
MOTION UNTIL AUGUST. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS NO SOME MEMBER
SALAS NOW BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I GEN. GEN NOT
VOTING PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOW
RUBIO. RUBIO NOT VOTING VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOW WOULD. WHAT I
SENATOR BORDERS. I'M SORRY
SENATOR ROTH. BUT OKAY- CENTER
GONZALEZ. OKAY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. IS A SENATOR MINING.
MORNING HIGH MORAL MORE LIKE
NOW SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR
WINNER. SO A CALL THE ABSOLUTE.
SENATOR OFF. NON AS A MEMBER.
HELLO SENATE ROTH WELL ROTH I
BORDERS. CENTER. I'M JUST TO
THAT SERVICE. THEY BRING.
KICKOFF CENTER. THE. IF. OKAY.
HERTZBERG NOW. HEY THAT MOTION
FELL I'LL GO TO ME LET ME ASK
WHERE MOTION ON THE RIGHT AUDIT
WILL BY CENTER MORE LAW SECOND
BY SO ROBB I'M SIXTY CALL THE
ROLL. THIS MOTION IS TO A
AUTUMN REQUEST TWENTY TO DASH
OH FIVE. HIGH RISK LOCAL AGENCY
AUDIT PROGRAM CITY OF SAN
GABRIEL REQUESTED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
AYE. SALAS HI LEARN MORE ABOUT.
BOERNER HORVATH HI GEN. CHEN
NOT VOTING PATTERSON PATTERSON
HI RUBIO RUBIO I'D. VOTE HI
WOULD. SENATOR ROTH HI CENTER
ROCK HI BORDERS. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HIGH MINING MINING HI MORE LA
MOORLACH I. WIENER AYE. MOTION
CARRIES WILL THAT OVER FOR DISH
MEMBERS TO ON THANK YOU. OKAY
AT THIS TIME I WE'RE TO RETURN
BACK TO IN A CALL. THE ROLL ON
OPEN I DO WILL. CENTER HAS MOST
FOR ON. CRISTINA AS WHICH IS.
RESIDENT GEN I NUMBER FOR THIS
IS TWENTY TWO DASH ONE ONE
THREE THREE OF HAVING TO PARK
AND CON PRACTICES AGAIN LIFE SO
GOOD. OCEAN THANK YOU I'D LIKE
TO THINK MISTER CHAIR I LIKE TO
MAKE THE MOST TO RETAIN US A
MEMBER OR OUT A REQUEST THIRTY
OR MORE DO FOR HER TO WEAR WITH
THIS HUNTING. YOU WILL HAVE. TO
HEARING ASSEMBLY MEMBER UP. OUR
QUEST AND I AM CERTAINLY. APPLY
THE IF SHE WOULD TO CHANGE A
REQUEST TO THAT TIME THEN WE-
CHANGE THE SCOPE AND BACK AND
DISCUSS THAT. IF NEED BE LAST
WOULD LIKE TO. THE MOTION TO A
WAVE OF ANY OF. COMMITTEE WERE
THAT WERE PREVENT. US FROM HOW.
ALL RIGHT YOU THANK CENTER OF
THE MOTION BEFORE US IS TO HAVE
A VOTE ONLY HEARING IN THIRTY
OR MORE DAYS DURING. THAT TIME
ASSEMBLY GARCIA CAN REFER OUR
LAST MOST AS TO WHY COMMITTEE
RULES AND- ROLLED. THAT WOULD
PREVENT FROM. THAT'S THE MOST
BY. SOME GONZALO I WAS. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SO UP THE KALRA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI. SOUTH
I BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I JAN. GEN
VOTING PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOT
VOTING RUBIO RUBIO I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILL. WHAT I CENTER ROCK.
CENTER ROTH HI. FOR JUST AYE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HURTS.
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON AT
THIS TIME WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE
AGENDA LIST SO WE WILL GO BACK
AND CALL ABSENT MEMBERS. SO THE
FIRST ONE IS. RIGHT SO. I'M
CALL THE BOATS UNTIL SO THAT
YOUR- YES. CLOSE SO THE FIRST
THE WOOL OVER THE ROLE OPEN
WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR THE
ITEMS THAT TO ALLOW MEMBERS SAT
ON THE FIRST ONE IS THE WAVING
OF JOINT RULES THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN SO THAT WE CAN TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR OF A
STRUCTURE CALL THE ROLL
INDICATING THE JURORS BUT AGAIN
THE MOTION IS TO WAIVE
COMMITTEE WILL THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN IN ORDER TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR
BOERNER HORVATH. FOR ABOUT AYE
CHAN CHAN I WOULD. WHAT I
SENATOR MORLOCK MOORLACH AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE. RIGHT
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE MOTION
SIR PER THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OH THREE BY
SENATOR BELL TWENTY TWENTY ONE
OH EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ELEVEN. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OH
TWO CITY OF LIFE BY THE STATE
AUDITOR. TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OH
THREE CITY OF EL SERENO BY THE
STATE AUDITOR TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT OH SIX CITY OF WEST
COVINA BY THE STATE AUDITOR.
THE GERMANS VOTED BY-
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI GEN. GEN HI
WOOD. WOOD I. SENATOR MORLOCK
MOORLACH HI WIENER WIENER ON.
THE MOTION CARRIES. WE NOW MOVE
TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TEN THIS
IS TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE OF
TWO ALAMEDA FRESNO LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
REALIGNMENT FUNDING FUND
SPENDING- MISTER RECALLED. THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OH TO ALAMEDA FRESNO
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE REALIGNMENT FUND
SPENDING BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM
LONGER. SO MEMBER CHAD. SO
AMBER CHEN HI. SENATOR ROTH.
BARGES NO ON THE REPORT IS NOW
YOU'RE RIGHT YEAH THIRTY FIVE
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI
MORNING. AND SENATOR WINNER. WE
HAVE FIVE DID YOU GET THAT ONE
WHAT THE DIPLOMA MORE YEAH YEAH.
I GOT YOUR- ONE. MONEX THAT'S
ABOUT THE DOESN'T MUNNINGS.
MONIES I FELT MORE. MONEY ZERO
NINE ALSO. YES ABOUT THE- BUT
BUILT LIKE A REFRIGERATION TO
CHANGE MY VOTE FOR THE PAST-
ALMOST OF SO PLEASE. SO THAT GO
THROUGH IT ONCE MORE AND PLEASE
ANNOUNCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD
THIS MOTION WAS YOUR PROVIDER
QWEST TWENTY TWENTY ONE OR TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COM LONGER
I'LL JUST GO THROUGH THANKS BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS. HI
BOERNER HORVATH. OUR EVERY
NOTING JUST NOT ABSENT ONE OKAY
SO CHEN YELLOW CHANGE. FROM HI
TO FROM FROM EITHER NOT VOTING.
YEAH YEAH YEAH. THE BILL. THE
GENERAL. AND UNTIL. CORRECT CAN
CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF THE- OKAY
YEAH THE SERVICE THROUGH. BUT
IT DOESN'T. IN A DOZEN ON
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AJ. CENTER
MONNING I SEC THE SUN. TWENTY
TWENTY YEAH TWENTY TWENTY A
TWENTY. HEY WE ARE THAT THE
BOOK. IS THAT WHAT YOU CALL IT.
SO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME-ACCOUNTABILITY OR SO FOR TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE OH TWO. THIS IS
A VOTE ON THIS IS HOW WE HAVE
IT. WE HAVE A THE CHAIRMEN
SUMMER CELLS VOTING AYE
BOERNER HORVATH WE HAVE AS
EDUCATED AS MY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAD AS A NOT VOTING WHICH
DOESN'T CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF
THE VOTE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON IS NO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
RUBIO IS YES TO MY MEMBER
VOEPEL YES SOMEONE MEMBER WOULD
YES. ON THE SENATE SIDE SENATOR
ROTH WE HAVE IS VOTING I. AS
OUR BORDERS VOTING NO SENATOR
GONZALEZ YES CENTER HERTZBERG
GAS. CENTER MINING YES SIR MORE
LOCKED UP VOTING CENTER WIENER
AYE. JUST SO WE'RE ALL CLEAR
THE MOTION CARRIES THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
AGENDA ITEM. THE GENDER ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN TWENTY TWENTY
DASH ONE OH FOUR CALVARY
COLLEGE THE STRUCTURE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CAN WHAT WAS
THE MOTION YEAH I'M NOT. BUT
YEAH THE MOTION WAS TO- PROCEED
WITH THE AUDIT WAS CARRIED. FOR
THAT AUDIT NO JUST TO GET
OTHERWISE KNOWN. SO YEAH I'M
SORRY I THOUGHT YOU WERE ASKING
ABOUT. THE MOTION FOR TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE OH FOUR FOR.
THE CALIBRATED TO THE MOTION AT
THE TIME WAS MADE THAT. WE
WOULD DELAY THE AUDITOR LOOKING
AT THIS UNTIL AFTER JULY FIRST
A CONTINGENT UPON IT BEING
FUNDED IN THE STATE BUDGET. SO
THOSE WERE THE TWO MOTIONS.
WELL NOT FUNNY FOR ME NO NO NO
FUNDING THAT CALIBRATE THAT THE
ONLY COLLEGE CONTINUES IN THE
BUDGET BECAUSE OF THE- IT
DOESN'T. IT'S A MOOD VûI MOVE
POINT. THAT MAKES SENSE NOTE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT AGAIN. IN THE
DISCUSSIONS DURING THE HEARING
OR WANTED TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT IF THE AUDITOR WERE TO
PROCEED WITH THE AUDIT THE TWO
CONDITIONS BE MET ONE THAT IT
HAPPENED AFTER JULY FIRST WHICH
ALLOWS THIS HOUSE THE
DELIBERATION BETWEEN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES TO DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT THE ON MY COLLEGE COLLEGE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE FUNDING.
FUNDED IF IT IS FUNDED THEN THE
ODD IT WILL GO THROUGH IT'S NOT
FUNDED IT BECOMES A MOOT POINT
AND WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE THE
AUDITOR LOOK AT SOMETHING
THAT'S NO LONGER BEING FUNDED
BY. THE LEGISLATURE. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON. THE MOTION IS TO
APPROVE AUTUMN REQUEST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OH FOUR CALIBRATE
COLLEGE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA WITH THE INTENTION TO
START THE AUTO ON OR AFTER JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. AND
DEPENDENT ON FURTHER BUDGET
FUNDING OF CALIBRATE COLLEGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD ALL RIGHT
GEN I PATTERSON. PATTERSON I
WOULD. WOULD HI SENATOR ROBB.
SENATOR ROBB I'D FORGES. FOR
JUST HI GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HIGH MINING
MINING HI MOORLACH MOORLACH HI
WIENER WIENER HI. THAT MOTION
CARRIES A MOVING ON TO AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE OH SIX
STATEWIDE HOMELESSNESS FUNDING
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BOERNER HORVATH FOUND RUBIO.
YES IT'S TWENTY TWENTY ONE OH
SIX BY THE MEMBER KILEY NOT
PUTTING OKAY. SENATOR ROTH.
WHAT THE ROTH I. GORGEOUS
GORGEOUS I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG. MORE LACK MORE
LIKE I. I THINK. THIS IS I
THINK THERE MAY BE SOME
CONFUSION ON WHAT THIS ITEM IS
IT'S TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE OH
SIX STATEWIDE HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KILEY IS THAT. CORRECT WITH
EVERYONE. OKAY I DON'T THINK.
THAT'S RIGHT. WE HAVE COMPETING.
BILLS BECAUSE THE- SURE. THE
OTHER. ALRIGHT THAT WILL KEEP
OKAY THAT MOTION FAILS. I AM
MOVING ON TO. PLEASE CREATION
OF HONORED BY TWENTY TWENTY
THAT BUT I CAN READ WITH WITH
MEETING COMMITTEE. I KNEW WHAT
THE. MISTER SECRETARY. THE VOTE
STANDS WHERE. THREE EYES AND
THE REST ARE EITHER NOT VOTING
OR NOW FOR THE ASSEMBLY ON THE
SENATE SIDE WE HAVE. THREE EYES
AND FOR NOT VOTING. GOT A
MISTER CHEN- WIDE EYES EXCUSE
ME COMMISSION FOR THE J. LACK
ANYBODY CAN RESUBMIT A LETTER
FOR AN UPCOMING HEARING. SO
WHAT SHOULD YOU SPOKE WITH MADE
A MOTION TO RECONSIDER- ON. IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
MR CHEN TO BE REMOTE FIGURE
THIS HERE. NOW IN THE FUTURE NO.
SORT OF THE POINT. SAME HERE.
OKAY SO PURSUANT TO. THE JOINT
ROLES MR CHEN IS ASKING THAT
THIS AUDIT. THE REQUESTED. YOUR
MOTION IS TO ALLOW TO BE HEARD
AT A SUBSEQUENT HEARING CORRECT
OKAY. THIS. ONE OF THE FIVE
POINT POINT OF THIS WILL BE A
VOTE YEAH COULD YOU CLARIFY SO.
WE'RE NOT VOTING THAT WE WILL
WE'RE ONLY VOTING THAT WE WILL
HEAR THE ENTIRE THING AGAIN
WHAT WE DID TODAY AT A
SUBSEQUENT HEARING THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY. SO THE MOTION IS
TO ALLOW RECONSIDERATION LIKE
WE- BUT IT'S PURSUANT TO THE
JOINT ROLLING WE NAME IT'S
WHAT'S THE GENERAL. THIRTY
THREE THIRTY BE. A MOTION Y.
WILL READ THIRTY BE INTO THE
RECORD SO EVERYBODY'S CLEAR A
MOTION TO RECONSIDER A VOTE BY
WHICH AND I REQUEST THAT HAS
BEEN DEFEATED SHELBY IN ORDER
AND SHALL BE VOTED UPONAT THE
SAME. THE SAME MEETING. AND
SUCH A MOTION IF SUCH A MOTION
IS CARRIED BY A VOTE OF FOUR
MEMBERS FROM EACH HOUSE THE OUT
A REQUEST FOR EACH. WHICH
RECONSIDERATION HAS BEEN
GRANTED PURSUANT TO THIS
PARAGRAPH SHALL NOT BE HEARD
AGAIN UNTIL A SUBSEQUENT
MEETING OF THE COMMITTEE. SO
THAT'S A MOTION. ALL RIGHT SO
THERE'S A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHANNELS ARE SECONDS.
SECOND BY SENATOR ROBB. OKAY
MISTER ROTH IS CONCEDING THE
SECOND MOTION TO SENATOR
MORLOCK. FANTASTIC ALL RIGHT.
AB MR SURGERY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS- TO RECONSIDER AT A
SUBSEQUENT HEARING HOTTER QUEST
TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE OH SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AYE SALAS
HI BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HI GEN GEN HI
PATTERSON PATTERSON I RUBIO
RUBIO HI. VOEPEL. WOULD WOULD I
CENTER ROTH ROTH AYE FORGES
BORDERS HI GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HIGH
MORNING MONNING AYE MOORLACH
MOORLACH HI WIENER WIENER AYE
THE MOTION CARRIES ITS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
DASH ONE OH SEVEN DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL LEAD
CONTAMINATION CLEAN UP BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
HI GEN GEN I. CENTER MORE
LOCKED. CENTER MOORLACH I
CENTER WIENER WIENER AYE. THE
MOTION CARRIES. WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE OH
NINE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM FUNDING MY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BOERNER HORVATH
THE STRUCTURE CALL THE ROLL.
SOMEONE OUR CHEN. GEN I
PATTERSON PATTERSON I RUBIO.
WOULD WHAT I CENTER RAFI ROCK
HIGH WAGES ORDERS AYE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HIGH MINING MINING FIVE. YEAH
THAT MOTION CARRIES REMOVING TO
FILE ITEM AGENDA NUMBER FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY DASH ONE TWELVE
HOMELESS SERVICES COUNTY
CONTINUUM OF CARE LEAD AGENCIES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. SUMMER
CHEN GEN HI SOMEONE NUMBER
WOULD WOULD I SENATOR GORGEOUS
GORGEOUS HI GONZALEZ INSULTS HI
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI MORNING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH. MORE LIKE
NO WIENER. WIENER HI. RIGHT
THAT MOTION CARRIES. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY DASH ONE ONE FOR
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
PROGRAMS BY SENATOR BRADFORD MR
SECTOR CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD GEN I
PATTERSON PATTERSON HI SENATOR
ROBB. CENTER GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG. CENTER BRAD
ROBERTS HI. HERTZBERG AYE
MONNING. CENTER WINNER. CENTER
WINNER NOW. OKAY THAT MOTION
CARRIES. NOW WILL MOVE TO
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY DASH EIGHT OH
FIVE CITY OF SAN GABRIEL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN. SENATOR
GORGEOUS. CENTER BORDERS I.
OKAY NO. CORRECT I CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY DASH EIGHT OH FOUR CITY
OF LINDSEY THIS WAS
ADDITIONALLY ON THE AGENDA IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IT WAS
PULLED FROM CONSENT AND MOVED
TO THE REGULAR ITEMS TWENTY
TWENTY DASH IT'LL FOR CITY OF
LINDSAY CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ON SAN DIEGO. ON THE AND WE'RE
CALLING THAT WAS NEVER CLEAR
VOTED ON IT'S TOO MUCH TO MORE
SENATE-ROOM WE HAVE A. ONLY THE
FAVORITE OF MANY YEAH. WE HAVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OF THE PAST IN
THE ASSEMBLY HOW WE TO. AND
ABSENT MEMBERS ELSE ABSENT. FOR
CALLING UP SOME MEMBERS GRAY.
THANK THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURNER.
BURGER HI GEN GEN I. PATTERSON
I SENATOR ROTH CENTER ROTH AYE
FORGES OR JUST I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. CENTER
MONEY MORNING HI THAT MOTION
CARRIES. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MEMBERS. SHE SAID IT'S. MAY
HAVE BEEN THE ONE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR TODAY'S
HEARING OF SHE WAS A LONG AND
ROBUST HEARING. SO THANK YOU.
OF. THERE WERE. YEAH